THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON HIGHER
EDUCATION IS CALLED TO ORDER-
WOULD NOT SEEN- MEMBERS HERE
WILL WE WON'T WE'LL SKIP-
CALLING THE ROLE. SO WELCOME TO
THE HIGHER EDUCATION COMMITTEE
BILL HEARING WHETHER YOU ARE
HERE IN PERSON WATCHING
VIRTUALLY OR ON THE PHONE LINES
I'M GLAD YOU'VE JOINED US. I
WILL NOT GO OVER SOME KEY
ELEMENTS OF THE STRUCTURE OF
TODAY'S HEARING. DUE TO THE
ONGOING PANDEMIC WE'RE STILL
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE IN
IN THE HEARING. AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITOL BUILDING WE ARE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
PEOPLE PHYSICALLY PRESENT TO
OBSERVE. AND PARTICIPATE DURING
THIS HEARING. IF YOU'RE HERE IN
PERSON PLEASE NOTE THAT WILL
MASK ARE NO LONGER REQUIRED. THE
RECOMMENDED REGARDLESS OF YOUR
VACCINE STATUS. ID LIKE TO WEAR
A MASK AND DO NOT HAVE ONE
PLEASE NOTE THAT MASK ARE
AVAILABLE FREE OF CHARGE. AT THE
SECURITY CHECKPOINTSAT THE
ENTRANCE OF THE CAPITOL BUILDING
. WE HAVE A- HAVE A FEW
DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR WITNESS
TESTIMONY TODAY. IN PERSON AND
VIA THE PHONE LINES. IN PERSON
IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
ON A BILL. PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME I WOULD ASK THAT THE PUBLIC
NOT TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU
CAN EXIT THE HEARING WHEN SHE
FINISHED TESTIFYING A RETURN TO
YOUR SEAT. PLEASE RICHARD
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTINCT
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITAL INCLUDING LIMITING THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE ON THE ELEVATOR
TO THE INDICATED NUMBER ON THE
SIGNS POSTED BY THE ELEVATOR
DOORS. WE WILL ALSO BE USING THE
A. T. AND T. MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE. THROUGH WHICH ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC AND EXPRESS
OUR POSITION ON THE BILL. THERE
MAY BE A SLIGHT DELAYS SO AGAIN
I ASK ALL INVOLVED INVOLVED TO
REMAIN PATIENT. THE PUBLIC TOLL
FREE NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING. IS. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THE NUMBER ON THE
HIGHER EDUCATION ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV OR MONITOR SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO
DO SO AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOUR TESTIFYING ON. IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE. BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVE STREAM BROADCAST. AND YOUR
SMART DEVICE TO REDUCE THE SOUND
DISTORTION. PLEASE BE SURE TO
MUTE YOUR PHONE WHEN YOU'RE NOT
SPEAKING. YOU HAVE ANY PROBLEMS
WITH THE MODERATE PHONE SERVICE
PLEASE CALL THE COMMITTEE OFFICE. NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE
THREE NINE SIX OO. AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF WILL DO THEIR
BEST TO ASSIST YOU. PLEASE NOTE
THAT WE ARE ACCEPTING WRITTEN
TESTIMONY. THROUGH THE POSITION
LET LETTER PORTAL ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE.
ADDITIONALLY PLEASE NOTE THE
GUIDANCE FOR BILLS HEARD IN THIS
COMMITTEE IS TO ALLOW TESTIMONY
FROM TO LEAD WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT AND TO LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SPEAK FOR NO MORE
THAN TWO MINUTES EACH.
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS AND ENTITIES
THAT ARE NEITHER IN SUPPORT NOR
IN OPPOSITION WILL BE ALLOWED TO
GIVE TESTIMONY FOR NO MORE THAN
TWO MINUTES WHEN I CALLED FOR
TWEETERS. THE MEASURE HAS MORE
THAN TWO ENTITIES IN THE TWEENER
CATEGORY ONLY TWO WILL BE
ALLOWED TO SPEAK FOR TWO MINUTES
EACH. THANK YOU FOR BEARING WITH
US AS WE IMPLEMENT METHODS TO
CONTINUE TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA WHILE ALSO BEING
MINDFUL AND RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO RESPOND TO A
ROLL CALL ASK A QUESTION OR
PROVIDE COMMENT ASK OF YOU TO
RAISE YOUR HAND AND ACTIVATE
YOUR VOLUME BUTTON ON THE DIESS
MICROPHONE. FOR AUTHORS OF BILLS
TODAY EACH MEMBER PRESENTED
TODAY WILL PROVIDE AN OPENING
AND CLOSING STATEMENT.
ADDITIONALLY AS I PREVIOUSLY
SAID STATED YOUR LEAD WITNESS
WILL EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY. WE ORIGINALLY
HAD TWENTY SIX MEASURES ON THE
AGENDA TODAY HOWEVER THE
FOLLOWING MEASURES HAVE BEEN
PULLED FROM TODAY'S AGENDA. A.
B. TWENTY FOUR FIFTY SIX MR
MCCARTY FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN AND
A. B. TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY TWO
MAYES RUBIO FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO
. ADDITIONALLY THE FOLLOWING
THREE MEASURES ARE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDARS. AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN FILE ITEM FOURTEEN.
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY SIX FILE
ITEM TWENTY AND A. B. TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY SEVEN FILE ITEM
TWENTY SIX. THAT LEAVES TWENTY
ONE MEASURES TO BE PRESENTED.
MEASURES WILL BE TAKEN UP AND
FILE ORDER AND I WILL PRESENT MY
BILL LAST. IF THERE IS A QUORUM
I WOULD ASK PER SECOND. AS
PROMOTION BUT SAY NO QUORUM- WE
WILL GO TO- AB NINETEEN THIRTEEN
FILE ITEM FOR IT THIS TIME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN IF YOU ARE
HERE PLEASE COME FORWARD. AND
YOU MAY BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY
WHEN YOU ARE READY. THE SURE
MEDINA FIRST TIME IN YOUR
COMMITTEE WELCOME. GOOD TO HAVE
YOU HERE. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR. I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB NINETEEN
THIRTEEN A BILL THAT WOULD
ESTABLISH. THE LOS ANGELES
COMMITTEE COLLEGE DISTRICTS
CALIFORNIA CENTER FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE EDUCATION. AT WEST LA
COLLEGE. FIRST I'D LIKE TO THANK
THE CHAIR THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR WORKING SO HARD WITH US. AND
WE'RE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS-
WHICH BETTER ELABORATE THE
PURPOSE AND GOALS OF THIS BILL.
CALIFORNIA IS A LEADER IN
CLIMATE CHANGE MITIGATION AND
CLEAN ENERGY POLICY. WE'VE
SEVERAL AMBITIOUS DEADLINES SUCH
AS REDUCING OUR MISSIONS BY 40%
FROM NINETEEN NINETY LEVELS BY
TWENTY THIRTY. HOWEVER THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR I
STATED THAT WE ARE FAILING SHORT
OF THESE GOALS. ADDITIONALLY A
STATE BY PEARSON REVEALED THAT
88% OF ADULTS GLOBALLY FEEL THAT
SCHOOLS HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
TEACH STUDENTS ABOUT CLIMATE.
AND ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES 54%
FEEL UNQUALIFIED TO WORK IN A
CLEAN ENERGY JOB AND TO GET THE
PERCENT BELIEVE THAT IT'S THE
GOVERNMENT'S RESPONSIBILITY. TO
FUND THESE TRAININGS AB NINETEEN
THIRTEEN WILL HELP ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES BY CREATING. THE LACC DE
CALIFORNIA CENTER FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE EDUCATION THE CENTER WILL
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR CREATING A
BLUEPRINT FOR CLIMATE CHANGE
CURRICULA AT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WILL ALSO
PROVIDE SUPPLEMENTAL CLIMATE.
EDUCATION RESOURCES FOR K.
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION.
FINALLY IT WILL FACILITATE HANDS
ON JOB TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR GREEN JOBS. AND CAREERS. THE
CENTER WILL BE ESTABLISHED AT
WEST LA COLLEGE. WHICH IS
CURRENTLY THE ONLY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN THE STATE THAT OFFERS
A CLIMATE CHANGE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL STUDIES ASSOCIATES
DEGREE. WEST LOS ANGELES COLLEGE
IS PARTICULARLY RELEVANT.
BECAUSE OF ITS PROXIMITY TO THE
INGLEWOOD OIL FIELD THE LARGEST
URBAN OIL FIELD IN THE COUNTRY.
AND ONE OF THE LARGEST IN THE
WORLD AND IT'S HOME TO A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF LOW INCOME
STUDENTS OF COLOR WHO HAVE COME
FROM THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
MOST IMPACT. IMPACTED BY ADVERSE
CLIMATE CHANGE EXPERIENCES. IN
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE LOS ANGELES CITY COUNCIL
VOTED TO CLOSING WITH OILFIELD.
BY NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY SIX.
AS WE INTO THE PROCESS OF
PHASING OUT THIS FIELD. AND
OTHERS THE CENTER'S PURPOSE IS
GOING TO BECOME EVEN MORE.
EVIDENT THE CITY WILL PROVIDE
RESOURCES FOR PEOPLE
TRANSITIONING INTO CLEAN JOBS
SUSTAINABLE FUTURES. THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE SENATE THIS
PARTICULAR CAMPUS WILL ALLOW FOR
A MODEL FOR THE REST OF THE
STATE TO CONTINUE TO BUILD OUT.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY TODAY OUR
DOCTOR FRANCISCO RODRIGUEZ
CHANCER OF THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNICATORS. A DISTRICT IN JB
BOMB A CURRENT STUDENT AT WEST
LA COLLEGE. WELCOME DOCTOR
RODRIGUEZ. IT'S A GOOD AFTERNOON
. GERMANY NOT HONORABLE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU SOME
OF THEM ARE BRIAN FOR MONEY
TODAY TEN FOR ALL THREE NO TWO
ARE MEASURES THIS LEGISLATIVE
YEAR THANK YOU SO MUCH. FOR THE
RECORD I'M FRANCISCO TO THE
GUESTS CHANCELLOR OF THE LA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT I'M
HONORED TO JOIN YOU THIS
AFTERNOON REPRESENTING LACC THE
OF THE PROUD SPONSOR OF AB
NINETEEN THIRTEEN THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THE CRITICAL ISSUE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE EDUCATION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN SHARED IN
HIS OPENING REMARKS THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES THE CALIFORNIA
CENTER FOR CLIMATE CHANGE
EDUCATION THE FIRST OF ITS KIND
AT ANY COMMITTEE COLLEGE AS
EDUCATORS WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO HELP OUR
STUDENTS UNDERSTAND THE
IMMEDIACY OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
HOW THEY CAN CONTRIBUTE TO
SOLVING THIS GLOBAL CHALLENGE.BETTER UNDERSTANDING CLIMATE
CHANGE WILL HELP TO INCREASE
AWARENESS MODIFY BEHAVIORS. ARE
CURRENT AND NEXT GENERATION OF
WORKERS FOR GREEN SECTOR JOBS
AND CAREERS AND FOR THE
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP SO
ESSENTIAL TO ALTER THE IMPACTS
OF GLOBAL WARMING. CLIMATE
CHANGE EDUCATION. IS A
PARTICULAR TO COMMITTEE COLLEGE
STUDENTS THE MAJORITY OF WHOM
COME FROM PREDOMINATELY UNDER
RESOURCE TO COMMUNITIES
COMMITTEES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED AND
THE MOST VULNERABLE TO THE
EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE. LACC
THE 60% OF OUR STUDENT BODY COME
FROM LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND 53%
OF OUR L. A. C. CITY STUDENTS
LIVE AT OR BELOW THE POVERTY
LINE. IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
FOR STUDENTS TO UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF THEIR ROLE AS
ENVIRONMENTALLY CONSCIOUS
STUDENTS AND AS ADVOCATES FOR
CLEAN WATER AND CLEAN AIR WITHIN
THEIR OWN COMMUNITIES. CURRENTLY
WEST LOS ANGELES COLLEGE AS
NOTED IS THE ONLY COMMITTEE
COLLEGE THAT OFFERS A CLIMATE
CHANGE AND ENVIRONMENTAL STUDIES
ASSOCIATE OF ARTS DEGREE. AB
NINETEEN THIRTEEN AMPLIFIES THIS
DEGREE BY ESTABLISHING THE L. A.
C. CITY CALIFORNIA CENTER FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE EDUCATION AND
WITH COURSES BEING OFFERED
VIRTUALLY. THIS DEGREE WILL BE
MADE AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS
ACROSS THE STATE AND INDEED
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. AB NINETEEN
THIRTEEN ESTABLISHES. SH IN
SUMMARY A JOT A GREEN JOBS
WORKFORCE CENTER OPPORTUNITY FOR
STUDENTS TO ENGAGE IN WORK BASED
LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FACULTY TO
ENGAGE IN RESEARCH AND
CURRICULUM DEVELOPMENT THAT IT
BENEFITS THE ENTIRE SYSTEM.
PROMOTES EDUCATIONAL RESOURCES
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE AND
SUSTAINABILITY WITH REGIONAL
PARTNERS AND ESTABLISHES AN
EDUCATION RESOURCE CENTER ON
CLIMATE CHANGE FOR PRIMARY
SECONDARY AND POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. INSTITUTIONS PARTLY
WITH UC AND CSU FOR THESE
REASONS THE L. A. COUNTY COLLEGE
DISTRICT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB. NINETEEN
THIRTEEN. I UNDERSTAND THERE'S A
SECOND WITNESS ON THE PHONE LINE
CORRECT SO EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR
IF YOU'D PLEASE GO TO THE PHONE
LINE- FOR THE SECOND WITNESS-
MISTER MOM. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMUNITY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CHANCELLOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND I'M JB BON AND I'M
HONORED TO JOIN YOU THIS
AFTERNOON. AN ECOLOGY MAJOR AT
WEST LOS ANGELES COLLEGE I'M
HERE THE STUDENT IN SUPPORT OF
AB AB NINETEEN THIRTEEN WHAT TO
STOP US SINCE THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
CALIFORNIA CENTER FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE EDUCATION AT WEST LOS
ANGELES COLLEGE. TODAY ASK HOW
CAN WE BE USEFUL AND A WORLD OF
COLLECTING NATURAL THAT THE- MY
OWN ANSWER TO THE QUESTION
INVOLVED RETURNED TO EDUCATION.
I CHOSE WEST LOS ANGELES COLLEGE
SPECIFICALLY FOR PERSONAL KIND
QUITE PRIVATE PROGRAM WITHOUT
WHICH A NEURO DIVERGENT STUDENTS
LIKE MYSELF MAY NEVER HAVE THE
SUPPORT. OPPORTUNITY AND SUCCESS
IN HIGHER EDUCATION. THE WEST
LOS ANGELES CLIMATE CHANGE
PROGRAM FOSTERS A DIVERSE CROSS
SECTION OF THE LEARNERS FROM THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY. IT IS THE
CAMPUS NESTLED AMONG BOTH NATIVE
VEGETATION AND OMNIPRESENT
FOSSEL FUEL INFRASTRUCTURE.
PUTTING US FIRMLY AT THE CROSS
SECTION OF CLIMATE EDUCATION AND
CLIMATE JUST. MY COURT DEALING
WITH SCIENCE ETHICS AND SOLUTION
TO OUR- IMPACT ON EARTH'S SYSTEM
HAVE BEEN FOUND. IN FOURTEEN A
PATH TOWARDS GREATER SERVICE I
THINK PREPARE TO CONTINUE MY
STUDIES IN THE UC SYSTEM. I'M
INCREDIBLY THANKFUL FOR THIS
PROGRAM- THE CULTIVATED A DEEP
KNOWLEDGE AND PURPOSE IN THESE
COMPLICATED TIMES. BUT IT IS NOT
ENOUGH AB NINETEEN THIRTEEN WILL
STRENGTHEN THE WEST LOS ANGELES
COLLEGE OF EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM
MAKING IT AVAILABLE TO OTHER
STUDENTS. HE CAN CAREERS IN
GREEN TAX LAND RESTORATION AND
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO REIMAGINE
PUBLIC POLICY IN THE ENTER
BETWEEN. THIS IS NOT ONLY AN
OPPORTUNITY KNOCKING. IT IS IN
FACT A NECESSITY. ON A STATE NOT
LEVEL WE MUST TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE HISTORIC
HARMS WE HAVE INFLICTED AND PART
OF THAT ONUS IS EMPOWERING
STUDENTS LIKE ME WITH QUALITY
EDUCATION. SO WE CAN MEET THE
MOMENT. IF THAT WAS ONE OF LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT CALIFORNIA CENTER FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE EDUCATION WILL
PROVIDE THE FUNDING AND A CROSS
DISCIPLINARY EDUCATION. ON
CLIMATE SOLUTIONS FOR STUDENTS
ACROSS THE STATE ENABLING
CALIFORNIA TO SET THE PACE AND
LEAD BY EXAMPLE I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB NINETEEN THIRTEEN I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
JOIN YOU TODAY. THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. C. NINE EIGHTEEN TWO
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINE. YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO A AB
NINETEEN THIRTEEN UP PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. IN
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WILL
QUICKLY GIVE YOUR LINE NOT LINE
NUMBER OFFLINE AND PLACE IT BACK
IN THE QUEUE WILL BEGIN TODAY
WITH WIND OUT ONE FIFTY FOUR.
ONE THIRTY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN.
ONE MORE SHOT ONE THIRTY FOUR
REJECTED CHECKED BY AN OPTICIAN. WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE SEVENTY
ONE. SEVENTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE SEVENTY
ONE. MISTER CHAIR YOU'RE HEARING
ME RIGHT I CAN HEAR YOU THAT YEP
. NO- I JUST MINOR MODERATOR AYE
AYE I DID FORGET TO ASK FOR-
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE IN THE ROOM NAY HEARING
ROOM CASEY NINE ABOUT MODERATOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE LINE. OKAY WE WILL GO OUT
FOR SUPPORT FOR AB NINETEEN
THIRTEEN LINE ONE NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
SANTIAGO WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS IN SUPPORT
. THANK YOU ONE ONE FIFTY FOUR
YOU ARE OPEN. I WON FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THEY TOOK
THEMSELVES OUT OF Q. THERE'S NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME MISTER PARQUET NEITHER
IN SUPPORT NOR IN OPPOSITION.
ZACKS ALRIGHT ONE WATER. BILL IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
NINETEEN THIRTEEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NOBODY IS QUEUING UP OKAY-
ANY ANY TWEETERS. ON THIS BILL
IF. MISTER MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY TWEETERS ON THE LINE. NOBODY
HAS QUEUED UP OKAY THANK YOU I
WOULD LIKE COMMITTEE THAN ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
ARE EDUCATION IS THE KEY TO
UNLOCKING A LOT OF OUR FUTURE I
CAME FROM THE UNIVERSITY SETTING
AND WE PUT A LOT OF INCREDIBLE
ASSETS AND RESOURCES INTO MANY
LEVELS OF EDUCATION UCLA YOU SEE
OUR WE'VE GOT GREAT INSTITUTIONS
BUT WE OFTEN FORGET TO MAKE THE
SAME KIND OF INVESTMENTS AT THE
COMMUNICATOR LEVEL WHERE MOST
BLACK BROWN POINT INDIGENOUS
STUDENTS ARE LEARNING TO THE
OPPORTUNE FOR CALIFORNIA TO
ESTABLISH THE FIRST CENTER FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE EDUCATION AT A
COLLEGE. IN THE COMMUNICATIONS
DISTRICT THAT'S DIRECTLY%
IMPACTED BY THE ADVERSE EFFECTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE I THINK IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU- I WANT TO THANK
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THIS MEASURE FORWARD. AND
SEEKING TO ESTABLISH A CLIMATE
CHANGE CENTER. TO HELP AND
ASSIST THE ENTIRE SYSTEM.
PREPARES SKILLED WORK FORCES
CALIFORNIA TRANSITIONS. AWAY
FROM FUSEL FOR. FEW FOSSIL FUELS
AND TOWARDS GREEN ENERGY. SO
ONCE WE- I HAVE A QUORUM WILL
CALL FOR THE VOTE THANK YOU. AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN I BELIEVE
YOU HAVE A SECOND BILL. YEAH
EFFORTS INSIDE COME SEATED. I
HIT YOU TWICE ALL RIGHT. AND
THAT IS. A. B. TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE. YES SIR. THANK YOU
AGAIN MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE BUT BEFORE I BEGIN
I WANT TO THANK THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICATIONS OFFICE FOR
WORKING SO CLOSELY WITH US ON
THIS LEGISLATION WE'VE HAD A
NUMBER OF ENCOURAGING AND
THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATIONS AND
WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO REFINE THIS BILL-
BEYOND THIS HEARING I'M HERE
TODAY TODAY TO PRESENT A BILL
THAT WILL CREATE PIPELINES THE
QUALITY JOBS UPWARD MOBILITY AND
INCOME SECURITY FOR THOSE
EXITING INCARCERATION IN
ENTERING THE SCHOOL PIPELINE IN
A COMMUNICATIVE STRIX. THIS BILL
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE THE
HIGHER UP FROM CORRECTION TO
CAREER STATEMENT PILOT PROGRAM
IS INNOVATIVE. ACCORDING TO THE
BRENNAN CENTER FOR JUSTICE
UNEMPLOYMENT IS THE SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT INDICATOR OF
RECIDIVISM. DECIMATED THAT ONE
IN THREE ADULTS HAVE A CRIMINAL
RECORD IN UP 275% OF THOSE WITH
PAST JUSTICE SYSTEM INVOLVEMENT
ARE STILL UNEMPLOYED A YEAR
AFTER THE ACCIDENT CAR
SERRATION. MANY MORE UNDER
EMPLOYED EVEN IF THEY FIND JOBS
. ALMOST 67% UNEMPLOYED FIVE
YEARS AFTER EXITING
INCARCERATION. CONSIDERING THE
RATES OF UNEMPLOYMENT IS
POPULATION IT'S UNSURPRISING
THAT THE TWENTY NINETEEN REPORT
BY CDC ARE FROM THE 28% OF
CALIFORNIANS ON HOUSE POPULATION
REPORT HAVING RECENTLY BEEN
RELEASED. FROM INCARCERATION.
THE BARRIERS TO EMPLOYMENT FOR
JUSTICE INVOLVED INDIVIDUALS ARE
MANY. IN ADDITION THE TO THE
LEGAL CONSTRAINTS TO PREVENT
SOME PEOPLE FROM ENTERING
CERTAIN PROFESSIONS. PEOPLE
COMING FROM THE CAR SERRATION
ALSO FACE A STIGMA HELD STILL BY
EMPLOYERS. AGGRESSIVE BACKGROUND
CHECKS. AND OFTEN LACK
MARKETABLE TRAINING AND SKILLS.
FOR PEOPLE BECAUSE THESE FACTORS
ARE COMPOUNDED BY RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION THAT ALREADY
PERVADES AND OUR LABOR MARKET.
HOWEVER THE COST OF CAREER
TRAINING PROGRAMS CONTINUE TO
PREVENT MANY FROM TAKING FULL
ADVANTAGE OF THESE RESOURCES WE
HAVE A NUMBER OF STUDENTS WERE
PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED IN OUR
COMMUNICATIVE STRICT. THAT ARE
WORKING HARD TO SKILL UP TO
TRAIN UP AND TO FIND GAINFUL
EMPLOYMENT. BUT STILL AS YOU'RE
LEARNING THE COMMITTEE BECAUSE
SITTING THERE ARE NOT ENOUGH.
PROGRAMS TO PROVIDE A RELIABLE
FOR SOURCE OF FINANCIAL SUPPORT
. AND THE NEED FOR EFFECTIVE
REENTRY SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA
IS QUICKLY INCREASING. THE
HIGHER UP STARTED PROGRAM
PROPOSED IN THIS BILL MAYBE
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE WILL
PROVIDE A MEASURE OF FINANCIAL
STABILITY FOR JUSTICE INVOLVED
STUDENTS. WHO CAN DEDICATE THEIR
TIME TO EDUCATION AND CAREER
TRAINING WITHOUT SACRIFICING
THEIR BASIC NEEDS LIKE FOOD
HOUSING AND CHILDCARE. THE
HIGHER UPS TYPING WILL REIMBURSE
JUSTICE INVOLVES STUDENTS AT THE
RATE OF THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE
FOR EVERY HOUR THEY SPEND IN
CLASS TRAINING AND SKILLING UP.
AS A STIPULATION FOR RECEIVING
THE STAFF AND STUDENTS WILL BE
PARTICIPATING THE RISING
SCHOLARS NETWORKS AT THEIR
SCHOOL. THE RISING SCHOLARS
PROGRAM IS A DATA DRIVEN TESTED
APPROACH TO RE ENTRY IN THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM THAT PROVIDES
GUIDED ACADEMIC PATHWAYS. FOR
PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED STUDENTS
COUPLED WITH WRAPAROUND SERVICES
AND CAREER DEVELOPMENT.
ADDITIONALLY A LONG TERM
APPROACH. ROOTED IN CARE NOT
INCARCERATION AND REENTERED THE
REINTEGRATION. RE INTEGRATION
REDUCES RECIDIVISM INCREASES
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY. BY LINKING
THE HIGHER UPS TYPE INTO
EXISTING REENTRY SUPPORT OF
SERVICES. THAT FOLLOW STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT THEIR EDUCATIONAL
JOURNEY AND INTO THE WORKFORCE.
THIS POTENTIAL STATEMENT HAS
THE- HAS THE POTENTIAL TO IMPACT
COUNTLESS STUDENTS ACROSS OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM OR
PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED CAN ARE
LEAVING THE INCARCERATION
PIPELINE AND HEADED INTO THE
EDUCATION PIPELINE AND THEN INTO
OUR WORKFORCE PIPELINE. I'M
JOINED HERE TODAY AGAIN BY
CHANCELLOR FRANCISCO RODRIGUEZ
OF THE LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT A SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL BUT ALSO GREG FIDEL
THE POLICY DIRECTOR. AT INITIATE
JUSTICE. THANK YOU THIS MEMBER
BRIAN FOR YOUR- INCREDIBLE I
THINK OF CARE ON THIS ISSUE. AND
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP THANK YOU.
GERMANY NINE HONORABLE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE RECORD
I'M DOCTOR FRANCISCO TO THE
GUESTS CHANCE OF THE SENATE
COMMITTEE COLLEGE DISTRICT AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE I A
BILL THAT IS COSPONSORED BY THE
LA COMMITTEE COLORS DISTRICT AND
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN COLLABORATION
WITH LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SUPERVISOR HOLLY MITCHELL. AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
ESTABLISHES AS WAS NOTED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN A FIVE
YEAR HIRE A PILOT PROGRAM
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE COLLEGES CHANCES
OFFICE TO PROVIDE STIPENDS FOR
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS ENROLLED IN AN
EDUCATIONAL OR PROFESSIONAL
TRAINING PROGRAM ANY ONE OF THE
STATE'S COMMITTEE COLLEGES. THIS
BILL CREATES PIPELINES THE
QUALITY JOBS UPWARD ECONOMIC
MOBILITY OR AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
UNIVERSITY TRANSFER AND THROUGH
THE STIPENDS THE NECESSARY AND
STABILIZE IN INCOME SECURITY FOR
THOSE EXITING INCARCERATION.
FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS FACE MANY BARRIERS
IN ACQUIRING LONG TERM STABLE
EMPLOYMENT INCLUDING
DISCRIMINATORY HIRING PRACTICES
AND LIMITED ACCESS TO FULL TIME
WELL PAYING JOBS MANY EMPLOYERS
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES. USE
BACKGROUND CHECKS TO SCREEN FOR
APPLICANTS WITH CRIMINAL RECORDS
MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR JUSTICE
INVOLVED CALIFORNIANS TO GET A
FRESH START. IN ADDITION THE
RISING COSTS OF EDUCATION OR
CAREER TRAINING CONTINUES TO
PREVENT MANY FROM TAKING FULL
ADVANTAGE OF EXISTING RESOURCES
AND PROGRAMS. THE LOS SANTOS
COMMITTEE COLLEGE DISTRICT
EARLIER ROLES ABOUT A THOUSAND
SELF IDENTIFIED FORMERLY
INCARCERATED STUDENTS BUT WE
SUSPECT THIS NUMBER TO BE MUCH
HIGHER. FORMERLY INCARCERATED
STUDENTS HAVE ADDITIONAL HURDLES
IN COMPLETING THEIR EDUCATION
STABLE EMPLOYMENT AND THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR UPWARD ECONOMIC
MOBILITY ARE KEYS TO
REHABILITATION AND TO REDUCING
RECIDIVISM. L. A. C. CITY HAS
ESTABLISHED SEVERAL INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS FOR THIS POPULATION OF
STUDENTS AN EXAMPLE IS A
LOGISTICS EDUCATION AND CAREER
PROGRAM A PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF
PROBATION. AND UPS THIS PROGRAM
PROVIDES YOUTH L. A. COUNTY
JUVENILE PROBATION CAMPS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EARN A
CERTIFICATE IN LEADERSHIP IN
GLOBAL LOGISTICS SKILLS. EMILY
UPON RELEASE THESE STUDENTS ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR EMPLOYMENT WITH UPS
APPROXIMATE HUNDRED TWENTY YOU
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED THIS
PROGRAM HAD BEEN HIRED BY U. P.
S. IN THE LAST THREE YEARS. AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE ENABLES
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
BETTER SERVE JUSTICE INVOLVED
INDIVIDUALS BY ESTABLISHING A
FIVE YEAR EDUCATIONAL STIPEND
PILOT PROGRAM. WITH ALL THE
WRAPAROUND SUPPORT SERVICES THAT
ARE NEEDED FOR STUDENT SUCCESS
THIS POLYENABLES COMMITTEE
COLLEGES TO DEMONSTRATE PROOF OF
CONCEPT AND PROVIDE STUDENTS A
MEASURE OF FINANCIAL STABILITY
WHILE THEY ARE ROLLED IN A
DEGREE SEEKING A CREDENTIAL
PROGRAM. AT ANY CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE COLLEGE AB. TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE IS A PRUDENT
INVESTMENT FOR THE STATE THAT
GOES BEYOND PROVIDING
OPPORTUNITY FOR A VULNERABLE.
POPULATION IT HAS THE ADDED
POTENTIAL TO LOWER UNEMPLOYMENT
STRENGTH IN THE ECONOMY AND
REDUCE THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE CAR SERRATION AND RECIDIVISM
FOR THESE REASONS THE LOS ANGE
COMMITTEE COLLEGE DISTRICT. AND
IT LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS URGES YOUR AYE VOTE
ON AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU CHANCELLOR ARE YOU AT
THE SECOND- SUPPORT THE WITNESS
GO AHEAD YES SIR THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS GREG FIDEL AND I AM THE
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR INITIATE
JUSTICE. WE WORK TO END MASS
INCARCERATION BY ACTIVATING THE
POLITICAL POWER OF THE PEOPLE
DIRECTLY IMPACTS WE ARE PLEASED
TO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE AND
THANK THE MEMBER FOR BRINGING
THIS. IN CALIFORNIA. JEWEL'S
THESE BARRIERS MAKE IT HARDER TO
SUCCESSFULLY REINTEGRATE INTO
SOCIETY AND SUPPORT THEMSELVES
THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES. DESPITE THESE
BARRIERS WE WORK EVERY DAY WITH
FOLKS WHO ARE TRANSFORMING THEIR
LIVES. FINANCIAL STABILITY OR
LACK THERE OF IS ONE OF THE
STRONGEST INDICATORS OF
RECIDIVISM THUS THE STABLE
EMPLOYMENT IN UPWARD MOBILITY
ARE THE MOST EFFECTIVE ANTI
RECIDIVISM TOOLS AVAILABLE TO
THE STATE TO IMPROVE PUBLIC
SAFETY OUTCOMES FOR ALL. ONE OF
THE BEST WAYS TO ENSURE THESE
INDIVIDUALS ACHIEVE FINANCIAL
STABILITY THIS COLLEGE I ASSUME
THE MAJORITY THE PEOPLE IN THIS
ROOM TODAY ARE HERE IN PART
BECAUSE OF THE SUCCESS THAT
THEIR HIGHER EDUCATION TREATMENT
SET THEM UP FOR. I MYSELF AM A
PROUD PRODUCT OF THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM THIS BILL IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE JUSTICE
INVOLVES STUDENTS AND
INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE THE SAME
BENEFITS. THE STATE BEEN THAT
THIS BILL PROVIDES A INSERTED
THEIR SET UP FOR SUCCESS WHICH
AGAIN IS IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
EVERYONE. WE NEED TO ENSURE
FOLKS THAT ARE LEAVING
INCARCERATION ARE ANY
COMPETITIVE SALARIES NOT
SCRAPING BY ON MINIMUM WAGE A
POVERTY WAGES. WE WANT FOLKS TO
COME HOME AND BECOME GOOD AND
PRODUCTIVE NEIGHBORS AND A
STRONG EDUCATION LEADS THEM IN
THAT DIRECTION. WE NEED TO BE
LIFTING PEOPLE OUT OF POVERTY
AND THIS IS A BILL THAT DOES
EXACTLY THAT THANK YOU AND I ARE
DRIVE VOTE. THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT OF
THIS- A. B- TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE. THANK YOU TERM MEMBERS
MARK MCDONALD M. G. I. ADVOCACY
ON BEHALF OF THE- ANTELOPE
VALLEY PALO VERDE SAN DIEGO AND
YUBA COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. ANY
OTHER PERSON. OKAY. EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR IDEA ANYONE ON THE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE FALL BY ZERO FOR
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE. M. MISTER CHAIR
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CALMLY WITH L.
A. COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
PRAGUE CONFINES OF THE BILL WHEN
I THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRIAN
BROCK DURING. SIX OF THE LINE
ONE NINETY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON NATALIE BACK ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE AND SUPPORT
. NINE TO TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO TO FIFTEEN CAN THERE ARE
MADE UP OF THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE ARE IN
SUPPORT. THE FINAL REMINDER TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONE
MOMENT MISTER CHAIR WE DO HAVE
ANOTHER ONE COMING UP. FIVE TO
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. TO
FOURTEEN YOU ARE OPEN. THANK YOU
FOURTEEN GO AHEAD. AND THEY JUST
TOOK THEMSELVES OUT OF QUEUE
THERE ARE NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME. DID WE
CALL FOR ANYONE IN A POSITION.
ANY ANYNE IN THE HEARING ROOM
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. AT&T
OPERATOR ANY ONE ON THE PHONE
LINES IN OPPOSITION. YOU MISTER
CHAIR DIRECT EXPRESS OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ONE TAL
BUDGET. MISTER CHAIR NOBODY IS
KILLING UP ANY TWEETERS IN THE
HEARING ROOM- MISTER OPERATOR
ANY TWEETERS ON THE PHONE LINE
WELL WE HAVE A TWEENER HERE. K.
THERE YOU GO GOOD AFTERNOON
INTERMINABLY COMMITTEE LINDA
BASKETS WITH A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL AT
THIS MOMENT WE ARE IN BETWEEN-
AND I'VE ENJOYED CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER TWEETERS. HAD
SEEN ANY A MODERATOR ANY
POINTERS ON THE LINE. NOBODY IS
KILLING UP MISTER CHAIRMAN I
WILL GO THEN TO COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. COMMITTEE SEEING NONE
OF. ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. ABSOLUTELY I WANT
TO THANK AGAIN THE COMMITTEE GOT
CHANCES OFFICE FOR THEIR
THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATIONS IN THE
LA COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
FOR THEIR- OVERWHELMING SUPPORT
IN THE LAWSUIT IS WHAT
SUPERVISORS THERE'S A SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELINE- WE'RE ALL AWARE
OF THAT WE DON'T. HAVE A ROBUST
PRISON TO SCHOOL OR SCHOOL TO
WORK FORCE PIPELINE FOR PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN IN PRISON AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
BUILD HERE I WITH THIS HIGHER UP
STIPENDS PROGRAMS ARE. ASK RIVAL
. NO NO THANK YOU ASSEMBLY FOR
BRINGING HIS MEASURE FORWARD- I
MAY NOT HAVE HAD A CHANCE TO
SHARE WITH YOU BUT I WAS A-
ADULT EDUCATION TEACHER- AT
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION FOR
WOMEN. BEFORE BECOMING A PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER SO EVERYTHING
THAT WE DO IN THIS AREA IS- IS A
DEAR AND CLOSE TO MY HEART SO
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS. FORWARD A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE- ARE DOING GOOD WORK-
WITH JUST AS INVOLVED STUDENTS.
AND I AM VERY GRATEFUL FOR THIS
PILOT. I THINK IT'S AN
INTERESTING WAY TO TRY TO
PROVIDE FINANCIAL SUPPORT FOR
THESE STUDENTS. AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU'RE ACTIVELY WORKING
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. ON POSSIBLE
AMENDMENTS AND ASKED THAT YOU
PLEASE CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. TO KEEP STAFF
FORM OF THE PROCTORS. OF WE
STILL DON'T HAVE A- LOCAL THAT
QUORUM SO WE WILL VOTE WHEN WE
DO ACCEPT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND AT THIS POINT I'M GONNA- ASK
FOR MR FONG'S QUICK INDULGENCE
MR FONG I'M GONNA TRY TO PRESENT
BILL HOPEFULLY WON'T TAKE ME
LONG. I HAVE. I HAVE A WITNESSES
WHO GONNA NEED TO LEAVE SO THEN
WE'LL GET TO MR FONG.
ONE FORTY.
GO AHEAD THEM THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TODAY I PRESENT
AB TWENTY FORTY. TWENTY FORTY
SIX VERY PERSONAL BILL FOR ME
WHICH IS TABLETS IS THE INLAND
RISING FUND FOR THE SCHOOLS OF
MEDICINE AT UC RIVERSIDE AND UC
MERCED. CALIFORNIA AS WE ALL
KNOW IS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY. BUT THESE ECONOMIC
BENEFITS ARE NOT SHARED BY ALL
REGIONS OF THE STATE AS 70% OF
JOB GROWTH HAS BEEN IN COASTAL
CITIES. THIS LACK OF EQUITY
BEGINS AT OUR SCHOOLS LAST YEAR
MY HOMETOWN NEWSPAPER THE PRESS
ENTERPRISE REPORTED THAT UC
RIVERSIDE RECEIVES THE LOWEST
AMOUNT OF PER STUDENT. ON A PER
STUDENT BASIS IN OF ANY OF THE
UC CAMPUSES. THIS IS COMPOUNDED
BY THE FACT THAT 62% OF THE UC
SYSTEM STATE FUNDING IS
ALLOCATED TO CAMPUS ON BASE TO A
STUDENT ENROLLMENT. HELLO NOT.
YOU SEE THAT AND READ THERE IS
SO MUCH MORE US TO ADDICT INVEST
IN OUR REGION TO TRULY REACH
CALIFORNIANS WITH MINISTER
ECKLEY UNDERSERVED FOR
GENERATIONS UC MERCED AND UC
RIVERSIDE ARE ANCHOR
INSTITUTIONS IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY AND IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
AND THEY ARE ON THE CUSP OF
BECOMING RESEARCH LEVEL ONE AND
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA AMERICA.
INSTEAD AGENTS. TIMELY TRANSFER
INFORMATIONAL INVESTMENT IN UC
RIVERSIDE AND UC MERCED IS KEY
TO SPURRING ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
SPECIFICALLY IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE AND IN THE JOAQUIN SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY. AB TWENTY FORTY
SIX THIS STAB WISHES THE INLAND
RISING FUNDS. ALLOCATING ONE
POINT FOUR SIX BILLION DOLLARS
ONE TIME AND ONGOING FUNDS TO
THE. TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
TWENTY THREE STATE BUDGET AT UC
RIVERSIDE AND UC MERCED. THIS
INVESTMENT WOULD EXPAND CAMPUS
CAPACITY MORE RAPIDLY TO RESPOND
TO THE CRITICAL NEEDS OF THE
STATE AND LOCAL REGIONS
SPECIFICALLY BY ADDRESSING
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY. CLIMATE
CHANGE HEALTH CARE AND RESEARCH
THE INVESTMENT WILL RESULT IN
THE FIRST EIGHT B. U. AND ONLY
THE SECOND RESEARCH ONE
INSTITUTION IN THE INLAND VALLEY
REGIONS. BENEFITING UC'S MOST
DIVERSE STUDENT POPULATIONS
STRATEGICALLY ADVANCING THE
STATURE OF THESE TWO
UNIVERSITIES WILL ACCELERATE
ECONOMIC GROWTH AND INLAND
REGIONAL DEVELOPMENT. GIVEN
RECENT ENROLLMENT ISSUES AND
OTHER UC CAMPUSES SUCH AS UC
BERKELEY AND THE HISTORIC LACK
OF EQUITABLE INVESTMENT ACROSS
CAMPUSES IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT WE
BEGIN TO RECTIFY THESE PROBLEMS
THIS IS WHY I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FORTY SIX.
I REALIZE THAT RECENT AMENDMENTS
WERE INTRODUCED AND THAT THEY
ARE STILL UNDER CONSIDERATION WE
ARE OPEN TO HAVING THESE
CONVERSATIONS MOVING FORWARD
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE IS JACK CLARK.
PRESIDENT OF THE MONDAY MORNING
GROUP AND UC RIVERSIDE FACULTY
MEMBER DARIAN ANDERSON. I
SUPPORTER WITNESS WHO YOU CAN GO
AHEAD THEY FEEL READY. JACK
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE NO PROJECT. JACK CORK AND I'M READY. WE'RE
WE'RE READY WHEN YOU ARE JACK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS JACK CLARK I AM CALLING
THE SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FORTY
SIX I'M CALLING THE CREEK
BAPTIST CHURCH AT THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT. OF THE- MONDAY
MORNING A GREATER RIVERSIDE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AREA. WHICH
THOSE OF THE PUBLIC SERVICE
PRIVATE CITIZENS WHOSE MEDICAL
EDUCATE OURSELVES ON MATTERS
REASONABLE ORTON AND THEN
ADVOCATE USING OUR PERSONAL
FUNDS TO HELP IMPLEMENT THOSE
ISSUES OF IMPORTANCE TO OUR
COMMUNITIES. I WOULD NOT A
BALLOTS THAT MONEY MORNING GROUP
IS THE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FORTY SIX. SECOND CALL THE LOCAL
RESIDENT OF RIVERSIDE FOR OVER
FIFTY YEARS AND LASTLY I'M
CALLING THOSE LOT OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE. KANAME COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I CANNOT TELL YOU HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS TO OUR REGION
BUT YOU FAVORABLY CONSIDERED AB
TWENTY FORTY SIX. IF THE VENTRAL
PASSAGE WOMAN OTHER THINGS
IMPROVE THE UCR SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE BY ADDING TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
SCHOOLS INFRASTRUCTURE. WILL
PROVIDE CAPITAL EXPENSE
EXPENDITURES FOR UNDERGRADUATE
CLASSROOMS AND FACILITIES
VITALLY IMPORTANT TO OUR
COMMUNITY TO AREA A REGION. THAT
DOES NOT HAVE ENOUGH COLLEGE
GRADUATES. ALSO AND MOST ALMOST
MOST IMPORTANTLY WILL PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE RESEARCH. THANK
YOU APPROACH THIS MATTER MANY
MEMBERS I WOULD SINCERELY ASK
THAT YOU CONSIDER THESE
IMPORTANT POINTS. ONE OF THE
LARGEST EVER TO GROW CURRENTLY
OUR STATE IS THE AMOUNT REGION.
AND YET THE AMOUNT REGION IS NOT
AN AREA OF LOW. UCART ONE ANKLE
MINISTRY. I WOULD HAVE THAT YOU
PLEASE NOT LOOK AT THE WHAT BOB
WHAT THE WHAT THE BILL WILL DO.
FOR ONE OF THE TWO YOU SEE. LOOK
AT A THE ACTUALLY IT. AN AT BAT
IN HISTORICALLY UNDER. AND UNDER
WE REGION. WE BUT YOU PLEASE
PRAY BELIEVE. BY YOU. DO YOU
HAVE A SECOND GENTLENESS- DARIAN
ANDERSON ON THE LINE. THE SURE
MEDINA THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY HER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
DARREN ANDERSON ON THE
CHAIRPERSON AND CEO OR SALSA
BRIAN LEADING NORTH AMERICAN
ENGINEERING TECHNICAL SERVICES
FIRM WE ARE BOYS SIXTEEN HUNDRED
TEAM MEMBERS ACROSS NORTH
AMERICA AND MANY UC RIVERSIDE
GRADUATES I'M ALSO A FORMER MALL
ALSO ALUMNI OF UC RIVERSIDE A
FORMER REGENT A MEMBER OF THE UC
RIVERSIDE FOUNDATION. THANK YOU
FOR HEARING AB TWENTY FORTY SIX
TODAY. I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL. THERE'S A CHICKEN
STATE AND REGIONAL VALUE
CONDUCTING RESEARCH UNIVERSITIES
INCLUDING GREATER ECONOMIC
IMPACT THROUGH JOB CREATION
RESEARCH AND LOCAL SPEND. WE
NEED TO INVEST MORE IN
ENGINEERING AND CLEAN ENERGY
TECHNICAL DISCIPLINES SIMPLY
STATED WE ARE NOT GRADUATING AND
NOT. STUDENTS FOR THE NEED TODAY
THAT FOR THE NEXT TWO DECADES WE
MUST DO MORE. ENGINEERING WORK
OF SALT AND BRINE DELIVERED
EVERY DAY WORK WITH GLOBAL
ENGINEERING FIRMS GLOBAL
ENGINEERING COMPANIES. TO REDUCE
ENERGY CONSUMPTION AND
EMPLOYMENT POSITIVE CHANGES TO
FACILITIES. REDUCE GAS. LOS
UNITED STATES. WITHOUT GRADUATES
IN BE RESEARCHERS WITH NOT BE
ABLE TO ACHIEVE OUR STATE AND
FEDERAL GOALS TODAY WE SIMPLY
NEED TO KNOW MORE TALENT IN THE
WORKFORCE AND RESEARCH TO
ADVANCE OUR PRODUCTIVITY. THE
OUTPUT OF RESEARCH INSTITUTION
INTENSIVE UNIVERSITIES FALLS
INTO THREE SURGICALLY IN A
RELATED VALUE TRAINS. ONE
RESEARCH INCLUDING THE
PRODUCTION AND DISTRIBUTION OF
KNOWLEDGE. TO EDUCATION
INCLUDING FUTURE RESEARCHERS AND
WORKFORCE AND THREE THE
TECHNOLOGY TRANSFER INCLUDING
PATENTS LICENSING START UPS IN
INDUSTRY CREATION. FORMER
PERCENT PRESENT CASPER SAID
RESEARCH EDUCATION AND EXCHANGE
OF KNOWLEDGE WITH THE OUTSIDE
WORLD FERTILIZE EACH OTHER
CHALLENGES NOT BY INDUSTRY AND
SOCIETY MAY INSPIRE NEW BASIC
AND APPLIED RESEARCH CONTACT THE
STUDENTS INSPIRED RESEARCHER.
RESEARCHERS INCLUDE STUDENTS
WORKING ON RESEARCH PROJECTS AND
COMPANIES TO EXCHANGE KNOWLEDGE
WITH GRADUATES WHEN THEY EMPLOY
THEM. YOU SEE MERCED IN
RIVERSIDE ARE THE TWO MOST
ETHNICALLY DIVERSE CAMPUSES IN
THE UC SYSTEM AND HAVE BEEN
DESIGNATED AS HISPANIC SERVING.
AN ASIAN AMERICAN AND NATIVE
AMERICAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
SERVING INSTITUTIONS BY THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. AT THE
NEW LEADER IN THE ENGINEERING
AND TECHNICAL SERVICES FIELD I
UNDERSTAND HOW IMPORTANT PLACES
LIKE UC RIVERSIDE AND UC MERCED
OUR TO TRAINING AND TALENTED
DIVERSE WORK FORCE WE NEED MORE
TODAY WE NEED MORE
REPRESENTATION FROM ALL SOCIAL
ECONOMIC BACKGROUNDS TO MAINTAIN
A HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT WORKFORCE
AND TO REPRESENT ALL AMERICANS.
AB TWENTY FORTY SIX WOULD ALSO
EXPAND CAMPUS CAPACITY MORE
RAPIDLY TO ADDRESS CRITICAL NEED
TO THE STATE AND LOCAL REGIONS
SPECIFICALLY UP BY ADDRESSING
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY. BOTH
CAMPUSES ARE ACTIVELY WORKING
WITH LOCAL EDUCATION PARTNERS TO
INCREASE EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT
WITH PLANET ROMA GROWTH
ESPECIALLY FOR MORE CALIFORNIA
UNDERGRADUATES. I THINK IT'S TO
BE KNOWN THAT THE UC RIVERSIDE
AND UC MERCED OUR NUMBER ONE IT
TOO IN TERMS OF SOCIAL MOBILITY
FOR ALL INSTITUTIONS IN THE
UNITED STATES. CON HEALTHCARE
AND RESEARCH BOTH CAMPUSES HAVE
PLANS TO GROW THEIR OWN MEDICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS. WITH
INITIATIVES THAT WILL RESULT IN
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND REFLECT BOTH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THE MEDICAL RESEARCH
THAT ADDRESSES DISTINCTIVE HELP
CHALLENGE. WELL KNOWN THAT BOTH
OF COMMUNITIES ARE ON SERVED
UNDER. FROM HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS AND PROFESSIONALS IN
BOTH INSTITUTIONS ARE ACTIVELY
WORKING TO IMPROVE. THE NUMBER
OF- DOCTORS AND PROVIDERS IN
THOSE REGIONS WE NEED TO DO MORE
FROM AN EQUITY PERSPECTIVE AND
JUST TO MAKE SURE WE'RE TAKING
PARK. ANOTHER CLIMATE CHANGE
BOTH CAMPUSES ACTIVE ADDRESSING
CHANGE THROUGH RESEARCH AND
ACTION. THE UC RIVERSIDE CLEAN
TECHNOLOGY IN AIR POLLUTION%
RESEARCH TO THAT SUSTAINED
SUSTAINABILITY INNOVATION ANSEL
FROM COLLUSION AND YOU SEE MORE
SAYS RESEARCH ON THE-
AGRICULTURE INCLUDING
AGRICULTURAL COULD NOT. THE
DEFICIT USED AND BETTER WATER
UTILIZATION WE HAVE THE NEW CARB
HEADQUARTERS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BASED IN RIVERSIDE IT
IS THE STATE OF THE ART ACILITY
THIS IS AN INCUBATOR OF
REGULATORY THINKING AND
INNOVATIVE RESEARCH TO IMPROVE.
THE LIFESTYLE AND EMISSIONS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA YOU SEE ARE
THE ONLY R. ONE UNIVERSITY IN
INLAND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WITH
NO FOUNDATIONAL RESEARCH
FRANKLIN AIR QUALITY HEART
OFFICIAL TOLD INSPECTION ONYX
AND SUSTAINABLE AGRICULTURE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. UP YEAH WE
GET YOUR POINT TO SELL MOVE TO-
ANY. ANY OF THE- WAS SUB. IN
SUPPORT OF THIS OUT A. B. TWENTY
FORTY SIX SO IN THIS ROOM YOU
CAN STEP TOWARD- THANK VICE
CHAIRMAN ROBERT MITCHUM HALF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FORTY
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IN A
THE PERSON. OKAY IF NOT THE
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATE OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE. IN ORDER AB
TWENTY FORTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. ARE WE GOING TO
LINE NUMBER TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR NUMBERS
AND THE LAW ON BEHALF OF EACH OF
THE WATER DISTRICT INCLUDES
PARTS. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE
ANOTHER IN JUST A MOMENT. I
COULD I DO A LONGER OKAY EGGMAN
REGARDS LEVINE NUMBER. MEXICO TO
LINE NUMBER TWO TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS CONNIE CHAN WHAT IS THAT
ANALYSTS FOR STATE TREASURER
FIONA MA CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY FORTY SIX ON BEHALF OF
THE TREASURER THANK YOU. AND
NEXT WEEK TO LINE NUMBER. TWO
ZERO THREE TWO OH THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD WORK. MY NAME. THANK
YOU THEY ARE I WANTED TO WITH
YOU MUCH INSIDE DEDICATE MY
STUDENT BRING TO THE CLASSROOM
EVERY DAY I WANT TO ASK YOU YOUR
COLLEAGUES IN THE GOVERNOR I'M
NOT BE IMMENSE RESERVES OF
INSIGHT LEADERSHIP AND
INNOVATION IN THE INLAND REJECT
THESE STUDENTS ARE USING THEIR
THE FUTURE EIGHT THANK YOU. FOR
THANK. I'M MORE IF YOU. OKAY NOW
I IS R- SMM AND COULD AS- JOINT
AUTHORS IN THE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO. IF ECONOMY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRET IT'S GONNA CLOSE. SO IF
HE'LL DO THAT ALSO IS ON A I
THOUGHT YOU STEPPED IN TO MAKE A
STATEMENT ON THIS IN SUPPORT TO
. YEAH THAT THAT'S FINE THEN-
THEN THE IS THE DO YOU HAVE A
YOU ARE ANY. OPPOSITION WITHIN
THIS YEAR. IF NOT THE IN THE
AUDIENCE SO ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO
OPPOSE A TO DISPEL. AT&T
OPERATOR ANYONE- IN YOUR PHONE
LINE TO OPPOSE THIS BILL. WEBER
UP OPPOSITION FOR AB TWENTY
FORTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THE ZERO. OKAY BOB- AND WE WILL
HAVE A FEW HERE THE FIRST WILL
BE GOING TO LINE NUMBER TWO
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MANY
PINERA MARIE SENT COUNTY
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL WE ARE OPPOSED TO A. B.
TWO ZERO FOUR SIX. FOUR CONNECT
WE'RE GOING TO LINE NUMBER TWO
OH TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HAVE A
HELLO. CAN YOU ARE LOOKING. YES-
ALTHOUGH I AGREE ON FUNDING FOR
UC SYSTEM I HAVE TO OPPOSE THIS
BILL- AS GROW LISTED AS AMENDED
THANK YOU IT DOES NOT ADDRESS
THE BUILDING TRADE THE WORKFORCE
- THANK YOU. RODRIGUEZ I WILL
GET LOCAL FOR THIRTY THREE
BUSINESS DAYS. THANK YOU AND
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE NUMBER
ONE SIXTY FIVE ONE SIX FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. FIVE THANK YOU.
DAVID BEANIE ON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE SANTA CLARA AND
SAN BENITO COUNTIES BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL. WE
STAND WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL AND LET
COMMENDED. INCLUDE BUILDING
TRAIN FORCE FLYKNIT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. BONTA LINE NUMBER.
ONE NINE ZERO ONE NINE ZERO
ALLIES. A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS PAUL BRANDO BUT THE IRON
WORKERS LOCAL FOUR THIRTY THREE
AND- WE ARE POSTING- THE AB
TWENTY FORTY SIX OF WHAT THAT
MEANT THEY- ALSO. A RIVERSIDE
COUNTY READ AND- YOU KNOW MOST
OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE TO TRAVEL IN
THE LA FOR THIS KIND OF WORK
COMMENCED ITS WORK COULD BE DONE
FOR YOU KNOW ALL. THE PUT IT YOU
WANT TO WORK SO- WE'RE HOLDING
UNLESS THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WE'RE GOING TO NUMBER
TWO ZERO SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS BENITO
ROBLESS ARMED WITH THE LABORERS
DISTRICT COUNCIL HERE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS BILL
AND LAST AMENDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT TO GOING TO MY
NUMBER ONE EIGHT FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ANTHONY RISKY
SO ND BUSINESS ROUTE FROM LOCAL
SIXTEEN SHE'D CROSSED AND
SLATER'S AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
THE MASS AMENDED THANK. THANK
YOU NEXT WE'RE GOING TO LINE
NUMBER ONE SIX ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JEREMIAH WITH THIS MY MASONS
FROM NORTHERN CALIFORNIA- WE-
OPPOSE- TWENTY FORTY SIX UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO LINE NUMBER. ONE SIX
THREE ONE SIX THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SIX FORGET FOR LEGISLATIVE
CHANGE IN THINKING SINCE THE
FALL OF THE FULL FULL. FOR
INSTANCE AND- IF. HELLO THANK
YOU AND NEXT WE'RE GOING TO MY
NUMBER ONE SEVEN FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON GEN
NELLER IRONWORKERS LOCAL THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT WE STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE STATE
BUILDING COURAGE OPPOSED AND
LET'S NOT MEANT IT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND NOT GOING TO LIE
NUMBER ONE NINETY FOUR ONE NINE
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH HI
RICK SMILES THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA DISCOUNT OF LABORS
AND WE STAND IN OPPOSITION OF AB
TWO ZERO FOUR SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THERE ARE NO MORE
IN Q. OKAY I WOULD SHERMAN-
MEDINA AS A FAVORITE THE-
TWEENER SO IDEA ANY. TWEENER SO
IN THE ROOM- NO TWEETERS MISTER
VICE CHAIR I THOUGHT WE HAD-
SAID IN SOME OF THE NAME THE
BILL PEREZ AND A CONFERENCE LINE
FOR HIM TO BE THE CHIEF
OPPOSITION WITNESS ON THIS. I
DON'T KNOW IF HE'S ON THE LINE
OR NOT IF THAT OPPORTUNITY WHY
LOCAL. OKAY COULD I COULD I TAKE
AS THE AS THE AS THE CHIEF
OPPONENT OF THE TWO MINUTES GIVE
GRANTED TO- TO OPPOSE ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING TRADES. HE
YEAH COME OVER HERE OKAY. THANK
YOU MISTER BOETTCHER I'D PAUSED
BECAUSE I THOUGHT THE BILL WAS
ON THE PHONE IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
CALLED ON BY THE OPERATOR SO I
APOLOGIZE FOR COMING UP WATER
JEREMY SMITH YOUR BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL. TO GIVE SOME
CONTEXT TO THE CALLERS THAT JUST
CALLED IN TO OPPOSE. A WE HAVE
GIVEN AMENDMENTS TO MR MEDINA.
MISTER GRAY ABOUT THE- BUT
MAKING SURE THAT WE INCLUDE A
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE IN
THESE PROJECTS AND THAT THE
PREVAILING WAGE. IS ALSO PAID ON
THESE PROJECTS. READY
CONVERSATIONS MR MEDINA- THOSE
ARE ONGOING WE APPRECIATE THAT.
OTHERS WANT TO TAKE A COUPLE
MINUTES OR A FEW SECONDS HERE
AND JUST. MAKE A FEW POINTS- YOU
KNOW. THESE PROJECTS. THAT ARE
GOING TO BE FOR COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS. SHOULD ALSO
BE LOOKED AT AS LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS FOR OUR PREMISES.
MAN JOURNEY WOMEN. UP OUR
STUDENTS BEFORE THEIR JOURNEY
MANAGER LEMON AS APPRENTICES ON
JOB SITES SO THE ADS WE BUILD
PROJECTS FOR TRADITIONAL FOUR
YEAR COLLEGE EDUCATED-
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS WE THINK
IT'S GOOD PUBLIC INVESTMENT TO
LOOK AT THESE PROJECTS. HIGHER
EDUCATION FOUR POINT BECOME
JOURNEYMEN AND JOINING WOMAN-
WANTED TO JUST UNDERSTAND
UNDERSCORE THAT THAT PUBLIC
FUNDS LIKE THIS THAT GO TOWARDS
PAYING LIVING WAGES. WITH
BENEFITS FOR CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS- THINGS THAT BOTH MISS
RITA MISTER GREAT SUPPORT I'M
AWARE OF THAT- GOLAN WOULD
RESULT IN HELPING LOCAL
ECONOMIES AND HELPING FAMILIES-
BEING THE MIDDLE CLASS- SO
WE'VE- ENGAGED WITH OTHERS ON
THESE AMENDMENTS MANY OF YOU
HAVE HEARD ABOUT THAT BEFORE- WE
HOPE THAT WE CAN- COME TO AN
AGREEMENT ON THAT BUT IT.
FORTUNATE RIGHT NOW WE ARE
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED WITHOUT
THE SKILLED ENTRY REQUIREMENTS
AND THE PREVAILING WAGE COVERAGE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. YOU ARE
ARE THERE ANY TWEENER SOON IN
THE ROLE. HI YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SO- GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
MEDINA AND MISTER GRAY AND THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
I'M KAREN FLAHERTY ON BEHALF OF
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA I
WANT. YOU AND THE OTHER MEMBERS
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF ALL OF
THE UC CAMPUSES AND OF COURSE
YOUR LEADERSHIP FOR MERCED IN
RIVERSIDE. THE UNIVERSITY
CURRENTLY DOES NOT HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION ON AB TWENTY FORTY SIX
BUT I DID WANT TO TAKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO LET YOU KNOW THAT
WE'D LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU
MOVING FORWARD AND SEE WHAT
MIGHT BE POSSIBLE FOR INVESTMENT
IN THE RIVERSIDE AND MERCED
REGIONS. WHICH ARE CERTAINLY
WORTHY AREAS OF THE STATE FOR
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT THE
UNIVERSITY DOES HAVE A BUDGET
REQUEST FOR CAPITAL OF ONE POINT
SIX BILLION IN- STATE FUNDING-
THAT WERE HOPING- WILL BENEFIT
ALL TEN CAMPUSES INCLUDING
RIVERSIDE MERCED. IF APPROVED BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
WE ALSO HAVE GROWTH.
TOWARDS DIVERSIFYING OUR FACULTY
AND OUR STUDENTS THAT WE
ENROLLED PARTICULARLY AT THOSE
CAMPUSES ARE THE MORE DIVERSE IN
REFLECTIVE OUR FACULTY
EVENTUALLY BE CALM FOR ALL THREE
SEGMENTS IN WHICH WE TEACH AND
THE GOVERNOR IS ALSO PROPOSED
FUNDING FOR CLIMATE CHANGE OUR
RESEARCH INNOVATION HUBS
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. AND WE
THINK THOSE CAMPUSES ARE ALSO
PERFECTLY POISED TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THAT FUNDING AS
WELL SO WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING AND WE AND THE CO
AUTHORS PARTICULARLY FOR THEIR
WORK IN THOSE REGIONS WHEN IT
COMES TO HEALTH PROFESSIONS
EDUCATION AS WELL AS GRIPPING
THE REGION IN THE CAMPUS AND
THANK YOU. OKAY A OPERATOR AT&T
OPERATOR ANY ONE KNOW ON THE
PHONE NOW- TO MAKE A COMMENT
THAT AS A NEUTRAL PERSON. TWENTY
COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. OKAY THANK
YOU NOW- ANA ASCO MEMBERS- ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. OKAY.
THANK YOU BOTH SO MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS BEFORE AND I'M
JUST WONDERING WHERE ARE YOU IN
THE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION AS FAR AS INCLUDING
THAT LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL. I
WOULD WOULD SAY BRIEFLY THAT-
THIS IS- NOT THE ONLY BILL.
RIGHT AND SO I KNOW THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAVE- CONVERSATIONS
AND- I DON'T DISAGREE WITH
ANYTHING- THAT THEY SAID. AND AS
HE INDICATED I. THE MERCHANTS IN
BOTH PREVAILING WAGE AND
ANYTHING THAT THAT. HELPS THE
WORK FORCE AND AGREE THAT THAT
IT COULD BE A WIN WIN SO WE WILL
WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION. THAT ADD TO THAT-
CERTAINLY IS CHAIR MEDINA SAYS
THERE ARE LARGER DISCUSSIONS
GOING ON- ABOVE THIS BILL BUT I
WILL SAY YOU KNOW WHEN WE DID
THE TWENTY TWENTY PROJECT UC
MERCED I WAS THE PRINCIPAL
ARCHITECT OF ENSURING THAT-
PREVAILING WAGE UNSKILLED TRÊN
LANGUAGE WAS PART OF THAT DEAL
AND I THINK BOTH STELLAR MEDINA
MYSELF HAVE A TRACK RECORD. OF
LANDING ON THAT SIDE OF THE
ISSUE AND I AM A 100% CONFIDENT
WILL LAND ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF
THIS PARTICULAR BILL. OKAY ANY
OTHER MEMBER. OKAY OF MISTER I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE FOR YOUR
IDEA TO STIMULATE THE YOU'RE-
FAVORITE AREA OF- IN EMPIRE I'M
AT THAT AREA HAS A CERTAIN THE
FOCAL POINT- END OF TRACTION
BECAUSE THIS OF MORE AVAILABLE
LAND OUT MORE FOR. AND THE NICE
THING OF THIS INITIATIVE- VERY
ATTRACTIVE AND NAME THE SUN
RISING CLASS. SO CERTAINLY THAT
THE ORIOLES- IN A BECOME THE
AREA WITH THE SUN RISING AND THE
ECONOMIC MORE VITALITY
DEVELOPMENTS IS SO I THINK I AM
IN SUPPORT OF THAT THE AND THEN
I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR ANY OF
CLOSING STATEMENT YOU WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF
GRACE GOING TO MAKE THAT THE
STATEMENT. WHAT BOTH OF YOU
EITHER ONE OF YOU IS A WEBER
GRILL. THANK YOU- CHAIRMAN. AND
MEMBERS. I'M PROUD TO BE HERE
TODAY SENATE SHOULDER SHOULDER
WITH CHAIR MEDINA DEMANDING
SIGNIFICANT AND MEANINGFUL
INVESTMENT IN UC MERCED UC
RIVERSIDE. THESE CAMPUSES
REPRESENTED A PARCHER FROM OUR
STATE'S TRACK RECORD OF IGNORING
INLAND COMMUNITIES AND DIRECTING
INVESTMENTS TOWARDS POPULATION
CENTERS ON THE COAST. THERE'S A
REASON THAT DESPITE BEING HOME
TO FOUR AND A HALF MILLION
PEOPLE. THERE WAS NOT A UC
CAMPUS IN THE VALLEY UNTIL YOU
SEE MERCED OPENED IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE AFTER A TWO DECADE
FIGHT. YOU SEE MERCED IS NOT
RECEIVE THE SAME STATE SUPPORT
AS THE OTHER UC CAMPUSES IN
PART. BECAUSE OF THIS INLAND
BIAS BUT ALSO BECAUSE IT OPENED
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE GREAT
RECESSION. SO ALL OTHER CAMPUSES
WERE BUILT ALMOST ENTIRELY WITH
STATE MONEY. MUCH OF UC MERCED
WAS BUILT BE A PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CAMPUS
TAKING ON SIGNIFICANT DEBT. IN
ORDER TO EXPAND AND ROLL ENOUGH
STUDENTS TO BECOME SELF
SUFFICIENT. UNIQUE UNTO ITSELF
FROM OTHER CAMPUS IN THE SYSTEM
. DOES THE STATE SITS ON TENS OF
BILLIONS IN ON PRESIDENT
SURPLUSES WE HAVE NOT DONE
ANYTHING TO RIGHT THIS WRONG TO
REDUCE THE BURDEN ON THE
STUDENTS WHO ATTEND UC MERCED.
AND LET'S JUST TAKE A LOOK AT
THE STUDENTS FOR A MOMENT. UC
MERCED WAS BUILT WITH THE
PROMISE OF BRING IT UC
EDUCATIONS TO STUDENTS WHO
TRADITIONALLY WERE EXCLUDED FROM
THE SYSTEM. UC MERCED IS THE
MOST ETHNICALLY AND CULTURALLY
DIVERSE CAMPUS IN THE UC SYSTEM
. AS A MAJORITY MINORITY CAMPUS
MORE THAN 70% OF STUDENTS ARE
THE FIRST IN THEIR FAMILY TO GO
TO COLLEGE AND A MAJORITY OF
STUDENTS SPEAK A LANGUAGE OTHER
THAN ENGLISH AT HOME. YOU SEE
MERCED IS ALSO ENROLLED THE
HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS IN THE UC
SYSTEM IN THE CAMPUS HAS BEEN
DESIGNATED BOTH AS A HISPANIC
SERVING INSTITUTION. AND IS AN
ASIAN AND NATIVE AMERICAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER SERVING
INSTITUTION. YOU SEE MERCED IS
DOING EVERYTHING RIGHT AND
DELIVERING ON THE PROMISE OF
EQUAL REPRESENTATION THAT MANY
OF US PREACH IN THIS BUILDING
AND IN OUR DISTRICTS EVERY
SINGLE DAY. BUT THEY ARE DOING
THIS DESPITE BEING FORCED TO
OVERCOME BIAS AND UNDER
INVESTMENT FROM OTHER PARTS OF
THE UC IN THE STATE. LET'S TALK
ABOUT WHAT THAT BIAS LOOKS LIKE
FOR ME. THE ALEJO'S DISCUSSION
OF THE UC BUDGET THIS YEAR
MENTIONS UC MERCED RIVERSIDE UC
MERCED AND UC RIVERSIDE ONLY
ONCE BY NOTING THAT THEY'RE THE
ONLY REFERRAL CAMPUSES IN THE UC
SYSTEM. MEANING THERE WERE THE
REFER STUDENTS WHO ARE NOT
ACCEPTED TO THEIR CAMPUS OF
CHORES. THE L. A- THEN SUGGESTS
AS A REMEDY GIVEN THE OTHER
CAMPUSES MORE MONEY TO REDUCE
REFERRALS BUT MAKES NO MENTION
OF THE FACT THE UC MERCED HAS
THE SMALLEST BUDGET OF ANY OTHER
CAMPUS OR THAT. RIVER SIDE OF
THE SERVING THE MOST DIVERSE
STUDENT BODIES IN THE SYSTEM.
THIS IS THE DEFINITION. OF
REWARDING THE HAVES WHILE
IGNORING THE HAVE NOTS. BUDGET
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE GOVERNOR
AND YOU SEE IT FOCUSED ON
EXPANDING ENROLLMENT IN ROLLING
MORE CALIFORNIA STUDENTS AND
INCREASING STUDENT OUTCOMES AND
EQUITY. THE BUDGET PROPOSES TO
REWARD YOU SEE FOR TAKING STEPS
TO MEET THESE GOALS WHILE
SUGGESTING BUDGET CUTS IF THE UC
FAILS TO ACT. YOU SEE MERCED AND
RIVERSIDE ARE ALREADY DELIVERING
ON THESE GOALS. BUT WHERE'S
THEIR EXTRA MONEY. WHERE IS THE
REWARD AND ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
FORGETTING RIGHT WHAT IS WRONG
IT'S SO MANY OF THE OTHER
CAMPUSES. THAT'S WHAT AB TWENTY
FORTY SIX IS ABOUT GIVE THESE
CAMPUSES THE FINANCIAL RESOURCES
THEY NEED. TO DO MORE BY
INCREASING ENROLLMENT OF
UNDERSERVED CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
INCREASE REGION SPECIFIC
RESEARCH IN AGRICULTURE CLEAN
AIR WATER CLIMATE CHANGE AND
MAKE MAJOR ADVANCEMENTS IN
HEALTHCARE BY ADVANCING MEDICAL
EDUCATION. AND RESEARCH THAT
ADDRESSES BOTH REGION'S
DISTINCTIVE HEALTH CHALLENGES.
RIGHT NOW THE UC IS ON TRACK TO
ENROLL JUST ONE SIX THE NUMBER
OF NEW STUDENTS CALLED FOR IN
THE BUDGET. GIVEN THE RIGHT
RESOURCES UC MERCED RIVERSIDE
COULDN'T ROLL FAR MORE THAN THE
SIXTY TWO HUNDRED NEW STUDENTS
THAT THE BUDGET CALLS FOR. AND
WE WOULD NOT NEED SPECIAL SECRET
LEGISLATION FAST TRACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO DO. FINALLY I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME
CONCERNS I'VE HEARD ABOUT
DIRECT. DIRECTING SPECIFIC
FUNDED INDIVIDUAL UC CAMPUSES
OUTSIDE OF THE GENERAL BUDGET
ALLOCATION. THE REALITY IS THAT
THE CURRENT UC CAMPUS FUNDING IS
INCREDIBLY REGRESSIVE. THE OLDER
RICHER AND MORE STAFFERS CABS
CAMPUSES RECEIVE THE LION'S
SHARE OF THE UC'S FORTY FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET. STATE
FUNDS BUILT THOSE ACADEMIC
MEDICAL CENTERS WHICH ARE HUGELY
PROFITABLE FOR THE- BUT THOSE
ARE. STAY AT THEIR RESPECTIVE
CAMPUSES INSTEAD OF BEING SPREAD
TO LIFT ALL BOATS. STATE FUNDING
ALSO MADE FEDERAL CONTRACTS
COPYRIGHT RESEARCH IN SPORTS
REVENUE POSSIBLE BUT AGAIN ALL
THAT REVENUE STATUS AT THE
RESPECTIVE. AB TWENTY FORTY SO
TEXAS TOWARDS A THIS IN THAT. BY
DIRECT SPECIAL INVESTMENT TOWARD
TWO OF THEM UNDER CAMPUS AND YOU
SEE SO. IN TWO OF THE MOST UNDER
REGION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO AND- JUST SAY
THIS IS OUR PER OUR MONEY WHERE
OUR MOUTH IS. WE'VE LAID OUT
VALUE WE WANT FOR THE UC SYSTEM
HERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A
HISTORIC INVESTMENT AT A TIME
THAT WE HAVE BILLIONS TO INVEST.
AND MAKE A REAL DIFFERENCE FOR
THESE REGIONS FOR OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE FOR CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMAN
. AND FOR THAT IS SO LONG-
CLOSING STATEMENT I HAVE HEARD.
ALL RIGHT- SINCE WE DON'T HAVE
ANY YET THE ORDERS JUST- WAIT
UNTIL QUORUM IS MADE THAT VOTE
ON THIS. AND I KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
MANY IS ON THE WAY. HEY THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG FOR HIS
PATIENCE AND WE WILL MOVE THEN.
TO ITEM. NUMBER SIX ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FOX. WHENEVER YOU ARE
READY. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FIRST OFF I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRED THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS A CONSULTANT FOR THE
HARD WORK AND EFFORTS ON THIS
BILL AND WITH THIS BILL EXCEPT
THE COMMITTEE. AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FIFTY
EIGHT CREATES THE COMMITTEE
CALLED STUDENT ACCESS RETENTION
AND THAT CANCELLATION PROGRAM
WHICH PROVIDE FUNDING TO THE
STARTS COMMITTEE COLLEGE
STUDENTS DEBT FOR UNPAID
BALANCES THIS BILL GIVES
COMMITTEE COLLEGES AND EFFECTIVE
TOOL TO RETAIN AND GROW THEIR
STUDENT ENROLLMENT. AS A RESULT
OF THE PANDEMIC THE RATES OF
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS GOING
DIRECTLY TO COMMIT COLLEGE AFTER
GRADUATION HAVE GREATLY DECLINED
FURTHER COMMITTEE COLLEGES HAVE
EXPERIENCED THE CLIENTS ITS
CURRENTLY STUDENTS AND LAST
ANNUAL BUDGET MADE A
MULTIMILLION DOLLAR OF
INVESTMENT IN SUPPORTING THE
EFFORTS OF ME COLLEGES TO
BOLSTER THEIR STUDENT RETENTION
RATES AND ENROLLMENT RATES THIS
APPROPRIATION HAS UNDOUBTEDLY
BEEN HELPFUL TO COMMIT COLLEGES
AND STUDENTS ALIKE. ASSEMBLY
BONUS FIFTY WOULD ESTABLISH A
PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY FOR TO
ENABLE ME COLLEGES TO DISCHARGE
THEIR STUDENTS INSTITUTIONAL
DEBT AND UNPAID BALANCES TO
COMMIT COLLEGES THEY ATTEND ONE
THE MOST COMMON OBSTACLES
RESIDENTS FACES COMPLAINING
EDUCATION IS IT. AND IT'S OVER
HELP ADDRESS THAT OP THE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ABBOTT. ARE
THEY- WITNESSES IN SOME. IT IN
THAT IN THE HEARING ROOM. THE DO
YOU HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT- ON THE ON THE PHONE
LINES. I DON'T BELIEVE SO NO
OKAY. SO NO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE ROOM EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR COULD YOU SEE IF
THEY'RE ANY WITNESSES ON SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE LINE. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO. TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF AB NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE FILED BY
ZERO. MISTER CHAIR NOBODY IS
KILLING UP. OKAY ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND THE
HEARING OR- C. NINE AND EIGHTEEN
T. MODERATOR COULD YOU SEE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE. WE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION
TO AB NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND MISTER CARE NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME. AND ARE
THERE ANY TWEETERS IN THE
HEARING ROOM. C. NINE EIGHTY TWO
MODERATOR IF THERE ANY WINNERS
ON THE PHONE LINES. NOBODY IS
GOING UP MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU-
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. YES. LANCASTER
MINIMUM MEMBER OF FONG- I THINK
THIS IS ALSO A POSITIVE
DIRECTION BUT I HAVE SOME
SPECIFIC QUESTION SAID DO YOU
HAVE ANY OUR QUALIFYING-
DEFINITIONS SELF FOR THE
CANDIDATES TO HOLD TO GET THIS
OUT THAT- EXEMPTION OR
CANCELLATION. THANK YOU SO MUCH
A SIMILAR CHOI THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPERIOR ON TERMS OF THE
QUALIFICATIONS FOR THIS PROGRAM
WERE CURRENTLY MEETING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE COMMISSION TO
REALLY DELINEATE THE- OUTCOMES
AND THE- PROGRAM MODEL FOR THAT
SO WE'RE IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
THEM AND WE CAN DEFINITELY KEEP
YOU POSTED ON THIS. I'M THERE
ANY. I THOUGHT THAT WE HAVE-
SEVERAL DIFFERENT KINDS OF-
THOSE CHILDREN THAT THE
CANCELLATION PROGRAMS OF
FEDERALLY AND THEN ALSO
STATEWIDE TO. WHY DOES IT HAVE
TO BE A SPECIFICALLY FOR THE UC.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS. RICK
I THINK IT'S A CHOICE FOR THE
QUOTE. IN TERMS OF THE CHEMICAL
A ROMAN WE SEEM TO CLIENTS AND
TO MAKE COLLEGE A ROMAN OF
101520% ACROSS A NUMBER OF OUR
DISTRICTS HERE IN. CALIFORNIA
AND OF THE SENATE THREE TO MAKE
COLLEGE DISTRICTS FRANCE'S DELIC
MAKE COLLEGE JUST BECAUSE IN THE
CLIENT'S OF 1015% ACROSS A
NUMBER OF THE COLLEGES AND SO
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN TO THE
STATE AS AN ORGANIZATION TO HELP
OFFSET SOME OF THESE COSTS. IN
TERMS OF STUDENT RETENTION AND
STUDENT SUCCESS IS CRITICAL IN
OUR EDUCATIONAL JOURNEY SO THIS
IS ANOTHER AVENUE TO REALLY
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
STUDENTS TO CONTINUE THEIR
EDUCATION. AND THE YOU KNOW
QUESTION PUZZLING ME IS THAT THE. PROBABLY CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES OUT ONE OF THE
CHEAPEST- AND THE MANY MANY
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES- THAT THE
STUDENTS THAT CAN TAKE. COURSES
NOW FREE OF CHARGE- OF VERY VERY
MINIMAL FEES I DO ANY-
STATISTICS YOU YOU HAVE- THIS
SEEING THAT THE HOW MANY
GRADUATES- WHO ARE REALLY
SUFFERING. FROM THIS CELL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE- EDUCATION
THAT. SAW THAT THE WE HAVE TO
TAKE A MEASURE HERE BECAUSE OF
ME THERE ARE MANY MANY PROGRAMS
SAID THAT THE PEOPLE ARE
DIFFERENT CATEGORIES SO WHO
QUALIFY. ALMOST A FREE EDUCATION
AND I THOUGHT ALL THE- FIRST
YEAR. COMMITTEE COLLEGES
CITATION FREE AND THEY EVERY FOR
THERE IS A VERY THAT VERY MANY
MORE. MANY MORE YOU KNOW FEES US
ALL THE TOTAL THAT- BE THAT BIG
. THANK YOU SIMILAR CHOI FOR THE
QUESTION IN TERMS OF THE DEBT
FOR CHEMICAL AS SOON AS WE KNOW
THAT ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
STUDENT CLEARINGHOUSE RESEARCH
CENTER THE COLLEGE GOING RATE
FOR CHEMICAL INCIDENTS FELL 22%
AT FAULT TWENTY TWENTY COMPARED
TO THE PRIOR YEAR. AND IN TERMS
OF THEIR ROMAN RIGHT FOR FULL
TIME STUDENTS GOING FORWARD AT
17% LESS THAN PREPAYMENT LEVELS
AND THIRTEEN BUT PERCENT LESS
FOR PART TIME STUDENTS AND AS
YOU MENTIONED WITH ASSEMBLY BILL
TWO INNOCENT BILL NINETEEN TO
REALLY HELP ON NICHOLAS
ENTERTAINER. WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S A LOT MORE COST TO GOING
TO MAKE COLLEGE THIS INDUSTRY
STATIONERS BOOKS. ON THERE'S A
NUMBER OF ADDITIONAL COST TO. IN
TERMS OF EDUCATIONAL JOURNEY AND
SO ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO AS A
STATE- WITH THIS BILL TO HELP.
REDUCE OUR DEBT FOR OUR STUDENTS
AND HELP THEM CONTINUE THEIR
EDUCATION IS CRITICAL- TO MOVING
AND BUILDING THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA'S WORK FORCES WALL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. C. NINE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE I THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY OFFER AN AYE VOTE.
RIGHT I THANK THE ASSEMBLY FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORD.
APPRECIATE IN WORKING WITH THE
STAFF OUR COMMITTEE STAFF AND
FOR TAKING THE AMENDMENTS- IN
LIGHT OF THE DECLINE IN ROMAN OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE ENSURE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE COLLEGES HAVE
EVERY AVAILABLE TOOL TOOL TO
ENCOURAGE ENROLLMENT AND RE
ENROLLMENT OF STUDENTS. AT THAT
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SO- OF NOT HAVING A QUORUM. WE
WILL WAIT TILL WE GET A QUORUM
TO TAKE A VOTE. AND WE WILL THEN
MOVE ON TO ITEM SEVEN. A. B.
TWENTY TWO FIFTY FIVE. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY MR FONG. THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS- GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO FIFTY
FIVE ESTABLISHES THE AFFORDABLE
BROADBAND SERVICE PROGRAM FOR
CALIFORNIA STREAMERS. THE MODERN
REALITY IS THAT AT INTERNET
ACCESSIBILITY IS ESSENTIAL FOR
VIRTUALLY ALL INDIVIDUALS YEAH
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS STILL
LACK ACCESS TO A QUALITY HIGH
SPEED RELIABLE INTERNET. IN
ADDITION EVEN THOUGH MANY
CALIFORNIANS. WITH INTERNET
ACCESS LAST INTERNET SPEEDS THAT
MEET THE NEEDS HAS WINDOWS
ENVIRONMENT WITH ZOOM'S
EVERYTHING ELSE IS A VERY
INTENSE. INTERNET REQUIREMENTS
THE LEGISLATURE HAS TAKEN
MEANINGFUL STEPS TO TOWARDS
CLOSING THE GAP ON INTERNET
ACCESSIBILITY FURTHER THESE
STEPS HAVE INCLUDED INVESTMENTS
IN BROADBAND FOR STUDENTS. AND
WITHIN EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
THESE INVESTMENTS SHOULD INCLUDE
EXPANDING BROADBAND SERVICES FOR
CALIFORNIA'S DREAMERS. COOLEY
DREAMERS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
FINANCIAL AID THROUGH KELP GRANT
B. WHICH IS MEANT TO HELP. PAY
FOR BOOKS AND OTHER COLLEGE
COSTS HOWEVER THE MIDDLE ROAD
AND LAST MILE PROJECTS. STILL
NEED TO BE COMPLETED AND EVERY
CALIFORNIA HAS ACCESS TO QUALITY
BROADBAND. ACCESS UNTIL THEN
MANY DREAMERS WILL CONTINUE TO
FACE UNIQUE CHALLENGES AND
ACCESSING BROADBAND TO CONTINUE
THEIR- JOURNEY HERE. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FIVE TO FIFTY FIVE
ESTABLISHES AFFORDABLE BROADBAND
SERVICE PROGRAM FOR CALIFORNIA
STREAMERS AND ITS PROGRAM WOULD
BE DEVELOPED AND ADMINISTERED
THE PARTNERSHIP OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID. THE
COMMISSION WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
AFFORDABLE. TO DREAMERS IRIS ASK
FOR NOT. IT WOULD IN SUPPORT. HI
DAVE I DON'T BELIEVE SO I DON'T
- AT&T MODERATOR THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ON THE
PHONE LINES. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR A BI
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE
FILED BY ZERO. CALIFORNIA VOEPEL
BOOK AND NOBODY IS QUEUING UP.
OKAY ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES- IN
OPPOSITION. FOR AB WOULD LIKE DO
I NEED TO FIFTY FIVE. THAT COULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. ONE CHILD BY ZERO. AND
MISTER CHAIR NOBODY IS KILLING
UP- AGAINST WITH LONG. TO- OKAY
ALL RIGHT OUR MODERATOR WOULD
YOU ASK FOR SUPPORT FOR SUPPORT
LET'S GO BY AGAIN IF YOU WOULD
GO BACK AND ASK FOR SUPPORT FOR
A BI. TWENTY TWO FIFTY FIVE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
TWO FIFTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. AND NOT MISTER CHAIR
NOBODY IS KILLING UP OKAY IF-
ANY TWEETERS IN THE- HARIAN ROOM
SEEN NONE. AND WHY INTO.
MIGRATED ME ONE PERSON JUST
QUEUED UP OKAY I'LL BE WHAT THE
SOMEONE MOMENT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THERE WITH AN OPERATOR.
YEAH AND LYFT ONE EIGHTY SIX YOU
ARE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL MY
NAME IS BACK AT AND I AM FROM
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA STUDENT
ASSOCIATION I WOULD LIKE TO
VOICE MY SUPPORT FOR THE FILM
THANK YOUNG. THANK YOU NOW
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR IF THERE
ANY BETWEEN OR IS ON THE PHONE
LINE FOR AB. TWENTY TWO FIFTY
FIVE. ONE CHILD BY ZERO IF YOU
ARE. BETWEEN- ON THIS BILL. AND
NOBODY'S QUEUING UP MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR WILL GO
THEN TO THE COMMITTEE. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. DR CHOI.
SORRY TO ASK YOU A QUESTION THE-
I CAN SEE YOUR INTENT TO HELP
OUR STUDENTS TO WAR IN NEED THE
FINANCIALLY. AND- MY
UNDERSTANDING ON BOTH BROADBAND-
WOULD BE ELECT- INTERNET WIFI
ACCESS WHY. INCLUDE A WIFI
BROADBAND ACCESS TO THE INTERNET
CORRECT YEAH. IN INCOME
QUALIFIED AND THAT THIS ONE IS
OUR TARGET IS SELF FOR DREAMERS. WE KNOW THAT THE THOSE
CATEGORY UP PEOPLE ARE. THE
CHILDREN OF OUR- ARE
UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE WHY DOES IT
HAVE TO BE OUT FOR THE DREAMER
SO ON THE- WHEN STUDENTS CIRCLE
COLLEGE THEY APPLIED FOR. OUR
FEATHER AND A STATE. ALL KINDS
OF- THE GRANTS AND- IN HOUSES
SCHOLARSHIPS ETCETERA AND THAT
ALSO SHOULD BE ARE ALL INCLUDED
IF FOR THAT IS- EVAN. YOU KNOW I
PAY ABOUT THE FIFTY FIVE DOLLARS
A MONTH- HIGH SPEED OVER A
HUNDRED. MEGABYTES OF PULP. BUT
I THINK THE SUPPORT SECOND-
ENDED A CERTAINLY NOT OVER A
HUNDRED DOLLARS- I THINK BECAUSE
RAJIDAE SOMEWHERE BELOW SEVENTY
OR EIGHTY DOLLARS SO. AND IF OF
THIS AID IS INDEED THAT NEEDED
TO FOR THAT THE PARTICULAR GROUP
OF US CHILDREN SO. WHY CAN'T YOU
MAKE IT THE- MORE INCOME INCOME
QUALIFIED THE LOW INCOME
STUDENTS RATHER THAN DREAMERS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SO MUCH MORE
FOR THE QUESTION WE KNOW THAT
INTERNET ACCESS IS A VERY MUCH
AN ISSUE FOR MANY UNIVERSITY
STUDENTS INCLUDING MANY STUDENTS
FROM LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS IN
TERMS OF THIS PARTICULAR
LEGISLATION FOR DREAMERS. THEY
FACE A UNIQUE CHALLENGE OF THEIR
IN AN ELIGIBILITY TO PELL GRANTS
BECAUSE OF THEIR UNDOCUMENTED
STATUS SO FOR THIS REASON A
PROGRAM THAT ADDRESSES THE
SPECIFIC BROADBAND NEEDS IS A
NECESSARY FOR DREAMERS. I AYE
SHE SAID THEY ARE NOT- ENTITLED
TO OF FEDERAL AID THE OR OR WHAT
BUT- I'M I'M CURIOUS TO MAY BE-
I NEED TO BE UPDATED- OKAY. CAL
GRANT IS NOT AVAILABLE
CALIFORNIA- HOW DO WE MAKE A
DISTINCTION. FOR DOES SO. GROUP
OF PAPER ESPECIALLY DREAMERS. SO
DREAMERS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
FINANCIAL AID THROUGH KRAUT
CRAPPIE BUT THIS IS FOR A POWER
GRANTED TO REALLY MAKE SURE THAT
STUDENTS HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITY IN PARTS OF THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE COMMISSION TO
ADDRESS THE UNIQUE CHALLENGES-
FOR DREAMERS. OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. DR WEBER HI THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL
SO I'M SO THESEARE NOT FOR CAL
GRANT BE STUDENTS IT'S FOR
PROGRAM. IS THAT WOULD AT. WHAT
WAS THAT YOU JUST IT'S FOR THE-
CALVET GRAND PRIX- RECIPIENTS
CORRECT OKAY- I'M- IS THERE ANY-
ANYTHING AROUND THIS PARTICULAR
LIKE BESIDES BEING A DREAMER ARE
THERE ANY OTHER CRITERIA IN
ORDER TO- QUALIFY ARE THERE IS
THERE A SPECIFIC AMOUNT OF THE
GRANT THAT WOULD BE AWARDED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF SUMMER
WEBER QUICK QUESTION AND TERMS
OF THE FUNDING SOURCE AND
RELATED WORKING OUT THE DETAILS
WERE TRYNA ARC STAFF'S BEEN A
TEAM IN CONTACT WITH CALPERS
TODAY COMMISSION AND THOSE A
AMENDMENTS WOULD BE MADE IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS- PROCESS BUT WORK
CURRENTLY CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE- CITY COMMISSION TO FINALIZE
THE DETAILS OKAY AND LIKE. OTHER
LIKE ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA WOULD
THEY HAVE TO PROVE THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO IT AND THAT
THEY LIVE OFF CAMPUS AND- THOSE.
IN IT'S NOT JUST KIND OF LIKE AN
OPEN DOOR IF YOU'RE A DREAMER
YOU GET ACCESS TO HIS SONS NO
THAT'S GREAT QUESTION SO THE- OF
ITEMS THAT WILL TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION IN THE SENATE AND
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE AND-
COMMISSION. THANK YOU FOR BEFORE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AN OTHER
QUESTION OR- FROM THE- A SCENE
NINE- ASSEMBLY FONG IF YOU'D
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
HER COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS
COMMENTS AND DICKEY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY VOTE.
RIGHT THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FOR.
BROADBAND INTERNET AS WE'VE SAID
HERE IS CRUCIAL PRODUCES
SUCCESS. OF ALL OUR STUDENTS. IT
DREAMERS DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
THE SAME PROGRAM. AS MANY OF
THEIR PEERS. THE ANALYSIS NOTES
THAT AREAS THAT NEED TO BE
EXPANDED. AND I UNDERSTAND AS
YOU'VE SAID THAT YOU PLAN TO
ADDRESS. THOSE THOSE AREAS THAT
NEED TO BE EXPANDED MOVING
pPLEASE KEEP MY COMMITTEE. A
STAFF INFORMED OF YOUR PROGRESS.
AND WE STILL DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM. SO WE WILL TAKE IT UP
WHEN WE DO. THANK YOU SO MUCH A
COMMITTEE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND NOW WE WILL MOVE TO
FILE ITEM. EIGHT A. B. TWENTY
ZERO FOUR. ASSEMBLY GARCIA. WHEN
YOU ARE READY. WELCOME THANK YOU
THANK YOU AB TWO THOUSAND AND
FOUR WILL ENSURE UNDOCUMENTED
YOUTH WHO OBTAIN CALIFORNIA
DREAM LOAN WE PROPOSED WILL BE
PROVIDED CRITICAL RESOURCES
ABOUT THE OBTAINMENT REPAYMENT
AND RELIEF OPTIONS AVAILABLE TO
THEM AT THE BAR. THIS BILL WILL
CLARIFY THE A MODEST INCOME
BORROW FOR UNDERGRADUATE STUDIES
AND GRADUATE STUDIES SEEKS TO
ESTABLISH LOAN FORGIVENESS
PROGRAMS AND REQUIRES
PARTICIPATING INSTITUTIONS TO
REPORTED DIGITAL SADDAM BORROWER
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA. THIS BILL WILL
FURTHER MAYOR FEDERAL STUDENT
LOAN PAYMENT DEFERRALS REPAYMENT
PLANS THAT RELIEVE REPAYMENT
PROCESS THIS TRY TO THAT AS WELL
AS ESTABLISH MORE LOW EDUCATION
FOR THE STUDENTS TO ACCEPT THESE
LOANS. AB TWO THOUSAND AND FOUR
ALSO ADDS ADDITIONAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FROM THE
UNIVERSITIES TO THE LEGISLATURE. NOW MORE THAN EVER
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS WILL TURN
TO THE CALIFORNIA DREAM LOAN
PROGRAM AT FINANCIAL AID OPTIONS
AND WE MUST ENSURE THE PROGRAM
IS FINANCIALLY STRONG AND
PROVIDES THE SAME INSTITUTIONAL
EDUCATION. AND BARLEY FAST OTHER
STUDENT LOANS AB TWO THOUSAND
AND FOUR WILL CREATE GREATER
PARITY FOR THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
LONG STUDENT BORROWERS AND GIVE
THEM THE SAME RESOURCES THAT ARE
AFFORDED TO FEDERAL STUDENT LOAN
BORROWERS. THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE COALITION OF
HUMANE IMMIGRANTS RIGHTS AND THE
WESTERN CENTER ON POVERTY LAW
AND IS A LATINO CAUCUS PRIORITY.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
TODAY IS EIGHT CFL ENOUGH AN
UNDERGRAD STUDENT AT CAL PLY
POMONA. WHO IS A DREAM LUMBAR
AND VALLEY ACKLES TESTED IN THAT
LEGAL LAW SCHOOL WITH THE LEGAL
IMMIGRANT IMMIGRANT JUSTICE
CLINIC. ADDITIONALLY WE HAVEN'T
READ A MEDINA WITH SHEILA AND
CHRIS SANCHEZ WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY TO
ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU. AND
YOU. BABE THE WHENEVER REDY.
WELCOME. GERMAN MEDINA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS JUST SOMETHING THAT I AM
TWENTY FIVE YEARS OLD BOB GRAHAM
I AM FINISHING MY LAST SEMESTER
CAL POLY POMONA I WILL BE
GRADUATING THE PRODUCTION
ATTENTION I HAVE BEEN INTERESTED
IN. MY DAD IS BECAUSE- AND I WAS
THE- I COULD TO TALK ABOUT THE
BOND. OKAY RIGHT OKAY BROWN AND
WHAT MAKE THEMSELVES. BUT IN THE
QUARTER OF THE AND I'LL BE THE
TO MAKE. TO ACTUALLY. FOR MY-
WHO THANK. OF THE WHICH APPROACH
. DEGREE THAT.
I THOUGHT ANOTHER FINANCIAL
INFORMATION THAT CAN HELP US
MAKE BETTER FINANCIAL DECISIONS
FOR OURSELVES. I THINK THIS BILL
CAN HELP. CAN ALSO HELP MY
YOUNGER BROTHERS UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEY'RE AGREEING TO IF THEY
CHOOSE TO GET A COLLEGE YOU
KNOW. I WAS NINETEEN THE FIRST
TIME I WORK I TOOK A DREAM LOAN.
IT WAS AT THE END OF MY FIRST
YEAR OF UNDERGRAD I LEARNED
ABOUT IT THROUGH THE- FINANCIAL
AID AT MY- BOB EIGHT PLUS. FOR
ME IT I KNEW BIGELOW BUT I DID A
UNDERSTAND HOW IT WORKED BUT FOR
THE FOR THE CLINTONS. I IT'S THE
FIVE I FOR THE THERE WAS A
FAMILY AND I NEED. A FOR MY
UNIVERSITY. I WAS NOT WELL
PREPARED MAKE IT THE- A HOT
LITTLE. ABOUT WHAT IT MEANT TAKE
OUT A LOAN. BUT I KNEW GET COULD
BE BUT THE PRESSURE ON LIFELINE
TO PAY FOR MY TO. SO IT WOULD
WORTH IT. THE LAST STREAM. LOOK
OUT WHAT THEY- AND I. DON'T AND
UNDER. I STILL DON'T KNOW BUT
QUESTION ARE. THE MOST AGENTS-
URGED ME TO IT BECAUSE AND- FROM
MUCH. ON HOW TO BIRD EMAIL I A
FOR IN LAW. CONVERSELY ABOUT.
WHAT ABOUT GEN. BUT THE
CONFUSION AND FEAR WERE. REAL NO
ONE HAD WALKED ME THROUGH THE
PROCESS- ANSWERED MY QUESTIONS
BUDGET UPON COMPLETION. AND IF
THIS HAPPENED TO ME IT CAN
HAPPEN TO OTHER STUDENTS. WE
NEED BETTER WAYS TO GET INFORMED
VILLAGERS BEING THERE FOR TO A
CONFUSING BUT LIKE THIS BILL
WOULD HELP WITH THAT. I'M
LOOKING TO SECURE A JOB BEFORE
GRADUATE. AT THAT POINT I WILL
HAVE TO START PAYING OFF. I
FINALLY GOT MYSELF IN. THE GYM
ALONE. REFINANCED STRASBOURG B.
WELL ME AND MY FAMILY. BUT I
WOULD HAVE LIKED TO HAVE.
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT COULD
HAVE HAPPENED AFTER GRADUATION.
OPTIONS BOB IN MY LOAN TO THIRD
OR EVEN BY FOR. THE PUBLIC THE
AS I AM MUCH. ABOUT THE FIRST
JOB I GUESS OUT OF. STATE
SELLERS BUT BEFORE. AND LET ME
PAID BACK I. HATE BY IN QUESTION
HAPPENED MY THE ANY BETTER WE
DON'T BRENT ARE MORE FLOWER THEY
WERE EVEN YOU'RE A CO THERE'S NO
QUESTION BUT THE GERMANS THE
FINANCIALS FOR BOTH MY FAMILY I
THINK BETTER FOR ME BUT WE COULD
BE BACK FOR AND UNDERSTAND FOR
THE RED. INVOLVED WOULD HAVE
ALLOWED US TO BETTER TO AND
PAPER THAT I THINK THE PROGRAM
THE OPPORTUNITY FAMILY LIKE MINE
THE BILL BUT IN THE BOOK.
THIS. GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SALLY R.
COSTA AND I'M A THIRD YEAR LAW
STUDENT WITH LOYOLA LAW SCHOOL'S
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE CLINIC HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWO ZERO ALL FOR
LOWELL IS IMMIGRANT JUSTICE
CLINIC PROVIDES ASSISTANCE TO IT
TO ADVANCE THE RIGHTS OF
IMMIGRANT OF THE IMMIGRANT
POPULATION IN THE EAST LOS
ANGELES AREA THREE DIRECTLY GO
SERVICES EDUCATION AND COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT. FOR SEVERAL MONTHS
MY COLLEAGUES AND I HAVE WORKED
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY CONDUCTING RESEARCH
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA DREAM LOAN
PROGRAM THE DREAM LOAN PROGRAM
IS AN EXCELLENT PROGRAM THAT
ASSISTS STUDENTS IN FINANCING
THEIR EDUCATION IT IS THE ONLY
STATE LOAN PROGRAM THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR.
THROUGH OUR RESEARCH WE HAVE
FOUND THAT THE CURRENT PROGRAM
ONLY ALLOWS FOR DISCHARGING
FORBEARANCE BUT THERE ARE STILL
SOME PROVISIONS THAT DON'T
COMPLETE THE FEDERAL LOAN
PROGRAMS SUCH AS FALSE
CERTIFICATION- FILING FOR
BANKRUPTCY. THERE ARE CURRENTLY
NO ADMINISTRATIVE RELIEF
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE SUCH AS
EMERGENCY RELIEF DURING NATURAL
DISASTERS. ALTHOUGH THE SYSTEM
GRANTED TEMPORARY FORBEARANCE
DURING THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. IT WASN'T CLEAR TO
MANY STUDENTS WHETHER THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR FORBEARANCE OVER OR
WHETHER THEY HAD TO PROVIDE
PAYMENT DURING THE PANDEMIC. WE
WORRY ABOUT OTHER FORMS OF
NATURAL DISASTERS SUCH AS THE
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRES THAT OFTEN
DISPLAYS AND PUT PEOPLE AND
UNSTABLE FINANCIAL SITUATIONS.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE PROTECTIONS ARE IN
STATUTE FOR ANY STATE OF
EMERGENCIES. WE ALSO FOUND THAT
THE PROBE. HE LOAN FORGIVENESS
PROGRAMS CURRENTLY SET FORTH IN
THE FEDERAL PROGRAM SUCH AS THE
PUBLIC SERVICE LOAN FORGIVENESS
. THE TEACHER LOAN FORGIVENESS
AND OTHER LOAN FORGIVENESS
PROGRAMS TO THOSE PURSUING A
CAREER IN THE HEALTHCARE
INDUSTRY. TODAY DREAMLAND BARS
CONTINUE TO FACE REPAYMENT
DESPITE REYES TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES. PUBLIC SERVICE ARE
ENTERING A DEMANDING FIELD. THE
FEDERAL STUDENT LOAN PROGRAM HAS
INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE LIKE ME TO
FOLLOW THE FEEL THE PUBLIC
INTEREST KNOWING THAT ONE DAY I
WILL ACT I WILL HAVE ACCESS TO A
PUBLIC SERVICE LOAN PROGRAM. THE
STATE OF KEPT THE STATE BAR OF
CALIFORNIA HAS GRANTED
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS WITH
LICENSES TO PRACTICE IN THE
STATE. I ASK MYSELF WHAT IS THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN ME AND
UNDOCUMENTED BORROWER THOSE
PROVIDING SERVICES TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES DESERVE ACCESS TO
THESE LONG. IT THE INTENT OF
PLEASURE TO CREATE INEQUITY
AMONG STUDENT LOAN BORROWERS AND
IT IS KNOWN THAT UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS FACE GREATER
DIFFICULTIES IN FINANCING THEIR
EDUCATION. AB TWENTY OH FOUR
WILL STRENGTHEN AND ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS ARE AWARE OF ALL FORMS
OF RELIEF. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I WOULD PERJURE I VOTE
ON AB TWO ZERO ZERO FOUR. THANK
YOU. OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
COME FORWARD NAME ORGANIZATION
YOU'RE WITH. THAT NUMBER
EXPECTED RESPONSE OF OCTOBER THE
BOXES THAT ARE ON POVERTY THE
PART OF IT BEFORE BUT THANK YOU
. BACTEREMIA MY VERY LONG FOR ME
WILL EVER ACCEPT. THANK YOU. DO
WITH THE HELP ME FIGURE
INFORMATION AB 200-044-2004
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEDINA HAD COAL FOR AND RIGHTS
UP BECAUSE OF THE BILL THANK YOU
AND NOW IT MODERATE- IF- WE HAVE
HE- OTHERS. IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY OH FOUR ON THE LINE. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SHOW SUPORT
FOR A B. TWO ZERO ZERO FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE VOTE BY GENERAL AND
WHICH CAROLINE TO TWENTY SIX.
PLEASE GO AHEAD TWENTY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN DENIED THIS
IS KATRINA LONDON ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA AND DOCUMENTED.
HIGHER EDUCATION COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO ZERO
ZERO FOUR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BY TWO FORTY FIVE YOU ARE OPEN.
TWO FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWO FORTY FIVE ONE MORE SHOT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO. SHOW SUPPORT. I WILL MOVE ALONG TO A LINE TO
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JANE CAN- WITH
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER WERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY OH FOUR THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND IT FINALLY PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO SHOW
SUPPORT FOR EIGHT. ZERO ZERO
FOUR AND WE WERE BLIND TWO FOUR
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
STATE THAT YOU'RE CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE I COULD NOT
WORK I'M GOING TO SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY TWO ZERO ZERO FOUR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. YOUR CARE THERE
NO OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME THANK YOU. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM. CNN IS AN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE
MISTER MODERATOR. YOU IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO. TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWO ZERO ZERO
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO ONE FILED BY ZERO.
MISTER CHAIR NOBODY IS QUEUING
UP THANK YOU ANY TWEETERS IN THE
HEARING ROOM. AND EIGHTEEN TO
MODERATE ANY TWEETERS ON THE
LINE. WHAT SOUTH BY ZERO IF YOU
ARE A TWEENER. AND MISTER CHAIR-NOBODY IS QUEUING UP THANK YOU
ARE ALLOWED TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. C. NINE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE ADJUSTING KEEP RETIREMENT
I WANT TO THANK OUR WITNESSES
FOR MAKING TIME TO BEING
RESPECTFULLY ASK FINAL VOTE.
THANK THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN BRING A
BILL FORWARD. I'M SO PLEASED TO
SUPPORT IT AND I BELIEVE THAT WE
GIVE OUR DREAMERS PARITY WE
SHOULD GIVE OUR DREAMERS PARITY.
STUDENTS WHO THE ABILITY TO HAVE
THEIR LOANS FORGIVEN SO THANK
YOU FOR THE BILL AND WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM WE WILL TAKE A
VOTE SO NOW WE WILL GO TO.
THANKS FILE ITEM. FILE ITEM NINE
A. B. TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FOUR
THIS GARCIA WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU AB TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY FOUR WOULD REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY TO
GRANT AN EMPLOYEE LEAVE OF
ABSENCE WITH PAY FOR ONE
SEMESTER OF AN ACADEMIC YEAR
FOLLOWING THE BIRTH OF A CHILD
OF THE EMPLOYEE OR THE PLACEMENT
OF A CHILD WITH AN EMPLOYEE.
ACTUALLY XIN. OKAY EMPLOYEE THE
CSU BRENT LEAVE OF THIRTY DAYS
NEEDS TO BE UPDATED TO REFLECT
TODAY'S REALITIES FACING THE
SYSTEMS TWENTY NINE THOUSAND.
COACH COUNSELING LIBRARIAN AN
INSTRUCTIONAL FACULTY WHO ARE
STARTING OR EXPANDING THEIR
FAMILIES THE CSE'S EXPECTATIONS
FOR WHAT FACULTY MEMBERS HAVE TO
DO TO SPEND TIME WITH THEIR
NEWBORN. AND ALLOW THEIR BODIES
TO HEAL ARE UNREALISTIC FACULTY
MEMBERS OFTEN HAVE TO TRY TO
TIME IN THE BIRTH IN ORDER TO
MAXIMIZE THEIR TIME AWAY FROM
WORK BASICALLY THEY HAVE TO
SCHEDULE THEIR CHILD'S SPORTS
DURING THE SUMMER OF. IF THIS
YEAR'S USUALLY COULD. INTEREST
SUCH RACISM NEVER CITY AND
INCLUSION AS IT CLAIMS TO BE CSU
MANAGEMENT WOULD HAVE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SIGNED OFF ON THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATIONS
PROPOSAL. TO EXPAND PARENTAL
LEAVE AND COME CLOSER TO
PROVIDING THEIR WORK LIFE
BALANCE BUT IS CSU MANAGEMENT
SHOWS TRAIN AND ANTIQUATED LEE
POLICY THAT THIS FOR. PARTLY
IMPACTS MEN AND FACULTY COLOR.
THE SCREEN ALL A THREAT TO THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
EMPLOYEES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THE CSU DISPARITY IN PARENTAL
LEAVE CONTINUES TO SET THE U. S.
APART FROM OTHER COUNTRIES.
DAVICH LANE FOR COUNTRIES WITH
NATIONAL PAID PARENTAL LEAVE IS
TWENTY NINE WEEKS. THE CSE
SHOULD BE ABLE TO MEET THIS
BASIC STANDARD. ONE SIMPLE BUT
SIGNIFICANT WEIGHT THANK SURE
THAT WE RETAIN WOMEN OF COLOR ON
FACULTY IS TO COMMIT TO A
SEMESTER TO TERM PARENTAL LEAVE.
A MINIMUM WOULD BENEFIT STUDENTS
IN MANY WAYS AND FACULTY ARE
PROVIDED A SEMESTER OFF. THEY'RE
LESS LIKELY TINKERING WITH
SCHEDULES AND PRESSURE ON
FACULTY TO FIND OTHER TO TAKE
OVER THEIR WORKLOAD. WHICH THAT
BURDEN ON FAT DANNATT STRESS
THAT. COULD BE SPENT ARE A-
THING. BECAUSE CSU EAST I THINK
PROVIDING AT PRINCE LEAVE THE
CONTRA NEGOTIATIONS. AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY FOUR IS CRITICAL
LEGISLATION FOR ENSURING THAT
THE CSU PROVIDE ITS EMPLOYEES
WITH NECESSARY PARENTAL.
PERRANCE TESTIFIED IN PERSON
TODAY IS TO MAKE ON A DONALD
LECTURE OF SOCIAL AND POLITICAL
HISTORY I MEMBERS SEE A SAVE CFA
STATEWIDE BARGAIN IN TEAM.
TESTIFY REMOTELY IS ON A LAURA
OR DINNER- A JD MBA PHD CFA
CAPITAL CHAPTER VICE PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEDINA AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MEGAN O'DONNELL AND I'M A
FACULTY MEMBER AT CAL STATE
MONTEREY BAY AS WELL AS THE SEA
OF A STATE WIDE AB P. FOR
LECTURERS AND A MEMBER OF OUR
CFA BARGAINING. SPEAKING ON
BEHALF. B. TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
FOUR CFA IS A PROUD SPONSOR OF
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION AND
I'D LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA FOR BEING ITS AUTHOR SOME
PEOPLE MIGHT BE ASKING WHY DO WE
NEED THIS BILL MY NETWORK TO
EXPAND PARENTAL LEAVE THROUGH
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING INSTEAD.
HOWEVER IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT ADEQUATE PAID
PARENTAL LEAVE SHOULD NOT JUST
BE A PERK OR BENEFIT THAT COMES
WITH THE NECKLACE AND THEY'RE
THIS IS A PUBLIC POLICY ISSUE
THIS IS AN EQUAL RIGHT IT. THE
NEW FAIRNESS AND INCLUDE. WE
KNOW FROM DATA ACROSS THE NATION
INCLUDING HEARING. THAT AN
ADEQUATE SUPPORT FOR WORKING
PARENTS INCLUDING A LACK OF PAID
PARENTAL LEAVE. IS A DRIVING
FORCE AND WOMEN LEAVING THE
WORKPLACE. WE ALSO KNOW THAT
INADEQUATE SUPPORT FOR PARENTS
HAS A LONG TERM DISPARITY IMPACT
ON WORKING MOTHERS RELATED TO
THEIR PAY. PROMOTION AND XIN.
MICHAEL T. IN THE SEAT WE OFTEN
CALL THE QUOTE MOMMY TAX. BUT IN
REALITY IT'S SYSTEMIC INEQUALITY
AND IT REFLECTS THE LONG HISTORY
OF SEXISM IN OUR SOCIETY THAT
PENALIZES WOMEN SPECIFICALLY AND
PROFESSIONALLY WHEN THEY GIVE
BIRTH OR ADOPT A CHILD. THANK
YOU HE'S RELATED I DON'T NINE IT
IS CRITICAL AND NOT LEAVE
PARENTAL LEAVE HAS SUCH WAITING
PATIENCE FOR THE- INCLUSION OF
WOMEN IN THE CSU. TO THE HANDS
OF AN EMPLOYER WHO HAS PROVEN
REPEATEDLY THAT THEY ARE NOT UP
TO THE TASK. WE'RE STILL THEIR
ACTIONS DEMONSTRATE A LACK OF
CARE AND A LACK OF SERIOUSNESS.
I CAN'T FIRST BADLY. ANCES AT
THE- TABLE WITH. NOT ONLY WERE
THEY DISINTERESTED IN WORKING
WITH US EARNESTLY ON PARENTAL
LEAVE THEY REFUSE TO DEVELOP A
SINGLE COUNTER PROPOSAL ON THE
ISSUE WE PROPOSE DURING
BARGAINING FOR MORE THAN A YEAR
AND A HALF. WHEN PRESSED TO
JUSTIFY THE REFUSAL TO AND WITH
US IN GOOD FAITH ON THIS ISSUE.
THEIR CHIEF NEGOTIATOR BASICALLY
SAID QUOTE WE ARE IN THE HABIT
OF PAYING PEOPLE NOT TO WORK.
THE FRAME PARENTAL LEAVE LIKE
THAT IS AN OUTRAGE BUT
THANKFULLY THE LEGISLATURE HAS
THE POWER TO MODEL THE KIND OF
MORAL LEADERSHIP MISSING IN THE
CSU. THIS GOES TO THE HEART OF
WHO WE ARE AS A STATE AND THE
VALUES WE ESPOUSE AROUND JUSTICE
AND FAIRNESS. AND THE
LEGISLATURE CANNOT THROUGH THIS
BILL FORCE A CULTURE SHIFT IN
THE CSU AND HOW IT VIEWS AND
TREATS WHAT. PARENTS THE
MAJORITY OF WHICH ARE WOMEN. I
RESPECTFULLY EQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS CRITICAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. OTHER
WITNESSES IN IN SUPPORT. OF THE
PHONE ON THE PHONE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR. THANK YOU YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE
FALL BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. THEIR
SECOND WHERE WE WILL GO OUT ON
THE LINE. MISTER ROGER. WE'RE
LOOKING FOR AND WHAT THEY ARE
AND LUNA LUNA ORDINAIRE. YOUR
JUNIOR HIGH I DID DIAL. ONE
ZERO. GO AHEAD. OKAY GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT SHOULD CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ANTOINETTE
GORDINIER I'M AN ASSOCIATE
PROFESSOR AT SACRAMENTO STATE
AND I HAVE THE HONOR OF SERVING
AS A TRY CHAIR FOR THE CFA
WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND THAT'S YES
THEY CAPITOL CHAPTER VICE
PRESIDENT I'M SPEAKING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
FOUR. PROVIDING FOR ADEQUATE
PATRONS LEAVE WITH AB TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY FOUR WILL CREATE
GREATER EQUITY FOR FEMALE BODY
FACULTY. THIS IS A SOCIAL
JUSTICE ISSUE WHICH AFFECTS THE
NOBODY FACULTY AND PARTICULARLY
MEMBERS OF BLACK INDIGENOUS AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. IN MOST
CASES IT IS FEMALE BODY THEN
POINT TO TAKE PARENTAL LEAVE. AS
THE CURRENT POLICY DOESN'T COVER
A WHOLE SEMESTER FACULTY ARE
STUCK BETWEEN A ROCK AND A HARD
PLACE. IMAGE EITHER GET COVERAGE
FOR PORTION OF THEIR CLASSES
DURING YOUR LEAVE. WHICH COULD
DISRUPT THEIR CLASS AND
NEGATIVELY IMPACT THEIR COURSE
EVALUATIONS. OR THE ALTERNATIVES
TO TAKE OFF THE STATURE AND YOU
TO CRITICALLY AND LIKELY HAVE TO
GO WITHOUT PAYING FOR PART OF
THE SEMESTER. THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
UNNECESSARY. WHEN FACULTY RICH.
THERE COULD. GET COUNTED AS
DAVID. AND RAISES FINAL PAY
SCALE RETIREMENT. WHEN NOBODY
FACULTY USER FIFTY TO HELP. SOME
TRYING TO LEAVE. THEIR LEARNING
ABOUT HEY I THE TERM IF YOU. THE
SAN BASED DIFFERENT AT THIS.
WHEN I DECIDED TO HAVE BABY. I
HAVE BEEN STRUCK ABOUT IT I
THOUGHT OUT ABOUT TERRIBLE THE
WHOLE. I THINK THAT TRYING TO MY
TIME OFFICE BUT- I'D UNDERGONE I
. FERTILITY FOR HALF THE WHEN IT
THI. OF THE MIDDLE THIS. I
DIDN'T TAKE ANY TIME OFF
AFTERWARD AND AT THAT POINT MY
DOCTOR SUGGESTED I MIGHT NEED TO
TAKE MEDICAL LEAVE OR EVEN LOOK
FOR A NEW JOB IF I WANTED TO
HAVE A BABY. I CONTINUE THE
TREATMENT THAT FIVE MONTHS LATER
AFTER THE COPA DOCTOR WAS ABLE
TO SUSTAIN A PREGNANCY. I'M SURE
THIS IS PARTIALLY BECAUSE I
DIDN'T HAVE TO DEAL WITH A LONG
COMMUTE AND IT QUITE AS MUCH
BURKE STRESSED. I WAS REALLY
STRESSED OUT THOUGH BECAUSE
THERE'S NO WAY I COULD TAKE THE
SEMESTER OFF WITHOUT HAVING TO
GO WITHOUT PAY. THANKFULLY
ANDERSON. IN THE SUMMER TWENTY
TWENTY DIDN'T REQUIRE ANY
MEDICAL INTERVENTION.
UNFORTUNATELY THE TIMING OF THE
BIRTH WAS SUCH THAT I WASN'T
ABLE TO USE PAID SICK LEAVE TO
COVER THE REMAINDER SPRING
SEMESTER. THERE ARE ALSO MAJOR
CHALLENGES HER FAMILY WENT TO
AMBER SUPPORT. OR OCT UPTAKE AND
A LOT OF TROUBLE WATCHING DURING
BREAST FEEDING. AMBER STOPPED A
TON OF WEIGHT WHICH LEFT ME IN A
PANIC ABOUT THEIR WEIGHT
THEREAFTER. MY PARTNER HAD TO
RETURN TO WORK A WEEK AFTER I
GAVE BIRTH BECAUSE OTHERWISE YOU
WOULD BE ABLE TO AFFORD ME
TAKING OFFICE PART OF THE
SEMESTER. AND THAT LEFT ME ALONE
AT HOME AND STRUGGLING WITH
FEEDING OUR NEWBORN BECAUSE I
COULDN'T PRODUCE ENOUGH BREAST.
SO THAT. THE DOCTOR TOLD. ME
THAT IF I TO BRING MARC. I NEED
TO READ MY- GET MORE SLEEP AND
ALSO. TO POP AROUND THE- TO
TALK. A. FOR THREE MONTHS WERE
AFTER THE HER TIME OF MY ENTIRE
LIFE. I WAS DEPRESSED. ISOLATED
AND- EXTR ECONOMIC HARDSHIP I
WHICH PLAYED BY RACING THOUGHTS
ABOUT HOW WE CAN MAKE AND
SPEECH. I WAS NEVER ABLE TO
PRODUCE ENOUGH MILK BUT IF I'D
BEEN PROVIDED ADEQUATE PAID
LEAVE THIS MIGHT HAVE MADE IT
LESS STRESSFUL TIME FOR OUR
FAMILY. I DON'T WANT ANYONE ELSE
TO THE FIFTH YOU'D HAVE TO MAKE
THE CHOICES THAT I HAD TO MAKE.
I WHAT Q. AND I'M REALLY HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS THANK YOU
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE ROOM PLEASE COME UP TO
THE MIKE IF YOUR NAME. AND THE
GROUP YOU'RE WITH. YEAH I GUESS. WE WOULD HAVE. JUST YOUR NAME
IN THE YOU'RE WITH I AM- MILLER
AND I AM THE A PEOPLE OUT CFA
AND ONE OF THIS CHAIRS OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS I AM IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FOUR.
THANK YOU. I'M DOCTOR CHARLES
TUNES ON THE CFA PRESIDENT
PROFESSOR AT SAN DIEGO STATE AND
I AM IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FOUR. THANK
YOU. I'M CHRIS **** I TEACH AT
SAN JOSE STATE THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIOLOGY AN INTERDISCIPLINARY
SOCIAL SCIENCE. AND THE- ZIDAN
FOR PFA'S COUNCIL FOR RACIAL AND
SOCIAL JUSTICE NORTH AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MAGGIE THABIT FABULA
PROFESSOR AT SACRAMENTO STATE
I'M WITH THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION ASSOCIATE VICE
PRESIDENT. OF THE NORTHERN
CHAPTER PRESIDENT AND I AM
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FOUR
SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. KEVIN WHERE VICE
PRESIDENT OF CFA AND PROFESSOR
OF SOCIOLOGY ON THE SACRAMENTO
CAMPUS AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS A BANG BANG A LIBRARIAN
FROM FRESNO STATE AND CALIFORNIA
FACTLY AS STATIONS. TRONG THESE
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FOUR THANK
YOU THANK YOU. HI I'M DIANE
BLAIR AND I AM A PROFESSOR IN
THE DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNICATION
AT FRESNO STATE AND I AM ALSO
CFA SECRETARY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
FOUR. THANK DR SHERANI LEASE CSU
SAN MARCOS SOCIOLOGIST. A. V. P.
FOR RACIAL AND SOCIAL JUSTICE
SOUTH FOR CFA. IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL PLEASE PASS IT
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS DR GREGORY C. BROWN. HI
T. TO CAL STATE FULLERTON I'M
ASSOCIATE VICE PRESIDENT SOUTH
OF CFA AND I STRONGLY STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB. TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD OCT. CAN
REALLY AMERICA WITH SEIU CAL
STOCKS. THANK YOU. EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR IF YOU TO GO TO THE
PHONES IT AND SEE IF THERE ARE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES INSTEAD OF
AB THE FOUR SIXTY. THANK YOU
MISTER CARE TO TRY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WHEN THEY'RE ATTACHED FINANCING
FOR A P. TWENTY FOURS BEFORE.
WHITE ONE NINETY NINE YOU ARE
OPEN. THANK A TEACHER MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO EXPORT. AS
A REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TEST PLAN SUPPORT FOR A BI.
TWENTY FOUR SIXTY FOUR. MISTER
CHAIR NOBODY ELSE'S QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. IN THE HEARING ROOM
. C. NINE EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR
IF YOU WOULD GO TO THE PHONE
LINES IT DOESN'T IF THERE ARE
ANY WITH ALL THE BE. OF H. T. T.
OPERATOR GEN CHASE IN OPPOSITION
. ON ON THE PHONE LINE. HEY GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE MEDINA AND
MEMBERS. HI THIS IS DAN FACEBOOK
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITYTHE
CSU HAS ADOPTED IN OPPOSE
POSITION ON AB TWENTY FOUR SIXTY
FOUR A MEASURE THAT VIOLATES THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS
AND REMOVE THE FIDUCIARY
RESPONSIBILITIES TRUSTED WITH
THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES. IF YOU
PROVIDE. OF EIGHT WITHIN OUR
COLLECT BARGAINING AS WELL AS
FOR NON IN. EMPLOYED CAN ACCESS
MORE PAID LEAVE WITH THE SICKLY
EVEN RANKING WITH AT LEAST LIKE
I A MILLION ALL RIGHT WE A DATE
OF BIRTH OF THREE AND HAVE A OF
WAR WITH ME UNION TO AS ARE
REPRESENTED. WE NEED FOR
CHOIRBOY TO WORK FOR SUCH AMOUNT
OF TIME THAT THE BENEFITS IF YOU
TO GENEROUSLY ALLOWED SIMPLY
ACCESS PAID PARENTAL LEAVE
IMMEDIATELY UPON PLACEMENT.
UNFORTUNATELY AB. SIXTY OUT. OF
BEND PAID PARENTAL LEAVE SIX
FIFTY WEEKS FOR ALL IF YOU DON'T
GROUPS. EXCEPT PROFIT IN THE-
EMPLOYEE. A SIGNIFICANT EXPAND
OF ALL LEAD TIME AND I'M OF L.
G. EMPLOYEES IS NOT CAN A IN OF
SYSTEM. WHEN THE C. IF YOU AND
HEALTH TACKLE OFFICE GENERAL
BRADDOCK FIVE A NEW BARGAINING
AND- ON FEBRUARY THIRD TWO
TWENTY TWO. THE FINAL MEMORY OF
UNDERSTANDING TO FORM A PARENTAL
SUPPORT WORKGROUP TO REVIEW
PRACTICE SUPPORT THE FACULTY AND
PREPARE A REPORT ON THE
FINDINGS. THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING PROCESS ALLOWS THE
BILL AND I WERE. EMPLOYEES TO
CONSIDER FACTOR UNIQUE TO THAT.
I'M GREENE MET ON THE FACT.
UNTIL RESOURCES OF THIS YEAR.
CONSIDERING THE THAT MAY HAVE
WITH A SPOON GLORIA LEARNING
EXPERIENCE. IT IS THIS
PREFERENCE AT THE OKAY SHE COULD
PAID PARENTAL LEAVE THE COURT
BARGAINING BARGAINING PROCESS.
SO THAT CHANGES CAN BE WITHIN
THE OF AND TOOLS AVAILABLE TO
OUR IS THERE ANY TECHNICAL. I
THINK. IN. FOR THANK BUT-
PERFECT FOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. EIGHT T. OPERATOR IF THERE ARE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES.
THANK YOU RICHARD IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TRY AND I TO THE TWENTY
FOUR SIXTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE FILED BY
ZERO. YEAH NOBODY IS QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU. ANY
TRAINERS IN THE ROOM. EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR IF THERE ARE ANY
POINTERS ON THE LINE. ANY
TRAINERS PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. HI MISTER
CHAIR NOBODY'S GIVING UP ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU- TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
DR WEBER. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR-
PRESENTING THIS BILL I AM. VERY
DISAPPOINTED TO HEAR THAT THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS
THAT DID NOT WORK THAT YOU WERE
NOT. BEEN UNDERSTANDING CASSIDY
OF SOMETHING LIKE THIS BUT I DO
APPRECIATE THE EFFORT. YOU KNOW
IN MY OTHER ROLE AS AN OBGYN AND
THE ISSUE OF- PAID PARENTAL
LEAVE AND HOW MUCH TIME. WILL
GET A CHANCE TO OUR MOTHER EARTH
CHANCE TO BOND WITH THEIR CHILD
AFTER BIRTH A SOMETHING THAT I
WITH. AN M. AND ON A PERSONAL
SOMEONE WHO. WENT TO WORK WEEK.
AFTER BOTH OF MY SECTION FROM
MY- I. THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT A
SYSTEMIC THREAT OUR COUNTRY. AND
OTHER COUNTRIES DON'T DO THIS TO
THEIR TO THEIR NEWLY PARENTS SO
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FOR IT AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING. ANY
OTHER. QUESTIONS I ACTUALLY
HAVE- QUESTIONS- TO DR WEBER. I
ACTUALLY HAVE RIGHT NOW- THE
STAFF MEMBER WHOSE- EXPECTING
SOON AND- SHE SHE WAS ACTUALLY
WITH TO. BE CONSULTED WITH MY-
THE HR MANAGER ABOUT JUST THIS
QUESTION RIGHT AND SO AND I WAS
SPEAKING WITH MY WIFE YESTERDAY
ABOUT THE VERY. AND THE WIFE
TRIED. A POINTED OUT TO THAT IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT SEEMS
RIGHT THAT THERE ARE LOTS OF.
THERE THERE ARE DIFFERENT
POLICIES. RIGHT AT THE STATE
EMPLOYEES HAVE CERTAIN. A
PARENTAL LEAVE. AND THEN OUR OWN
EMPLOYEES- HAVE DIFFERENT RIGHT
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT AS SUCH
STATE EMPLOYEES THEY ARE
EMPLOYEES OF THE STATE ASSEMBLY
AND SO THEN AND I'M- PRETTY MUCH
WANTED TO MAKE THIS INTO A
QUESTION BECAUSE- MY TWO
CHILDREN WERE IN QUITE A WHILE
AGO. FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN YEARS
AGO AND I DO REMEMBER- IN- MY
WIFEHAVING TIME- SO IT IS
UNEVEN THEN IS I THINK THE POINT
THAT I'M MAKING RIGHT IT IS
UNEVEN IT IS NOT- IT'S NOT THE
SAME. UP FROM ONE. THE STATE TO
THE STATE ASSEMBLY IS DIFFERENT-
HOW WELL HOW WELL HOW WOULD YOU
ADDRESS THAT VERY SUBJECT WHY
WHY DO WE HAVE SO MANY DIFFERENT
OF POLICIES IT THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WAY WHY
DON'T WE HAVE SOMETHING MORE
EVEN. I THINK WE DON'T VALUE.
PERRANCE ATHLETICALLY OFTENTIMES
THAT FEMALE PARENTS SINCE THE
BURDEN HAS BEEN PUT ON THEM BUT
THIS IS REALLY NOW IT'S MOVED
INTO TWENTY TWENTY ABOUT BOTH OF
OUR PAST. IMPORTANCE OF BOTH
PARENTS HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BOND WITH MY CHILDREN I'M
SURE THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO ADDRESS COLLECTIVELY
FOR THE WHOLE AND HAVE MADE SOME
STRIDES OVER THE YEARS THAT WE
HAVE BEEN HERE BUT NOT ENOUGH-
WE HAVE A NEW BILL. THAT IS
BEING WORKED ON UP THERE AS WELL
TO CONTINUE TO MAKE BUT I THINK
IT'S FINING. RESPECT TO HONOR
THESE PARENTS THE WAY THAT AND-
A WE WERE JUST TALKING THE SAME
OFFICE. I'VE OF. A STAFF RACK A
CHILD AT LEAST EVERY YEAR THAT
I'VE BEEN HERE FOR TEN YEAR AND-
THIS PANDEMIC WITH EXCELLENT- IN
TEAM VERY. AND BUT YOU KNOW WITH
WITH THE TIME HERE- HOW MUCH
THEY VALUE THAT TIME THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO HOME AND FOR
THEM IT'S DIFFERENT LEVELS AND I
HAVE SUBMIT ENOUGH- THEY CAN
TELEPORT TO PAY TAKE THAT
ADDITIONAL ON PAID LEAVE THAT
THEY- WANTED TAKEN THEY'RE
HAVING TO MAKE CHOICES TO COME
BACK PROBABLY SOONER THAN THEIR
BABY OR THEIR BODIES WALK. OUT
THERE AND THAT'S STRUGGLE HOW DO
WE ACCOMMODATE AND SO- I THINK
WE MOVE IN INCREMENTS THAT TIME
TO ALWAYS TO KEEP- OF THE BIGGER
PICTURE WE HAVE THAT WORK ALSO
HAPPENING AND SO THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE INCREMENTS FOR A GROUP. OF
PROFESSIONALS ARE WELL WE'RE
ALSO DOING THAT ADDITIONAL WORK. TO THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS. I
WANTED TO RESPOND GO AHEAD YES-
MISSED. MAN ARE IT'S REALLY TO
BE HERE PERSON- SOCCER. LAW NOT
ONLY DISK. AGAINST WOMEN IT
TAKES IT DISCRIMINATES AGAINST
PARENTS AS THEY HAVE TO THIS
PLETE ALL THEIR SICK LEAVE JUST
TO BEAR CHILDREN AND GIVES BIRTH
AND- I. TAKE THE TIME THAT THEY
NEED TO BOND AND WHAT NOT AND
THERE IS THIS. STIGMA THAT
TEACHERS AND PROFESSORS- ONLY
WHAT NINE MONTHS OUT OF THE YEAR
. YOU KNOW IF AND I HAVE THREE
YOUNG KIDS AND WE HAVE TO
SCHEDULE OUR PREGNANCIES AS AS
AS HE IS THAT HE'S A PROFESSOR
SO WHAT ENDS UP HAPPENING IS
WE'RE GIVING BIRTH DURING THE
MONTH OF JUNE. AS NUMBER. SO
WE'RE SPENDING OUR TIME DURING
HER BREAK EITHER PLANNING OR
ATTENDING BIRTHDAY PARTIES LOTS
OF. IT IS REALLY UNFAIR THIS IS
A- THIS IS ABOUT DOING THE RIGHT
THING. HOW IT DID THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT HOME. HARJIT THAT IS
. THAT IS AFFECTING NOT JUST OUR
PROFESSION BUT THROUGHOUT THE K.
TWELVE. THE ENTIRE SCHOOL SYSTEM
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES- IT'S ABOUT
DOING THE RIGHT THING- AND THAT
IS ALL. THANK YOU. I'D LIKE TO
GO NEXT TO THE ISSUE THAT CSU
RIGHT OUT OF THE FACT THAT THIS
WAS A BARGAINING. ISSUE- AND
THAT THE BILL AND THEN-
CIRCUMVENTS THE BARGAINING-
PROCESS. THE CONDUCTOR AND I. N.
AND I MAY GO TO CSU WHICH ALSO.
I THINK AS WE HEARD A PERFECT.
BUT WE'LL START HERE THEN I'LL
GO TO SEE A SHIFTING AS WE HEARD
FROM OUR WITNESS. THE ATTITUDE
DURING THE BARGAINING PROCESS
THAT NOT- GATHER GARNER SIX F.
INSPECTOR THEY CAME IN WITH AN
OPEN MIND AND IT'S MY OPINION
THAT WHILE WE RESPECT THAT IN
THERE WITH A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING. I HAS. NUMBER ON
THIS ISSUE THAT WE AS A
LEGISLATURE HAVE A DUTY TO
INTERVENE TO CORRECT INJUSTICES
ON THE PROCESS HAS FAILED THEM
ON AND SAID TO ME CLEARLY THIS
PROCESS S FAILING. GLACIER S.
U. V. LIKE TO RESPOND PLEASE DO
. GEN HI HELLO I CHAIR MEDINA
YES ON THIS IS JOHN CASE I'M
GONNA HAVE MY- TECHNICAL
SUPPORT- JOSEPH GILLAN SIX WHO'S
THE ASSISTANT CHANCELLOR OF THE
BARGAIN BONTA. YEAH AFTERNOON
SIR WELCOME WILLS FROM- ARE VERY
FROM THE COULD WITH THAT WHAT
THE BILL COME- EXPAND LEAVE TO
ONE CA AFTER. YOU HAVE PAID
RAPPORT TO ADDED GAMPEL REQUIRE
. EMPLOYER HAVE DIFFERENT WELL
OF BENEFITS BUT WE THAT AFTER OF
BETTER- WE'RE NOT GOING ADDS
GENEROUS. SAMPLE ONE HIRING HIM
- PROVIDE EACH WEEK APRENDE
LEAVE BUT AT SEVENTY PER. HEY
YOU WILL IS A LOT BETTER-
OVERALL BY. BEEN WHAT THE FEAR
PROVIDE- I HIGHER YOU EMPLOYER.
HAD A WAITING OF YEAR EMPLOYEES
USE THE BENEFIT. AND ON TOP OF
THAT THE EMPLOYEE- AT THAT
INSTITUTE HAD THE AND THEN
NUMBER OF OUR- WHICH PART.
EMPLOYEES THE WORK ARE GET THEIR
MADE WOULD EXCLUDE ALL THE ALL
FACULTY WHO ARE NOT PART TIME
AND AGAIN TO SEE IF YOU- IN
THEIR EXISTING- POLICY THAT
WOULD HAVE THE KIND THE
REQUIREMENTS. AND EVEN A THIRD
EMPLOYER THAT WE HAD LOOKED AT-
BUT IF THEY HAD BROUGHT FORWARD-
NOT REQUIRED FACULTY COULD STILL
PERFORM REDUCE DEFECTIVE-
STUDENT ADVISER GRADING. WHY
THEY WERE ON THE PARENTAL LEAVE
AND SO THE PARTIES REACHED A
COMPREHENSIVE I TEN IMMIGRANT
MENTIONED NUMBER- THAT WAS
RATIFIED IN FEBRUARY AND IN THE
END THE UNIVERSITY. AND IF YOU
IF YOU AGREE TO MAINTAIN STATUS
QUO IN THE PARENTAL LEAVE. WITH
AT PAID THIRTY WORKING DAYS I
BELIEVE HOWEVER WE DID AGREE TO
A WORKING GROUP OF EXPERTS TO
LOOK AT THE ISSUE MORE CLOSELY.
AND TO LOOK WHAT FOR SOME MORE
PLAYERS WERE DOING IN THE AREA
ALONG WITH LOOKING AT
UTILIZATION AND TRENDS WITHIN
THE KEY ISSUE. I'M NOT RECALL AS
REQUIRED. AND SIX MONTHS THE
PERSON NEEDING AND THAT REPORT
WILL GO TO THE CSU ACADEMIC
SENATE. BOARD OF TRUSTEES AND
THE. CHANCELLOR.
OUR UNDERSTANDING WHO COULD. I
THINK WHAT I WOULD JESTEM
EMPHASIZE WHAT I SAID BEFORE
THIS IS AN ISSUE A SYSTEMIC
ISSUE THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY I
AM WHEN YOU LOOK AT OTHER
COUNTRIES- THANK GIVE THEIR
MOTHER SIX MONTHS ONE YEAR ON
OFFENSE YOU KNOW WHEN THEY HAVE
HAD A BABY- WE ARE. VERY IN
THIS. AND I THINK THIS BILL IS
ONE STEP IN TERMS OF TRYING TO
FIX SOMETHING THAT. WE REALLY
NEED TO DEAL WITH ON A- SYSTEMIC
ISSUE NOW. YOU KNOW YOUR
PREVIOUS QUESTION ABOUT THE
INEQUITIES I THINK THAT HAS A
LOT TO DO WITH- DIFFERENT.
GROUPS AND THEIR OWN. BARGAINING
ABILITIES AND SO- FACULTY MAYBE
AT ONE LEVEL AND HAVE ONE TYPE
OF INSURANCE STAFF HAS ANOTHER-
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT. I SIDE
UT SOUTHWESTERN UCSD IN TERMS OF
WHAT PASSED BACK WHAT HE HAD.
THE FEDS IN TIME OFF VERSUS WHAT
THE STAFF PAD- AND VERSUS WHAT
SOME OF THE OTHER EMPLOYEES HAD
AND SO I WAS CONSTANTLY TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHERE YOU WERE
WHEN I WAS COUNSELING PATIENTS
ON WHAT KIND OF- MATERNITY LEAVE
OR HOW MUCH TIME THEY WOULD HAVE
OFF. THANK YOU. AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CO IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE. I WHAT WHAT I THINK MISS WEBER
FOR HER. AND ON THIS ISSUE- AND
THE WITNESSES FOR SHARING THEIR
STORIES THE MOMMY TAX ISRAEL.
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT AFFECTS
US UP FRONT WHEN WE'RE MAKING
CHOICES ABOUT. PAY CUTS AND
MISSING OUT ON ON INCOME BUT
IT'S ALSO SOMETHING AFFECTS US
ON THE BACK AND WHEN IT'S TIME
FOR RETIREMENT AS WELL AND SO IT
ADDS UP IN AND OUT SO QUICKLY IN
A HAS LONG TERM CONSEQUENCES.
WITH IT SO I. THOUGHT I
RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR AYE WILL
AND STEP OUT TO CORRECT SOME OF
THAT MOMMY TEXAS WON'T FIX OUR
PROBLEMS BUT A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. BUT THANK YOU MISTER.
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD. I
GAVE NO RECOMMENDATION ON THIS
BILL. AND I SAID THAT I WOULD
LISTEN TO THE DISCUSSION. AND
THERE IS NO RECOMMENDATION. BUT-
WE SHARED ALL THE DISCUSSION AND
EVERYTHING THE DOCTOR WEBER HAD
TO ADD- IT IS NOT VERY OFTEN
THAT I WANT TO INTERJECT. MYSELF
FOR THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
BARGAINING PROCESS WE DID ONE
BEFORE- OF THE ETHNIC STUDIES AT
CSU. SO EVEN I DON'T RECOMMEND
IN ON THIS BILL. I WILL VOTE FOR
IT- THIS AFTERNOON THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. SO NOW WE ARE ON ITEM TEN A.
B. TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
MISTER JONES SAWYER WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY YES. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR IN MEMBERS I PRESENT TO
YOU AB TWENTY FORTY FIVE THAT
CLASSIFIED POSITIONS HIRING
FLEXIBILITY ACT SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE CALIFORNIA LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES ELEAZAR HAVE
USED TO RULE OUT THREE RANKS TO
HIRE CANDIDATES BASED ON THE
PLAN. EXAM CORE FOR THOSE THAT
DO NOT REQUIRE A FAKE QUIT A
CREDENTIAL SUCH AS MAINTENANCE
AND CUSTODIAL STAFF BUS DRIVERS
AND CAFETERIA STAFF TO RULE
THREE RANKS ROUNDS EACH
CANDIDATE SCORE FROM THE
EXAMINATION PROCESS TO THE
NEAREST PERCENTAGE POINT. AND
THEN RANKS THOSE SCORES BY ONE
PERCENTAGE THIS MEANS ONLY THE
TOP THREE SCORES ELIGIBLE FOR
POTENTIAL EMPLOYMENT LIMITING
THE POOL OF APPLICANTS THAT CAN
BE CONSIDERED. THE CURRENT
SYSTEM FAILS TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
AND BEGIN WHO MAY BE BETTER
SUITED OVERALL FOR PARTICULAR
JOB BECOME FROM A SOCIO ECONOMIC
BACKGROUND THAT HAS LED THEM TO
LESS. ADEPT AT STANDARDIZED
TESTS AS A RESULT. LOCKED THEM
OUT OF FROM A DESERVED JOB
OPPORTUNITY WHILE INTENDED TO
PREVENT NEPOTISM OR BIAS IN
HIRING WILL RULE OF THE RANKS
HAD ITS OWN SET OF CHALLENGES.
THE 1% DISTINCTION BETWEEN
BRANCHES SO NOW THAT IT LIMITS
THE ABILITY FOR HIRING KICK
COMMITTEES HIRING OUT TO
CONSIDER WELL QUALIFIED AND
IT'S- WHO MAY EXCEL IN OTHER JOB
RELATED. SINCE. SURE BUT DO PLAN
WITHIN THE THREE RANKS AS SUCH
AB TWO FORTY WILL DELEGATES TO
OPT INTO A BANDING SYSTEM. THAT
WOULD INSTEAD GROUP CANADA'S BY
6% INTERVALS AND INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT CAN BE
CONSIDERED FOR HIRING TO FIVE
CANDIDATES. WHEN TRANSITIONING
FROM THE RULE OF THREE TWO
BANDING A PERSONNEL COMMISSION
WILL DETERMINE WHETHER TO CHANGE
TO BANDING SYSTEM IS SUITABLE
FOR THEIR LEN. UPON
DETERMINATION BY THE COMMISSION
THE PROPOSED CHANGES WILL BE
BROUGHT UP FOR NEARLY A EMPLOYEE
MAJORITY VOTE. IF ENACTED THIS
BILL WILL HELP COMBAT THE LACK
OF ADEQUATE REPRESENTATION HELP
ALLEVIATE STAFF SHORTAGES BETTER
IMPACTING OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM
THIS BILL ILL HELP CALIFORNIA
TAKE ANOTHER STEP TOWARD TRUE
EDUCATION. EQUITY JOINING ME
TODAY AND SUPPORT BE A PHONE IT
TOO IS ERICK ROWAN ROWAN WITH
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION PERSONNEL COMMISSION.
LA CO L. A. C. O. B. AS WELL AS
RON. DELAHUNT WHO SAY WITH THE
LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. THANK YOU IN RESPECT
TO ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU AN
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR IF WE COULD%
GO TO THE PHONE LINES FOR THOSE
TWO WITNESSES PLEASE. FOR SB
TWENTY FORTY FIVE. OKAY. THE
FIRST ONE SHOULD BE AEROGROW.
THE LINER IS ALL BUT. IT. ONLY
TO DO WE HAVE THE WITNESSES
THERE. YES. YES WE CAN HEAR YOU
NOW. HE'S GO AHEAD OKAY. OKAY
THANKS FOR THAT THE GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBER MY NAME
IS ERICA WANTED NINETY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR CLASS BY HUMAN
RESOURCES AT THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
CALLING TO REPRESENT IT PERSONAL
COMMISSION. OUR ORGANIZATION IS
IN FULL SUPPORT OF IT THE BILL
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WHICH WILL
PROVIDE HE CAME TO TWELVE AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS WITH
AN OPTION TO MAKE. FUNDING
DECISIONS FROM A GROUP OF RANK
GROUPS OF HIGHLY QUALIFIED
APPLICANTS RATHER. ONLY THE TOP
THREE. ANALOGY FOR THE LAST
ENTERTAINMENT IN A- ONE
PRESENTATION IN SCHOOL. WHEN I
PERSONAL COMMISSION WOULD PROMPT
BY THE COUNTY TO PRINT SCHOOL TO
EXAMINE ANY LAWS IN FISCAL THAT
MAY CONTRIBUTE TO ADVERSE IMPACT
IN OUR HIRING. DANNY COOPER WITH
THE CLEAR MANAGED. EQUITY YOUR
SYSTEM HIGHER. I THINK. WITH THE
DECADE OF HUMAN RESOURCE LEADERS
BETWEEN THE COUNTY AND PLANES L.
A. U. S. T. AND LIKE. ALL AGREED
THAT THE RESULTED BILL THE
CLEARED UP TO CREATE A STANDING
IN THE STONE AT THE MOMENT STAY
CRACK IN CITY COUNTY STATE AND-
PUBLIC SHOULD CONSIDER IT. WITH
THE SYSTEM IN. EIGHT TWENTY
FIVE. MILLION PLEASE THAT THE
COUNTY OF WHAT THEY- EARLY.
EIGHTY IT'S PAST THIS BILL WILL
ALLOW THIS YEAR TO HIM A WELL
ESTABLISH PRACTICE THAT WILL
PROVIDE MORE AFFECTED FOR
EQUITABLE HIRING. IT'S QUITE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR JOB AT IT. IN
THE HIRING PROCESS MORE
EFFICIENT TO FILL THE FRENCH
PARK JOB BUT CHILD AND ADULT
EDUCATION CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME TODAY INSPECT THE
I THOUGHT IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY
TWENTY FORTY CUT. THANK YOU NEXT
WITH WITNESS. CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES CANARY HELLO YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU HI GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'M HONORED TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS YOU
TODAY IN TOTAL SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FORTY FIVE MY NAME IS RON
BELL EACH DAY I'M THE DIRECTOR
OF THE LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT PERSONNEL
COMMISSION- I HAVE THIRTY YEARS
OF HUMAN RESOURCES PROFESSIONAL
EXPERIENCE IN EIGHTEEN YEARS. A
TRAIN EDUCATE THE QUICKEST
THIRTY CAN THINK. ONE OF THE
AREAS OF STAFFING FRUSTRATION
HAS BEEN THE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENT THAT OULD LIMIT
EMPLOYMENT OUTLOOK ELIGIBILITY.
LISTS TO THE RANK OF THREE WILL.
HIGHLY RESPECTED VERY LIMITING
MODEL- OUR NINE COLLEGES AND
FRONT OFFICE SPREAD THROUGHOUT
THE LOS ANGELES REGION ARE
ACTIVELY PURSUING EVER MORE
DIVERSE AND HIGHLY QUALIFIED
STAFF. THE BANDING METHOD THAT
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY- THAT LOS
ANGELES COUNTY HAS THRIVED UNDER
FOR DECADES MADE AVAILABLE UNDER
AB TWENTY FORTY WILL GREATLY
ENHANCE OUR ABILITY. TO PROVIDE
EXPANDED OPPORTUNITIES UP TO
EVERY GROUP OF PEOPLE WHETHER
BASED ON GENDER GENDER IDENTITY.
NARAL DIVERSITY OR ETHNIC
DIVERSITY. NOTE THAT WHEN I SAY
DIVERSITY ON CAMPUS I THINK THAT
DIVERSITY AT SCHOOL NO ONE. ELSE
AND THEN WILL GO A LONG WAY.
TOWARD HELPING A THE GOAL ARE
HIRING THE- WILL BENEFIT FROM
THE TO GREATER. OUR APP WILL
BENEFIT HAVING A GREATER
OPPORTUNITY TO BE PLACED ON AN
ELIGIBILITY LIST. AND OUR
COMMUNITIES WILL BENEFIT FROM
HAVING THE BEST TALENTS SERVING
. I'M QUOTING BY POINTING OUT
THAT THE LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT THE LARGEST
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
THE NATION. AND WE ARE IN TOTAL
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
I WANT TO THANK- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD. AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
ALL AGAIN FOR THE HONOR OF
ATTRACTING YOU AND I ASK FOR
YOUR- THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
HEARING ROOM. C. NINE EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR IF YOU COULD GO TO
THE PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
FORTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO FOR AB TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
MISTER CARROLL BEGAN TO FIND. GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RANDY PEREZ
AND I AM BUT THE SAN MATTEO
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU. BY TWO
FORTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
PAMELA GENSCRIPT IN THE LAST.
OKAY RECENTLY AT SPONSOR OF THE
BILL WE WANT TO THANK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR OFFERING
THAT BILL AND FOR CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH US AND OTHER
INTERESTED PARTIES. THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD WE URGE YOUR I
THOUGHT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES A
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED MEMBERS
MY NAME IS KENNETH CARTER ON THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF THE
PERSONNEL COMMISSION- CALLING ON
BEHALF THE LONG BEACH UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT PERSONNEL
COMMISSION AND WE'RE- FIVE AB
TWENTY FORTY FIVE. WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS UPDATE TURNOUT THIS
INTO GROUPS CAN BE A GREAT
BENEFIT THANK YOU OUT FOR NOT
USING HIS OWN EVEN INTO YOUR
WHERE YOU FROM THANK YOU. A. T.
AND T. OPERATOR NEXT. OVERLYING
TO SIXTY ONE YOU ARE OPEN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ANDREA
BALL ON THE HALF OF THE LONG
BEACH UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
URGED THE BILL TO MOVE FORWARD
THANK THE AUTHOR AND EVERYONE
FOR ALL THE WORK ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. ONE ONE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SEVEN ARCA FROM
DOWNEY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT-
I'M THE DIRECTOR ON AND I AM
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
FORTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF DAN
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. THANK
YOU. THE FINAL REMINDER TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
FORTY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
ONE TO THIRTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GERALD IN OUR
MAIL AND THE CLASSIFIED DIRECTOR
FOR YOU WOULD UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND ON BEHALF OF THE
MISSION WE'RE- AB FORTY FIVE
WHICH WE ARE IN FULL WHAT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR
THERE KNOW WHAT THE PARTICIPANT
QUEUED UP AT THIS TIME. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SB
TWENTY FORTY FIVE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. C. NINE EIGHTEEN P.
MODERATOR IF THERE ARE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES. TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION FOR AB TWENTY FORTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO ONE FILED BY ZERO.
NOBODY IS GIVING UP MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU ANY TWEETERS IN THE
HEARING ROOM. WE DO KIND OF
TWEENER CLEANER A BEATING IN
MISTER CHAIRMAN VISIT THE
COMMITTEE NAVNEET PER YEAR ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
MPLOYEES ASSOCIATION WE ARE A
TWEENER BUT WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ON FURTHER AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR IF THERE ARE ANY
TWEETERS ON. LINE IF THERE ARE
ANY CLEANERS AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. BUT
NOBODY TO GIVING UP THE
STRUCTURE THANK YOU- TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SEEING NONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON IT THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FOR. AND I
BELIEVE THAT- THE OPTION OF A
BANDED SYSTEM MAY PROVIDE HIRING
MANAGERS WITH OPPORTUNITIES TO
SELECT FROM A DIVERSE POOL OF
QUALIFIED CANDIDATES AND I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY. WE WILL VOTE WHEN WE HAVE
A CORE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. A MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ELEVEN NOT SURE THAT I
SEE THE AUTHOR HERE. SHOULD BE.
ON HIS WAY- RIGHT- NOT SEEN ANY
OTHER AUTHORS HERE. DO WE HAVE
ANY AUTHORS FROM THE COMMITTEE I
HAVE A BILL. WHICH OKAY OKAY YEP. HELLO OKAY. MY GOOD. AMONG
OKAY WE'RE ON FILE ITEM ELEVEN
A. B. TWENTY SIXTY NINE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
WELCOME ORIA GOOD. THE FILE ITEM
ELEVEN AB. TWENTY SIXTY NINE.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERSHIP FIRST
I WANT TO START BY THANKING YOUR
STAFF YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING OUT WITH MY OFFICE
SINCLAIR FIND THE LANGUAGE AND
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDATION AND MEASUREMENTS
AB TWENTY SIXTY NINE. SIR YES AB
TWENTY SIX AND I WILL ACT THE
CALIFORNIA HOME HEALTH AIDE
TRAINING SCHOLARSHIP ACT WHICH
WILL AWARD SCHOLARSHIP
RECIPIENTS. ONE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED EACH TO BE USED FOR HOME
HEALTH AIDE TRAINING PROGRAMS
AT- TO WORKING IN THIS FIELD FOR
THE FOR AT LEAST THREE YEARS.
ACCORDING TO THE MASTER PLAN FOR
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA WILL FACE A
LABOR SHORTAGE UP TO THREE THREE
THREE POINT TWO MILLION K.
DIRECT CARE WORKERS WHICH
INCLUDES HOME HEALTH AIDES. AS
GREATER NUMBERS OF OLDER ADULTS.
CHOOSE TO AGE AND THEN CHOOSE TO
AGE IN PLACE THE CHARGE THE
SHORTAGE OF THESE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS TO REALLY TO REALLY
IMPACT THE WELL BEING OF OUR
OLDER ADULTS AND INDIVIDUALS
WITH DISABILITIES. RESIDING AT
HOME BY INCENTIVIZING AROMA IN
THIS FIELD IT WILL HELP ADDRESS
THE DIRECT CARE FOR WORKERS
SHORTAGE AND WILL PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE RELIEF FOR FAMILIES
WHO DESPERATELY NEED HELP CARING
FOR LOVED ONES AT AT THEIR HOME.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIXTY NINE
IS KAREN CORR BACK AND JOANNE.
YUP A CONE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SENIORS LEGISLATURES. EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR THE THEY ARE BOTH ON
THE PHONE LINES IF- REACH OUT TO
THEM PLEASE. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS KAREN CORR BAT AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY ASSEMBLY MEMBER THEY
HAVE TO DO A- PERSIMMON DANA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. I AM A
SENIOR SENATOR AND THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE
AND RETIRED COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DEAN AND I'M ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIXTY NINE.
AT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID THIS
BILL SPEAKS DIRECTLY TO GULF WAR
IN CALIFORNIA'S MASTER PLAN FOR
AGING NOTING THAT IN COMING
YEARS THE STATE. BUT IT'S ABOUT
. YOUR WORKERS THAT INCLUDES
HOME HEALTH AIDES THIS IS
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE INCREASING
NUMBERS OF OLDER ADULTS ARE
CHOOSING TO AGE AT HOME A SOCIAL
CONSTRUCT SUPPORTED BY A TWENTY
EIGHTEEN A. A. R. P. SURVEY
NOTING THAT NEARLY 75% OF THOSE
POLLED INDICATED THAT THEY
PREFERRED TO AGE IN OUR OWN
HOMES AND COMMUNITIES. IF YOU'VE
EVER ATTEMPTED TO HAVE THE TALK
WITH THEM AND TO OUR NEIGHBOR
WHO RESIST LEAVING HOME TO
RELOCATE IN AN ASSISTED LIVING
COMMUNITY. YOU'VE SEEN THE PAIN
IN THEIR EYES AND YOU PER THE
FEAR IN THEIR VOICES AND YOU
KNOW THAT THE AARP DATA FAR
CORRECT. FAMILY AND FOR MAY HELP
PROVIDE HOME CARE FOR LOVED ONES
AS UNPAID CARE GIVERS ARE
COMPENSATED TO IN HOME SUPPORT
SERVICES THEY MAY NOT HAVE THE
EXPERTISE CONFIDENCE OUR TIME TO
FOLLOW THE ORDERS OF A
CLINICIAN. FINALLY WE ALL KNOW
THERE ARE NO EASY ANSWERS TO
COMPLEX PROBLEMS AND THE ISSUES
PLAGUING THIS WORKFORCE ARE
EXTRAORDINARILY COMPLEX. THEY
INCLUDE LOW WAGES AND
UNDERGROUND LABOR MARKET AN
INHERENT INSTITUTIONAL
INEQUITIES IN WHICH WOMEN OF
COLOR SHOULDER THE LARGEST
PROPORTION OF JOBS IN A
PROFESSION THAT HAS BEEN
AGENCIES GENERALIZED. AB TWENTY
FIFTY NINE PROVIDES WITH SMALL
REMEDY APPLY AND JOIN.
INDIVIDUAL TO COME OUT FROM
UNDERGROUND AND OBTAIN TRAINING
AS REQUIRED BY CALIFORNIA LAW.
COME PROFESSIONAL HOME HEALTH
AIDES WHAT OTHER FORMS OF
FINANCIAL AID ARE CERTAINLY
AVAILABLE THIS SCHOLARSHIP COME
BOTTLE. PATIENT.
PROFESSION WILL HELP AFFORDED
THE RESPECT IT DESERVES AND THE
DIRECT CARE WORKFORCE I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER BE A
PRODUCER FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THAT. THANK YOU A. T. T.
OPERATOR WE GO THE SECOND
WITNESS. HI MY NAME CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY NAME IS
MY NAME IS JOAN JAKOBAN AND I'M
VERY BORED OF AB TWENTY SIXTY
NINE. OF THE REGISTERED NURSE
THAT WORKED IN A HOSPITAL
SETTING FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS
AND HAVING BEEN A CAREGIVER FOR
MY MOTHER WHO LIVES TO BE A
HUNDRED AND TO. HER HUSBAND HAD
SERIOUS ISSUES FOR OVER FIVE. I
WE KNOW NEED AND THE DIFFICULT
FOR PATIENTS AND- THE- WHEN
PRINCIPLE OF ASSISTANCE.
SPEAKING PROFESSIONALLY MORE AND
MORE PROCEDURES ARE PERFORMED
WITHOUT PATIENCE THE DAILY WHEN
PATIENTS HAD TIME TO RECUPERATE
AND PROCEDURES IN A HOSPITAL
SETTING AND NURSES HAD TIME TO
FOR SUPERVISION AND EDUCATION AS
A FOLLOW UP TO PROVE YOU'RE NOT
. READY GONE. TRAIN HOME HEALTH
AIDES ARE DESPERATELY NEEDED TO
FILL THIS GAP. SPEAKING AS A
WIFE AND A DAUGHTER EVEN THE
MOST DEDICATED FAMILY MEMBER
PROVIDE HEALTH CARE FOR LOVED
ONES. CASE NO RELIEF THAT THE
ACT THAT THEY DIDN'T CAN DEPEND
ON. AND TO AN ALL TOO FREQUENTLY
THAT. THAT HELP IS SIMPLY NOT
AVAILABLE THE HOME HEALTH
PROFESSION NEED TO THE EDUCATION
THE RESPECT AND THE
ENCOURAGEMENT THAT IT SO RICHLY
DESERVES THIS MEASURE IN THIS
BILL THE MEASURES IN THIS BILL
ARE A SMALL STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION IT PROVIDES A MEANS
AND AN INCENTIVE TO PROPERLY
TRAIN. TRAIN OUR PEOPLE PER
CAREER IN A MUCH NEEDED
PROFESSION THANK YOU THANK YOU
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE HEARING ROOM. SEEING NONE
- EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR IF WE GO
TO THE PHONE LINES WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AB TWENTY SIXTY NINE. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY SIXTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS THE ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME- BY GENERAL.
AGAIN FIRST SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY SIXTY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. I ONE MOMENT THE
STRUCTURE. THANK. YEAH WE DO
HAVE A COUPLE OF ACUTE UP WITH
AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
THANK YOU. WE CAN GO AHEAD AND
NAME AN ORGANIZATION YOU'RE WITH. SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY SIXTY
NINE. ALL RIGHT OUR FIRST ONE
WILL BE LYING ABOUT TWO SIXTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD TO SIXTY TWO. YOU ARE OPEN TO SIXTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M ONE SIXTY
TWO IS THAT THE SAME NUMBER.
RIGHT THEY MIGHT A GIVEN YOU THE
WRONG LINE NUMBER BUT YOU ARE
GOING TO SIXTY TWO PLEASE CALL
YOUR GO AHEAD WE HEAR YOU. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS TONY AGAIN I'M A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA SENIOR
LEGISLATURE AS A SENIOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
VENTURA COUNTY AREA AGENCY ON
AGING. AND I LIVE IN WESTLAKE
VILLAGE IN VENTURA COUNTY. MY
VOICE SUPPORT. AB WO STILL- SIX
NINE AND HOPE THAT YOU WILL
SUPPORT IT ALSO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. FIVE ONE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD FOR ANYBODY ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO COME BY FOR AB TWENTY
SIXTY NINE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE EIGHTY FIVE
YOU ARE OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
JANICE BAILEY THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE. AS A SPONSOR
OF THE BILL WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. OF AB TWO ONE A. SIXTY
NINE AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED UP
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IN THE
HEARING ROOM. C. NINE EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR OF THEIR ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINE. PRESS OPPOSITION FOR
A. B. R. TWENTY SIXTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. FOLLOWED
BY ZERO IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO AB TWENTY SIXTY NINE. SURE
NOBODY'S GOING OUT ANY TWEETERS
IN THE HEARING ROOM. C. NINE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR ANY
CLEANERS. TWITTER IS ONE FILED
BY ZERO PLEASE. NO ONE IS
QUEUING UP THE STRUCTURE IN Q.
GO TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. DR CHOI.
THANK YOU FOR THE IT
PRESENTATION DISHES SO I THINK A
CRUCIAL AREA THAT THAT WE NEED
TO ADDRESS- TO RICK. THE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS YES- HOME
MADE UP I WONDER IF- THIS
INCLUDES SAW OR SO. OF KALLONI
SET IN HOME SERVICES SERVICE
PROVIDERS. THE THIS IS ONLY
TRYING TO GO AFTER. I MEAN SO IN
HOME SUPPORT SERVICES RT OF
QUALIFIED THEY'RE THEY'RE MET
THERE ALREADY MEMBERS WERE
TRYING TO RECRUIT NEW MEMBERS AT
. ARE YOU SAYING THAT THE
THERE'S A SCHOLARSHIP OF FOR
THOSE SO WHO ARE RECRUITED A FOR
IN HOME SERVICES. KNOW WHAT I'M
SAYING IS THAT RIGHT NOW WE ARE
HAVING A- ALMOST A TSUNAMI OF
FOLKS THAT ARE NOT TAKEN CARE
ARE ELDERLY FOLKS RIGHT NOW. SO
WE'RE I'M TRYING WE'RE TRYING TO
DO IS PLAN AHEAD. MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE NOW TRYING TO INCENTIVIZE
TO GET TIPS THAT FOLKS CAN GO
INTO THIS BILL AND B. A. B- BOB.
ELDERLY HOME CARE SERVICE FOLKS
. CHAU THIS OUR ELDERLY HOME
CARE OF PROVIDERS SO OTHER THAN
IN HOME SERVICE PROVIDERS I SAYS
SUCH AS SO I SHE'S BEEN ANALYSIS
US- CHILD CARE TRANSPORTATION C.
P. R. CARDIO PULMONARY. SOME
UNIFORMS AND SUPPLIES BOOKS
THREE SHOWN FOR TRAINING I TALK
ABOUT THAT THIS- TRAINING HAS-
TUITION AND BOOKS IS THE PRICE.
RIGHT SO IF THEY'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE TRAINING IT'S IT
DIDN'T MAX IS GOING TO BE
FIFTEEN HUNDRED BUCKS OUT
WHATEVER THEY CAN USE THAT FOR
SO THAT THEY CAN THEY COULD BE.
PROVIDER. A DIFFERENT JOB
CATEGORIES I'M SURE DIFFERENT
KINDS OF- TRAINING WILL BE
NECESSARY- DO YOU HAVE ANY
DURATION OR IS IT THE ORDERLY
UNIFORM OSCAR ON THE SHIP.
CAVING FOR THE- TRAINING PERIOD
THE MAY BE DIFFERENT. AS A
MEMBER CAN YOU CAN REPEAT THE
QUESTIONING OF. OUR DIFFERENT
KINDS UP ALL HOME- CARE A- WILL
REQUIRE A DIFFERENT KIND OF A
SKIER SAYS SO THE TRAINING
PERIOD THE ORDER SHOULD BE
DIFFERENT AVE ISSUE OF B. L.
ASSUMING. THAT THE- TRAINING
PERIOD THIS HORSE A MAN DO YOU
ARE SPECIFYING FIFTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS A SCHOLARSHIP SO
REGARDLESS OF WHICH KINDA THEY
WOULD BE ENTITLED TO GET THE
FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS. IT WILL
SAME TRACK. OKAY SO VERY
OBVIOUSLY- EUROPEAN WAS A
PROMPTED THAT BASED UPON THE OF
CURRENT A SHORTAGE AT THAT THE
RICE FIELD THIS EXPERIENCING.
FURTHER THERE THIS ISN'T WE'RE
TRYING TO INCENTIVIZE WE'RE
TRYING TO GET PEOPLE INVOLVED IN
THIS BILL. RIGHT NOW WERE WERE
THIS THIS FIELD AND THE ELDERLY
IT'S GONNA GET BUSIER BE MORE
MORE IN NUMBERS SO AS I SAID
EARLIER WAS THREE POINT TWO
MILLION RIGHT NOW AND THAT'S
GOING TO CONTINUE TO GROW. SO
WE'RE JUST GOT WE DON'T HAVE
TO SET UP BY SUPPOSED TO COME
INTO BILL. AND HOPEFULLY THAT
WILL HELP. YEAH I'M MUCH OF WAS
SUCH A WARM. CARE PROVIDERS ARE
PROPERLY SKILLED AND THE OR SO
MANY FAMILY MEMBERS ARE INVOLVED
COULD BE THE L. WILL BE FAB FM
FAMILY MEMBER THE ENTITLED THE
FOR THIS SCHOLARSHIP BE. YEAH A
LOT OF TIMES IT IS OUR OUR OUR
OWN FAMILY MEMBERS THAT ARE
TAKING CARE. SOMETIMES THEY HAVE
TO TAKE THEY HAVE TO. MAKE
CHANGES IN THEIR LIVES SOMETIMES
THEY HAVE TO O AND FIGURE OUT
HOW AM I GONNA TAKE CARE EITHER
MOM OR GRANDMA AND I HAVE TO
EITHER FIGURE OUT DAY CARE OR
SOME TYPE OF TRAINING OR- YOU
KNOW. IF THERE'S A HOUSE THERE
IS AN INCENTIVE FOR THE TIMES
THAT BUT IT IS IT. FIRST I CAN'T
I CAN'T- DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
THAT RIGHT I RIGHT NOW THIS IS
WHAT WE ARE GOING TO EVEN SEE
MORE AND MORE ELDERLY FOLKS AND
WHO'S GONNA TAKE CARE SO THIS IS
GOING TO BE AN INCENTIVE TO TRY
TO BRING FOLKS OUT TO TRY BOB
AND IT. YEAH MY MOTHER KNOWS SO
ONE HUNDRED THREE YEARS OLDER
THAN MY WIFE. OF COURSE TO HER
AND THE THANKS CARE VERS BUT I
DON'T THINK IT'S YOU KNOW CPR
AND SUGGESTING CASE SO MAYBE
WHAT I SHOULD SEND IT TO SCHOOL
WITH THIS A FIFTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLAR SCHOLARSHIP. THANK YOU.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. YES DR WEBER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE SPELL
AND- THANK YOU FOR COMMITTEE THE AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE
THE FIVE YEAR REQUIREMENT
BECAUSE THAT'S A LONG TIME TO
COME. I CURRENTLY HOW MUCH IS
ARE THESE TRAINING PROGRAMS
RIGHT NOW YEAH THURSDAY THURSDAY
RIGHT NOW THERE ISN'T ANY I MEAN
IT'S FIRST WITH. THERE'S NOTHING
. SO IF YOU'RE GONNA CALL IF
YOU'RE GONNA YOU'RE GONNA APPLY
YOUR GO THROUGH TRAINING BUT IF
YOU DON'T GET BOTHERED ABOUT GO
THROUGH THE TRAINING IS THERE IS
A PAY RIGHT SO LIKE YOU KNOW
SCHOOL PRINT THANK THANKS OUT.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA STOP JUST FOR A
MINUTE HERE SO THAT WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUARTER. MEDINA
PRESIDENT CHOI. ARAMBULA BLOOM.
GABRIEL IRWIN KILEY LEVINE LOW
SANTIAGO. VALLADARES WEBER. THE
QUORUM IS PRESENT DOCTOR EVER
CONTINUE THANK YOU. THANK ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE THE BILL. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU CHAIRED MEMBERS I
EXPECT THE ASTRONAUT ABOUT. I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING WITH. CAN I FIND THE
AMENDMENTS FOR BEING WILLING TO
TAKE THEM IN THE HELP COMMITTEE.
AS A COP CALIFORNIA BASED IN A-
ADDITIONAL HOMEMADE WILL BE
REQUIRED. TO ENSURE THE
POPULATION CAN AGE WITH GRACE IN
PLACE THIS BILL DOES PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL AVENUE BY WHICH HOME
HEALTH AIDES BRAIN TRAINING.
WITHOUT CURRY AT AND CORE. CAN
SENATE ADDITIONAL INDIVIDUALS TO
ENTER INTO THE CARE SERVICE OF
THE ELDER. WE HAD A- I. MISTER
LOPEZ SAID BY MISTER SUN- MY
SECRETARY THESE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
HEALTH. MEDINA I ENOUGH I CHOI
CHOI I ARAMBULA BLOOM GABRIEL
IRWIN KILEY LEVINE. LEVINE I LO
LO I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
VALLADARES WEBER. WEBER I'D.
OKAY THE PHYSICS SIX ZERO WOULD
KEEP THE BILL ON FILE AND GO TO
ITEM TWELVE AB. TWENTY TWO SIX
THREE OF THE- IS IT THIS YEAR
YOUR BILL ALSO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
. I'M SORRY ARE VERY DIFFERENT
YOU YOU DID WELL YOU DID WELL.
SO WE'RE ON ITEM WELL. THIS IS
THE CAR I THINK. A LITTLE I WELL
. A. B. TWENTY TWO SIXTY THREE
THANK YOU SHARE GOLDEN STATE
APPRENTICESHIP AND VOCATIONAL
USING OUTSIDE AROUND THE BILL.
OKAY ALL RIGHT. IT DOES HAVE A
SUPPORT SUPPORT THANK YOU CHAIR
MEMBERS AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY
THREE WILL ESTABLISH THE GOLDEN
STATE PRINT UP A PRINTER SHIP
AND OCCASIONAL TRAINING EMERGE.
WE'LL THROW. TIME C. GROUP JOBS
IN A ROW IN APPRENTICESHIP
ORDERBOOK TO PER ACCORDING TO
THE PURPOSE OF. THERE CAN TO BE
A HOBBY TO MEN OF THE PRINCES
PRINCESSES AND THERE ARE MORE
OPENING IT FEELS REQUIRED
TRAINING OUR QUALIFY APPLICANTS
. ONE OF THE MAIN BARRIERS OF
ACCESS TO APPRENTICESHIPS OUR
VOCATIONAL TRAINING PROGRAMS IS
THE COST MANY INDIVIDUALS DO NOT
HAVE THE FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO
ATTEND THE PROGRAM WITH THEM
FROM SUING A CAREER- DESIRE
FIELD AB TO SEE THREE WILL IN
THE WHO ARE FACING BY IT WHICH
WAS STAR ORDER.
TO TESTIFY IN AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY THREE IS ROBERT MARJORIE
WITH CALCHAMBER. THANK YOU A
CELL FROM. THANK YOU- AND MISTER
CHAIRMAN CHRIS GOOD AFTERNOON
I'LL BE BRIEF IN LIGHT OF THE
TEN PLUS BILL. BANNING AND FOR
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY IT IS THE
SKILLS GAP IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
LACK OF SKILLED AND VOCATIONALLY
WORKERS WHICH COULD TO KEEP THE-
OUR OUR ECONOMY GROWING GOING
FORWARD. WHAT POLICY INSTITUTE
CALIFORNIA. I WON'T GET INTO
SURPRISE IT. BUT IN LINE WITH OF
THE SUMMER SAID WE BELIEVE
FACILITATING THE USE OF EXISTING
APPRENTICESHIP OF OKAY PROGRAMS
IS A KEY WAY TO HELP. THAT SKILL
. THE WORKERS AND ARE. THOSE
REASONS WE WOULD URBAN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU IS THERE
ANOTHER WITNESS IN SUPPORTER. NO
OKAY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF YOU PLEASE COME THE
MICROPHONE. MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEDINA FEEL ON BEHALF OF AMBER
EDUCATION OUR SCHOOLS INCLUDE
INCLUDE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
COLLEGE IN CARRINGTON COLLEGE OR
IN SUPPORT OF A BETWEEN SIXTY
THREE YOU THANK YOU ANY THIS IS
. AN AREA. IN NINE. SEASONS OF
ON THE PHONE LINE EIGHTY T. MY-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
POINT TWO ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I WANTED ADVOCATE FOR AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY SIX ARE AT THEIR
ARE A LOT. WHAT I WANTED TO I
COULD BEAT YOU TO EIGHT YOU
FORTY SIX AND A THAT I AND I
WILL FOR. THANK YOU OKAY LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN. IF YOU. TO TOUCH
IN SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY TWO
SIXTY THREE PLAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY. AT THIS. AND WILL.
TO SELL. THREE MEMBERS JUST GOT
MORE AND THE COLOR DENTAL
ASSOCIATION WE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ONE TWO FIFTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON KAREN
MEMBERS MADELINE COOPER FROM
YELTSIN MARC BERMAN BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF CALIFORNIA WE
APOLOGIZE FOR THE LETTER IN ON
TIME TO BE REFERENCED IN THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT. WHETHER PARTY
ARE Q. UP THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY THREE AND THEIR- MISTER
MODERATOR. IF WE COULD GO TO THE
FRONT LINES FOR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY THREE. YOU ARE
IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY TWO
SIXTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONE FELL BY BUT THIS TIME
. EXPRESS OPPOSITION. TO TWENTY
TWO SIXTY THREE. MISTER CHAIR
NOBODY'S GIVING UP THANK YOU ANY
TWEETERS IN THE HEARING ROOM. C.
NINE. MISTER MODERATOR IF THERE
ANY WINNERS ONLINE. AB TWENTY
TWO SIXTY THREE. ANY TRAINERS
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. NOT AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS BY THE
COMMITTEE. DR CHOI WELL YEAH I
THINK OF THIS IS ALSO A VERY
IMPORTANT THE RECORD FROM
RECRUITMENT. B. L. A. IS SAYS-
THIS IS- CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN
AID TO COMMISSION THAT TO
PROVIDE A ONE TIME GRANT TO A
CALIFORNIA RESIDENCY MEASURE
THAT NEEDS TO. OUR DO YOU MEAN
FINANCIALLY QUALIFIED THAT
SOMEONE AND A ONE TIME GRANT IS-
WHAT THE RECRUITMENT THE NEXT
BONUS SO WHAT WHAT WILL BE. WE
SHOWN DURING THAT THE PETITION
PERIOD- WHAT DO YOU HAVE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT- SEPT- DEPENDING
UPON- EACH TRADE CATEGORY. HOLD
UP YOU ONE TIME MORE UNIVERSAL-
SAY MY MOM TO- I BELIEVE THE
PRESENT LAYERS OF BILLS A ONE
TIME AMOUNT ACROSS CATEGORIES- I
TOP MY BELIEVE IT'S CAP
PRESENTLY I THINK IT FIVE
HUNDRED THAT'S ACROSS ALL
CATEGORIES THAT IS ONE TIME.
THANK YOU. GO AHEAD IF YOU'RE-
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SCOTT WHICH
IS A TWEETER THE TWITTER HAVE A
LETTER ON THIS BILL- WE LOOK AT
THE ON THE- ASSOCIATION CORKER'S
THE CALIFORNIA STATE STREET
COUNCIL. IN THE WEST TO SEIZE
CANCEL SHEET METAL WORKERS WE
LOOK AT WORKING WITH THE OUGHT
WE JUST BELIEVE IS SIMILAR TO
CALGARY. THE THIS IS WHO ARE
SUBSCRIBED TO AN APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM WITH A HIGH GRADUATION
RATE. THEY SHOULD THEY SHOULDN'T
BE GIVEN TO APPRENTICES WHO ARE
ATTENDING- BRITISH PROGRAMS THAT
DON'T HAVE A TRACK RECORD OF
GRADUATING APPRENTICES SIMILAR
TO WHAT WE REQUIRE OF THE CAL
GRANT. WILL WITH AUTHOR YEAH
THEY- GOOD I JUST WANNA CLARIFY
MY ANSWER TOO FAR CHOI I'M SORRY
I MISSPOKE I JUST VERIFIED IT'S
ACTUALLY BETWEEN ONE THOUSAND
THREE. APOLOGIES FOR THE
INCORRECT. THANK YOU YEAH. I
THOUGHT THE DEPEND UPON CERTAIN
INDUSTRY- THEY DO PAY- DURING
THE- SIX MONTHS A YEAR WHATEVER
INDUSTRY EACH INDUSTRY MAY BE
DIFFERENT OF THAT PERIOD THE
BRITISH SHIP. THE AND THE DAY TO
PAY BECAUSE OF THE WORK
ALONGSIDE THE SOURCE MASTER
SKILLED TEACHER- SO- IT EVEN FOR
THEY ARE PAID THE WOULD THE
WOULD THEY BE ALLOWED TO GET
THIS- ONE TIME GRANT. YES AT A
SO MUCH OF MY MICROPHONE IS ON
CAN YOU HEAR ME ALRIGHT THAT IS
WORKING OKAY- HE IS- ANDERSON
QUESTION BETTER NOW THAN IT IS
ARE PAID DIFFERENTLY THE AMOUNT
UNDER THIS BILL IS. SEPARATED BY
A- YOU I'M- NOT LIVE. RIGHT HAVE
A BUT IT ALSO MEANT TO ADDRESS
AND- EARLIER STATE GAY YOU INTO
THE PIPELINE REALLY TO GET YOU
ROLLING INTO CONCERN FOR YOU'RE
IN IT SAME WAY. ANY CHANGE YOUR
- FROM COMMITTEE. US SOME
REMEMBER IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE
THINKER'S CHAIR MEMBERS NAY
PERSPECTIVE YES OR NO VOTE I
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THE BILL. AND IS IT SAID HERE
THE PRINTER IS DUE- BENEFIT FROM
THAT EARN AS YOU LEARN MODEL.
BUT EVEN SOMETIMES IN THE UNDER
SOME CIRCUMSTANCES A MERGING
SEIZE ARISE THAT REQUIRE
IMMEDIATE ASSISTANCE. AB TWENTY
TWOS D. THREE. DRIVES TO MEET
THAT NEED. AND I THINK THIS
AGGRESSIVE MOMENTS AND ANALYSIS
WILL HELP. GET US WHERE THEY'RE
AND I- THE YES THE THIRD- LOOK
AT THOSE SUGGESTIONS AND-
PERHAPS- ADOPT THEM MOVING
FORWARD SO WE HAD A MOTION BY.
MISTER SANTIAGO UNDER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
AYE MEDINA HI CHOI. CHOI I
ARAMBULA BLOOM BLOOM I GABRIEL
IRWIN KILEY LEVINE LEVINE I LO
LEVEL II SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
BALLADARES WEBER. ONE SIX ZERO
WE WILL KEEP THE BILL UNCALLED
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU.
NOW WILL GO TO FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN A. B. TWENTY NINETY
THREE MISTER MATHIS. WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN HAD BEEN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I WANT
TO START OFF BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE STAFF- FOR THEIR WORK
ON THIS MEASURE AND- TO NOTE
THAT I HAVE ACCEPTED THE A
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
OUTLINED ON THE COMMITTEE AND
SUS. A. I. IN EIGHT TWENTY
NINETY THREE FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THIS MEASURE WOULD
CREATE AN EDUCATIONAL LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAM FOR OUR
STATE'S FIRST RESPONDERS WHO
SERVE IN UNDER REPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES FOR FIVE YEARS.
DESPITE THE STATE'S EFFORTS TO
ATTRACT FIRST RESPONDERS TO
DISADVANTAGED AND UNDER
REPRESENTED AREAS THERE REMAINS
IN AN EQUAL DISTRIBUTION OF
QUALIFIED STAFF. AND ACTION.
WATER SERVICES EXPRESSLY WITHIN
RURAL AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. FOR MANY FIRST
RESPONDERS. IT IS NOT
ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE OR
ADVANTAGEOUS TO WORK WITH AND
RURAL OR DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES PRIMARY THE DUE TO
THE UNLIMITED POTENTIAL AND
COVERINGS AND THE NEED TO REPAY
STUDENT LOANS. FIRSTERS ARE ALL
IN FACED WITH A DOCUMENT OF
EITHER WORKING IN THEIR LOCAL%
COMMUNITIES FOR A SIGNIFICANT
LOWER SALARY OR WORKING IN MORE
AFFLUENCE. REGIONS OR FOR
PRIVATE COMPANIES THAT OFFER A
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER SALARY THE
OUTCOME OF WHICH RESULTED IN
VAST EQUITY IN THE TERMS. MISTER
UP FIRST RESPONDERS.
X. IN ORDER TO COMBAT THESE
STAFF SHORTAGES AB TWENTY NINETY
THREE CREATES AN INCENTIVIZE
PROGRAM DEVELOPED UPON THE
PROVEN SUCCESS OF THE EXISTING
STEVEN REPAYMENT I'M WHICH- IN
TWO THOUSAND THREE. THIS PROGRAM
HAS DONE AN AMAZING I'M AND
BRINGING AND PHYSICIANS IN
MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED AREAS.
HOWEVER MORE IMPORTANTLY IT IS
HELP KEEP THEM FIRMLY ROOTED IN
THESE COMMUNITIES. IT'S HARD
ENOUGH FOR OUR ROADS AND
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES TO
ATTRACT QUALIFIED CANDIDATES LET
ALONE RETAIN THEM FOR YEARS ON
END. THOUGH THIS BILL. WE SEEK
TO PROVIDE OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
WHILE ALSO FOSTERING THE
RELATIONSHIPS WITHIN THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SERVE.
WHERE IS THAT YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS MEASURE- TODAY I
BELIEVE WE HAVE. JULIO DE LEON
FROM THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT I'M NOT
SURE IF HE'S STILL HERE HE'S
HERE ALL RIGHT. THE TABLE IT OUT
YOU KNOW IF YOU'D PLEASE- YOU
MAY EXPECT. AND IT WILL BE YOU
MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD
AFTERNOON COUNCIL COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS BILL COMES AT AN
OPPORTUNE TIME OUR HISTORY OR
CALL FOR RAISING THE BAR FOR
PEACE OF CATIA. BARRING THEM
WELL IT IN. SAID CITING EIGHT
EIGHT NINE WHAT THAT'S HEREBY
SOME MEMBERS. YOUR SENIOR. I'M
IN THAT DEAL HE MET HIMSELF
STUDY HAS ALSO THAT BETTERIDGE
OFFICERS PERFORM BETTER IN THE
ACADEMY RECEIVE HIGHER SUPER
SUPER. AND HAVE FEWER DO
PROBLEMS. AND ACCIDENTS AND
ASSAULTED LESS OFTEN AND MISS
FEWER DAYS OF WORK THAN THEIR
COUNTERPARTS WHO DID NOT HAVE A
COLLEGE EDUCATION. MANY OF OUR
SHARES- IN OUR AGENCY SHARE
SIMILAR BACKGROUNDS AND
STRUGGLED. CONTINUE TO SERVE
COMMUNITIES DESPITE THE- EFFORTS
. OF THAT AT THE TIME HI
EDUCATION- IN MY LETTER. ADDRESS
ONE PARTICULAR START OR EIGHT.
WHO IS A FIRST BORN HERE THIS
COUNTRY. PROVIDE THEY FOR ME
THERE IS AN TO SEND KERN RIVER
ARTIST EVERY NOW WORK FOR AN
PART A PART- AS A SRG- HE'S ALSO
A LAWYER. AND THAT'S A OR- YES
LAW SCHOOL HIMSELF AND THE
PERSON IS ME- I HAVE OVER SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN DEBT AND WE
HAVE SEVERAL OTHER. THE SHARES
IN OUR VISION THAT ALSO SHAE
SIMILAR STORIES SO THIS BILL
WOULD DEFINITELY HELP- OUT NOT
ONLY ME BUT THOUSAND THEY'RE-
OFFICERS AND DEPUTIES THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE. WHO TO THE- THERE'S I
FELT THANK YOU THANK YOU OTHER
WITNESSES. NO ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND THE
HEARING ROOM. AN EIGHTEEN T. OP-
IF WE COULD GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF AB. TWENTY NINETY THREE. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE ESPY IN SUPPORT
FOR AB TWENTY NINETY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. MISTER CHAIR WILL DELIGHT
TO FIFTY YOU ARE OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT YOU CHAIR MATH. WITH
THEIR AGREED TO SOLICIT SOME
PERHAPS POOR ACTING STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE- THANK YOU. AS A
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWENTY NINETY
THREE AND WE WILL GO TO LINE TWO
SEVEN WERE OPEN. BUT AFTER.
HELLO IT SHOULD PORT AB TWENTY
THREE THANK YOU THANK YOU. AND
WE DO HAVE ONE MORE PARTICIPANT
WITH AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT
PLEASE.
AND FOR EVERYBODY ELSE BUT THEY
TOOK THEMSELVES OUT TO Q. RIGHT
THANK YOU. THIS IS AN OPPOSITION
IN THE HEARING ROOM. SEE NOT ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ANOTHER
PHONE LINES MR OPERATOR. WHICH
IS IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
NINETY THREE. IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY NINETY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME ONE FALL BY ZERO. AND
MISTER CHAIR NOBODY IS QUEUING
UP I THANK YOU. ANY TWEETERS IN
THE HEARING ROOM. ANY TWEET IS
ON THE PHONE LINE EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR. BURKE TWEENER TO AB
TWENTY NINETY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR NOBODY'S KILLING UP THANK
YOU ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. BUT THE
MOTION. BY MISTER LOIS SECOND BY
MR SANTIAGO- MISTER MATHIS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SH
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON THIS MEASURE TO HELP OUR FOR
RISK THANK YOU. I THANK. I AGREE
THAT FIRST RESPONDERS CONTINUE
TO BE OUR FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE
IN EMERGENCIES AND THEREFORE
DESERVE OUR SUPPORT SPECIALLY IN
LIGHT OF THEIR SERVICE DURING
THIS PAST THAT MAKE AND I WANT
TO COMMEND YOU NEEDS COULD
WITNESS FROM. I THANK BYE IN
SOME. STORY THAT I WAS FAMILIAR
WITH- SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER LEWIS SECOND BY MR
SANTIAGO A MATTER SICK. CALLED
PASSES AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA I CHOI. CHOI I
ARAMBULA BLOOM BLOOM I GABRIEL
IRWIN KILEY LEVINE LEVINE I LO
LO I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
CALAVERAS WEBER. SIX ZERO THE
BILL IS ON CALL WE'LL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR THANK YOUNG MEMBERS.
AND MOVED TO FILE ITEM FIFTEEN.
A. B. TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO THIS
RACE. WELCOME AND WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS. I PRESENT
TO YOU AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO
THE GOLDEN STATE SOCIAL
OPPORTUNITY GRANT PROGRAM THIS
BILL ADDRESSES CRITICAL
SHORTAGES WITHIN THE MENTAL
HEALTH WORKFORCE BY REDUCING
FINE. MR AS THE- OR COMES MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS CALIFORNIA IS
CURRENTLY FACING A SEVERE
SHORTAGE OF LICENSED MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS FURTHER OUR
MENTAL HEALTH WORKFORCE DOES NOT
REFLECT CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE BE
WITH AND WHAT THE PROFESSIONALS
BEING THE MOST UNDER REPRESENTED
GROUPS IN THE FIELD. STILL
CAREERS AS MEDICAL. THERE'S
COMPLETE EXTENSIVE FIELDWORK
RANGING FROM FOUR HUNDRED TO
EIGHT HUNDRED HOURS PER YEAR
THIS CREATES A FINANCIAL BARRIER
FOR STUDENTS WHO MUST WORK
QUALITATIVE SCHOOL FORCING THEM
TO SCALE BACK. OR FORGO THEIR
EMPLOYMENT ALTOGETHER IN ORDER
TO COMPLETE THE FIELD WORK.
ESPECIALLY IN OUR FOSTER YOUTH
AND HOMELESS YOUTH WHO SEEK TO
SERVE OTHERS WHO SHARE THEIR LOW
LIVED EXPERIENCES BUT MAY LACK
THE FINANCIAL RESOURCES TO
PURSUE CAREERS IN THIS FIELD. AB
TWENTY TWO. SEARCH SCHOLAR.
ANNUALLY TO STUDENTS TO COMMIT
TO WORKING AT THE CALIFORNIA
BASED NONPROFIT AFTER GRADUATION
AS THEY WORK TOWARDS OBTAINING
FULL LICENSURE. OUR TIES AND
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND HOMELESS
YOUTH FOR GRANTS AB TWENTY TWO
TWENTY TWO WILL ADDRESS CRITICAL
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES AND SHORT
CALIFORNIA IS A MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ARE REFLECTIVE OF
THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE THIS
BILL WILL ALSO IMPROVE QUALITY%
OF CARE FOR CURRENT FOSTER AND-
BUT- WITH PROVIDERS. WHO SHARE
THEIR LIVES X. IS. A TEST FIND
SUPPORT ARE KIM LEWIS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
AND NICK MARIANA A STUDENTS WHO
WOULD BENEFIT FROM THE FINANCIAL
SUPPORT THIS PROGRAMMATIC FIGHT
. YOUR WOULD IT IS OUR ONE ON
THE PHONE ON THE PHONE ONE ON
THE PHONE OKAY ALL RIGHT. YEAH
WHERE IS THE THING CARE GOOD
AFTERNOON CAN LAST REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
YOUTH WITH AT ADVOCATES ON
BEHALF OF YOUNG PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. WHICH
ARE. PRESIDENT OF THE YOUTH OF
COLOR AND YOU THAT IDENTIFIES
LGBTQ YEAR. I DURING THE
PANDEMIC UC BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S TRUST AND C. C. Y.
CONDUCTED A SURVEY OF YOUNG
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOME. ACCESS
SERVICES AT 81% NEED HELP
EMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE SO IT'S NO
SURPRISE THAT ONE OF OUR KEY
FINDINGS WAS THAT THE INCREASE
NATIVE M. PREVENT HAT. BOB THE
SURVEY IDENTIFIED THAT ANY
SUCCESSFUL SOLUTION TO ENDING
YOUTH HOMELESSNESS WOULD INCLUDE
TARGETED MENTAL HEALTH AND
EMOTIONAL HEALTH INVEST. AT THE
SAME TIME ARE NOT. SERVING THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE AND POPULATIONS ARE
STRUGGLING GIVEN THAT THEIR
STAFF ARE HITTING THEIR CAPACITY
AND UP AND YOU KNOW SIGNIFICANT
STRAINS ON THEIR MENTAL WELL
BEING AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR WORKFORCES NONPROFITS
REPRESENT THE COMMUNITIES THAT
WE SERVE. SO THE PRICE. DEMO
BURKE DID A STUDY CONDUCTED THAT
SHOWED THAT 28% OF THE COMBINED
OF THE PSYCHOLOGIST LMF TEETH L.
C.'S LCSW WOULD BE LESS WHAT'S
AVAILABLE IN THE FUTURE NEEDS SO
WE KNOW NEED TO CONTINUE TO ARM
WORK FOR. SOMEONE THAT ARE. FROM
LOWER. GET ON THE FRONT END
SUPPORT THEM WHETHER IT INSTEAD
OF BEING ONE OF THE LUCKY ONES
ON THE BACK AND HE'LL GET A LOAN
FORGIVENESS PROGRAM SO I THINK
IT. WITNESSES ON THE LINE
OPERATOR. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NINE IMPACT
NICK MARIANA I'M NOT REGISTERED
ASSOCIATE CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER
SPEAKING TODAY ON IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO. I HAD
TO PROVIDE STAFF IN THE BEHAVE
FIELD FOR ALMOST EIGHTEEN YEARS
NOW- THE STAFF AT THE FRONT LINE
WORKERS AND DIRECT CHARACTERS
THE IN THE LIVE PICTURE AND
FAMILIES WHO'VE EXPERIENCED
TRAUMA SUCH AS VIOLENCE
HOMELESSNESS AND POVERTY. AND
OPINION THE STAFF HAVE THE
HARDEST JOB IN BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
BECAUSE THEY WORK DIRECTLY WITH
THE MOST CHALLENGING AND INTENSE
SITUATION. THE DATA. PEOPLE
OFTEN HAVE TO WORK TO. NO LIVING
WAGE AND A COMMON SENTIMENT I
HEAR FROM THE STAFF I TO PROVIDE
IS THAT THEY WOULD LOVE TO GO TO
SCHOOL TO EARN A MASTER'S DEGREE
ELEVATE ADDITION A- THEY WERE
NOT. STILL ALL TOO OFTEN
ACTIVITY STAFF BURNOUT TURNOVER
AND ULTIMATELY THE FIELD WITH
HIS SKILLED PROFESSIONAL AND THE
CLIENTS WE SERVE SULPHUR. DURING
GRADUATE SCHOOL I WAS LOOKING IN
DALY CITY THE ONLY WAY I COULD
AFFORD TO ATTEND MY GRADUATE
PROGRAM WITH TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE WORKING THROUGHOUT.
TIME I'M AND I WAS VERY
PRIVILEGED MY WORKPLACE BUT VERY
ACCOMMODATING AROUND MY
SCHOOLING- THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
COMMON AMONG MY CLASSMATES AND
THE IN THAT KEEP IN MIND IT.
ALL THE TENSION ON MY GRADUATE
PROGRAM- AND I AM SURE THAT IT
WOULD DO SO FOR OTHER. INCLUDES
PART OF THE- VIRGINIA BEACH FOR
PEOPLE TO WORK IN THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH FIELD TO SUPPORT THOSE
WHO HAPPENED EXPERIENCE KNOWS
ALL WORKING IN THE BILL TO BE
PRIORITIZED SCHOLARS. THE BIG.
DEFAULT HOW COME COME WITH
INCREASING AMOUNT OF GUILT
PROFESSIONALS WORK LIKE THE
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY SERVE- AND
INCREASING THE BEHAVIORAL
INCREASING HE PROFESSIONAL OR
WORK TO PASS THE DAY WILL HELP
YOU TO MAKE FAMILY. I AM. YOUR
IDOL TWENTY HE TOOK ME TO. THANK
YOU FOR TIME THANK YOU AND OTHER
WITNESSES AND SOME AND HEARING
ROOM. C. NINE EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR IF THERE ARE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO ON THE
PHONE LINES. FOR EIGHT. TWENTY
TWO PRESS ONE BOB ZERO THIS TIME
ONE FOLLOWED ZERO AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE OUT TO SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND YOU KNOW. PART OF
AB TWENTY TWENTY TWO YEAH THANK
YOU. ANYBODY ELSE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR AB
TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. YOU
ARE. OPERATING A MOMENT. YES.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE TWO
SEVENTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN. I
THANK IN THERE WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO TWO
TWO. YEAH THANK YOU. WHAT ELSE
YOU GOT MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION A.
B. TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWOIN THE
HEARING ROOM. AND DITION ON THE
PHONE LINES MR OUR MODERATOR. WE
WERE IN OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY
TWO TWENTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. BY ZERO.
NOBODY'S KILLING UP MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU ANY TWEETERS ON A B.
TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO IN THE
HEARING ROOM MAY NOT ANY WINNERS
UP MINE. IF YOU ARE TWEENER TO
AB TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS BY THE COMMITTEE. HELLO
MOTION BY MR LOW. SECOND BY
DOCTOR CHOI- ASSEMBLY WOMAN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE I%
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL- AND
PORTENT. AB TWO CLINICAL. FRESH
PROFESSIONALS THAT THEY CAN
RELATE TO THIS MEASURE SEEKS TO
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE BURDENS
THEY KEEP TO PURPOSE IN THIS
PERFECT IS I ASKED OTHER DO
CONTINUE TO WITH HIS. EIGHT
ON A SECOND BY DOCTOR CHOI AND-
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE APPROACH. I BY CHAU. AROUND
BLOOM GABRIEL IRWIN KILEY LEVINE
LEVINE I LO LO I SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I BALLADARES WEBER.
WEBER II. SIX ZERO THE BILL IS
ON CALL WE WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS AND I WILL GO TO
ITEM SIXTEEN AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY YOU NEED TO CALL PLEASE
SHOULD BACK. THE CALL. COMPLY
THEIR CLOSE TO BE DIFFICULT
WITHIN YEARS. FOR MANY STUDENT
CENTER COMMUNITY COLLEGE WITH
THE EXPECTATION OF COMPLETING
THEIR DEGREES ARE TRANSFERRING
IN TWO YEARS. TO COMPLETION
RATES ARE LOW IN TWENTY NINETEEN
REPORT A REPORT FOUND THAT ONLY
13% OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FRESHMEN EARN THEIR ASSOCIATE'S
DEGREE WITHIN TWO YEARS THESE
RATES ARE USUALLY LOW FOR OF
COLOR. WELL SEVENTY NINE AND A
BLACK AND SEVENTY EIGHT BUT THE
MOST. IN FULL WITH ALL
PERTAINING A TWO YEAR DEGREE OR
TRANSFERRING TO INSTITUTION ALL
. SENT THE STUDENTS SITE
DIFFICULTIES WITH PLANNING THEIR
COURSE SCHEDULES AND ACCESSING
THE COURSES THEY NEED WITHIN A
TWO YEAR TIME FRAME THE STUDENTS
MUST OFTEN CHOOSE BETWEEN MANY
SAYS FURTHER READING COULD.
INTERVAL THIS MAKES FRESH
DIFFICULT FOR STUDENTS WITH
OBLIGATIONS OUTSIDE OF SCHOOL
SUCH AS WORK OR FAMILY TO PLAN
FOR AND COMPLETE THEIR DEGREES.
AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT WILL
ADDRESS ISSUES BY REQUIRING
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO PUBLISH A
CLEAR SCHEDULE OF COURSES
STUDENTS NEED TO COMPLETE EACH
DEGREE OF THE TIME IT TAKES TO
COMPLETE THEM. THIS BILL WILL
INCREASE TRANSIT. THIS IS EIGHT
IT UP. ETHNICITY ECONOMIC STATUS
AND ENROLLMENT STATUS. FINALLY
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
WILL ENSURE COLLEGES OFFER
COURSES AT THE INTERVALS
STUDENTS NEED TO COMPLETE THEIR
DEGREE AND CERTIFICATES WITHIN
TWO YEARS THE BILL. SHORES HOW
TO BUILD BARBARA. JUST THAT
WELCOME WITH THE PROVISIONS TO
HOLD A PUBLIC HEARING EVERY THE
REASON THEY DIDN'T. PART I WANT
. THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL AND I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS TODAY HERE TO SUPPORT
OUR JOSE FUNERAL PRESIDENT OF
SURREAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE THE
ARBELA IT CAN BE CALLED STUDENTS
AT ST STE. THANK YOU. THANK
ASSEMBLY RIGHT THIS FOR YEARS
FOR VERY IMPORTANT BILL GOOD
AFTERNOON- CHAIRED BY THE NOW
BUT THE CHECK CHOI A COMMITTEE
MEMBERS- FEDERAL. I AM THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LATINO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRUSTEES AND
ADMINISTRATORS. AND ALSO THE
PRESIDENT TO PUT THAT AND OF TO
REDUCE COLLEGE. THROUGH THIS
COLLEGE WHERE NINE OUT OF TEN
IT'S STUDENTS THAT IS STUDENTS
OF COLOR. SERVICE CALL IS THE
PLACE WHERE THE **** STUDENTS
GET ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION
HOWEVER. MANY WERE TO STUDENTS
TAKE A VERY VERY LONG ROLE TEN
EXPENSIVE ROAD TO REACH THAT
DREAM. IN CALIFORNIA ONLY TWO
OUT OF ONE HUNDRED LATINO
STUDENTS COMPLETE THEIR
ASSOCIATE DEGREE IN TWO YEARS.
YES THAT WAS NOT A MISTAKE ONLY
TWO OUT OF ONE HUNDRED. IT'S
STUDENTS THAT THE STUDENTS. IN
pSYSTEM COMPLETED DEGREE WENT IN
TWO YEARS. 70% OF THEM ARE THEY
STILL WORKING ON THAT ASSOCIATE
DEGREE EIGHT YEARS LATER. ABOUT
RARE TO STUDENTS FACES THE
CAFETERIA MODEL. DIVERTIDA MODEL
ESSENTIALLY AS A MODEL THE GIVES
THE STUDENTS A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY COURSES TO PEAK AND SAID
GOOD LUCK WE'LL SEE YOU ON THE
PODIUM YOU FIND YOUR WAY TO
APPROACH. A. B. THIRTY EIGHT IT
WOULD PROVIDE US TO. WAIT WHY.
PLAN YES IT IS OPTIONAL BUT HE'S
ONE PLAN IN WHICH THE STUDENTS
WILL BE ABLE TO GET. AN ACADEMIC
PROGRAM I'M WITH A SINGLE FORCE
THEY NEED TO TAKE IN ORDER TO
COMPLETE THE PROBE I'M TWENTY.
YEARS THREE YEARS FOUR. AND THEN
OF. AN ACADEMICAL. IF WE WANT TO
REMAKE THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY
IN THE WERE. IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE EDUCATE WITHOUT THE LATE
THE FASTEST GROWING DEMOGRAPHIC
IN THE STATE. FOR COMMUNITY CALL
WHICH IF A COMMUNITY COLLEGES
UNABLE TO GRADUATE RATHER TEND
TO OUT OF ONE HUNDRED LET YOU
KNOW STUDENTS. FOR ONE HUNDRED
STUDENTS WITH ASSOCIATE DEGREE
EVERY YEAR WE WILL BE PROVIDING
OR COMMUNITIES WITH INNOVATION
ALL TWELVE THOUSAND. AND FORTY.
DINO COMPLETION FOR D. F. AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY H. O.
STUDENTS AND FACULTY HOW THEY
CAN COMPLETE THAT CUT GOALS IN A
TIMELY MANNER AND THAT- WHO.
YEAH TWENTY SIX BE A THANK YOU.
pTHANK YOU NEXT WITNESS THE HERE
YES. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS OUR
MONDO MARVEL AT THE SECOND. AND
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT IT. I'M HERE
STUDENTS AT CERRITOS COLLEGE. WE
OFTEN HEAR THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
IS A TWO YEAR JOURNEY A BRIDGE
TO A FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITY.
BRIGHTER FUTURE. DOES NOT OFTEN
HEARD IS ALL THE SIDE ROADS
PITFALLS SETBACKS IN
MISINFORMATION ALONG THAT
JOURNEY. EVERY YEAR KNOWS THE
VALUE OF PROPER INFORMATION. IT
IS A TOOL THAT HELPS US BE MORE
EFFICIENT WITH OUR TIME AND
EFFORTS. AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT ACTS AS AN ADDITIONAL TOOL
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. TO HELP
STREAMLINE THEIR PATH TO THEIR
BRIGHTER FUTURE. AS IS YOUR
STUDENT I HAVE HAD MULTIPLE
OPPORTUNITIES TO LEAD SPEAK AND
WORK WITH MY FELLOW STUDENTS.
ANY WITH CONCERNS OF HOW LONG
THEIR HAS TAKEN THEM SOME LOSING
HOPE IN THEIR ABILITY TO
CONTINUE. BUT AB TWENTY SEVENTH.
HAS THE ABILITY TO FURTHER
SUPPORT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS IN A WAY THAT MAKES OUR
TIME AND EFFORT MORE EFFICIENT.
GIVING FUTURE STATE DIRECTOR IN
CLEAR PATH ACROSS. I WISH TO
CLOSE WITH SOMETHING I OBSERVED
AS VICE PRESIDENT OF OUR STUDENT
BODY. IF WE GIVE ARE THE TOOLS
AND INFORMATION THEY NEED. THEY
WILL SUCCEED. AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. YOU
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. C.
NINE EIGHTEEN TO MODERATOR ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT FOR A BI
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT. ON
THE PHONE LINES. WE WOULD LIKE
TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE
FILED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY. CHOI BECAUSE A LOT.
MISTER CHAIR NOBODY'S QUEUING UP
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN
THE HEARING ROOM. EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR OF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION FOR AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT ON THE
PHONE LINES. YOUR POSITION TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. THE BODIES
QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU ANY TRAINERS IN THE HEARING
ROOM. CORRECT WINNERS. PLEASE
COME UP. THANK YOU TERRY MEMBERS
DAVID O'BRIEN OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE NO OFFICIAL POSITION AT
THIS TIME BUT WE'VE HAD MANY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR AND SPONSORS AND ARE
FULLY A- IN A REMOVED. INTO THIS
LEGISLATOR GIVE THANK YOU. AT&T
MODERATOR OF THEIR ANY TWEETERS
ON THE PHONE LINE. TWEENER TO
OUR AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR NOBODY IS KILLING UP THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THE
MOTION BY MR LOW SECOND BY MR
SANTIAGO- ASSEMBLY WOMAN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THEIR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU- BEFORE I CALL
FOR THE VOTE I JUST WANNA SAY
THAT AS A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TRUSTEE. AS A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TEACHER AS A HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER. I OFTEN REMINDED
STUDENTS THAT IT'S A FOUR YEAR
COLLEGE DEGREE. AND EVERYTHING
THAT. TO KEEP IT- IS WORK IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION SO I THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT FOR OVER
BRING THOSE FORWARD. OF AN
ADDITIONAL STEP COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TO ENSURE STUDENTS HAVE
THE INFORMATION THEY NEED TO
MAKE EDUCATIONAL DECISIONS AND
TAKE THE COURSES THAT ARE.
MOSTLY AVAILABLE FOR STUDENTS
THAT WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
LOW AND THE SECOND BY. HELLO I'M
SECRETARY OF. IN THE PAST AS A
MAN TO THE COMMITTEE MEDINA AYE
MEDINA AYE CHOI CHOI I ARAMBULA
BLOOM BLOOM I GABRIEL IRWIN
KILEY LEVINE. LEVINE I LO LO I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I BALLADARES
WEBER WEBER II. SEVEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT AND WE WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK
YOU. NOW WILL GO TO A FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
TWO MR MCCARTY. WELCOME.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEDINA FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT THIS
BILL- SOME OF YOU MAY HEARD THIS
LAST WEEK IN THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE THIS IS AN OP YOU
PRESENT HERE TODAY AT HIGHER.
SHIN IS RANKED AS ONE THE TOP
FIVE ENVIRONMENTAL RISKS TO
PUBLIC HEALTH IT'S NOT JUST AN
ABSTRACT ISSUE I KNOW TWO YEARS
AGO HERE IN SACRAMENTO SOME YOU
MAY MAY THAT. AT THE WORK
QUALITY GIRLS. THAT WE FOR A FEW
DAYS AND IMPACTS NOT ONLY THE
AIR OUTSIDE BUT THIS CLASSROOMS
AND STUDENTS INSIGHTS A
PROTECTING PUBLIC HEALTH NOT
JUST OUTSIDE. MARK AND HOT.
HENCE BACK. EVERY FEW YEARS
WE'LL MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
GOOD AIR QUALITY IS CRITICAL TO
. THE PUBLIC HEALTH BUT ALSO OUR
STUDENTS WHO WORST TIME IN THE
CLASSROOM AND CONVERSELY
IMPROPER VENTILATION POOR INDOOR
AIR QUALITY. PUTS OUR STUDENTS
AND KIDS AT RISK PARTICULARLY
THAT WITH THEIR SET
SUSCEPTIBILITY TO ENVIRONMENTAL
HAZARDS. THAT'S WHY HAVING THIS
LAW REQUIRING A QUICK INSPECTION
OF THE EQUIPMENT IN OUR- PUBLIC
EDUCATION SPACES IS GOOD FOR A
PUBLIC HEALTH BOOK GOOD FOR OUR
STUDENTS AND FOR CALIFORNIA. IN
COURT TO AT TWELVE TWENTY REPORT
FROM UC DAVIS OVER HALF OF NEW
H. PACS SYSTEMS HAVE SIGNIFICANT
PROBLEMS. THREE AFTER THEY SENT
ABOUT CLASS IS HAVE TO MEET
THESE NEW MOMENTUM RAY- COMBINE
THESE. FOR WELL IN IN. POSS THE
WORD. THIS IS A BILL SAYS NOT
ONLY A SMART BILL FR CALIFORNIA
REPUBLIC CALCULATE IT'S NEW IT'S
THAT EVERY FIVE YEARS YOU SHOULD
HAVE THE SINCE. IT'S AND WE WILL
GO TO THE TO THE PEOPLE WHO IT'S
NOT ONLY A REALLY HONOR THEN
COULD YOU THIS IS NOT TV. AND UP
TO. CHANCE TO YOU UP EARLY
PUBLIC MONEY TO MAKE THOSE FIXES
FOR PLACE TO LOWER THEIR BILLS
ALSO- AIR QUALITY AND HEALTH WE
NEED ARE REPRESENTS IN THE STATE
BY TRADE CAPSULE THIS MATTER
WORKERS RIVALS THANK YOU. OF
WHICH- WESTERN ALSO SHE CAN WORK
. IT DRAFT BY THE ALL. PRIOR A
THE ODDS ON SAID OF THE G. A.
THE GENERAL OFFICE DO A SURVEY
OF SO FOR CONGRESS. IN HEALTH IS
ONE OF THE FOUND THAT FIFTY PER
OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
VENTILATION SYSTEMS FAILED TO
INFORM STANDARDS REQUIRED BY THE
C. C. IN ORDER TACTIC IT. DID
YOU NOT. THAT HAVE BEEN THE
COMMISSION E. P. T. IT FOUND
THAT. NEW H. BACK SYSTEMS UP
23250% OF NEW H. FAX SYSTEMS IN
85% REPLACE SYSTEMS- LOOK. GREAT
30% LESS EFFICIENCY BECAUSE OF
THE FACT THAT THEY'RE NOT
PROPERLY MAINTAINED AND
CALIBRATED BY FOLKS WHO ARE
TRAINED TO PROPERLY CALIBRATE
UPS- BE THAT WERE BY THE- THIS.
IS FISHES ARE ALSO FOR. THAT 20%
OF CALIFORNIA CLASSROOMS
AVERAGED NEARLY TWO THOUSAND
PARTS PER MILLION OF CARBON
MONOXIDE. IS ALMOST DOUBLE. THE
WHAT THE STATE HAS BEEN A SAFE
LEVEL THIS BILL WOULD ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM FOR US I REQUEST
YOU CAN. I'M THIS JUST ONE
HERE'S AND WOULD THAT CO TWO
MONITORS BE PLACED IN THE
CLASSROOMS THESE ARE NOT HARD
WIRED CO TWO ORDERS THEY MAY BE
THE ONES YOU'RE FROM THEY CAN G.
H. ALL THE T. JUST- I COULD STEP
OUT OF THE SYSTEM. TO SEE TO
LEVEL EXCEED SAFE LEVELS ARE
APPROPRIATE WE GET THAT SO WE
WOULD URGE AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THAT THE CHAIR MEMBERS TOM
MENZEL ALSO REPRESENTING WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL AND THAT ARE IN
THE PIPE TRADE TALK BUT ALSO
HERE ON BEHALF OF IT THEIR
INTERNATIONAL ASSOCIATION.
PLUMBING AND- THE FISHEL. TWENTY
TWO IS AN IMPORTANT STEP TO
ENSURING THAT OUR SCHOOLS HAVE
EXPECTS SYSTEMS THAT ARE ENERGY
EFFICIENT AND THAT PROVIDE
STUDENTS AND TEACHERS VENTILATE
. A RECENT STUDY PUBLISHED ALL
LAST MONTH BUT- ITALY SHOWS THAT
VENTILATION CAN CUT CORPORATE
CASES BY 82% AND CLASSROOMS NOT
EVERY TRANS. FROM ASKS PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS IT'S THAT CRITICAL
THE TEACHERS AT LEAST HAVE THE
PROTECTION PROVIDED. THANKS
INSTEAD OF THE PROTECTION
PROVIDER BY PROPERLY OPERATING
VENTILATION SYSTEMS. TOTAL EIGHT
CURRENTLY ANNUAL INSPECTIONS FOR
BUILDINGS OF EXPECTS SYSTEMS BUT
IT DOESN'T PROVIDE ANY GUIDANCE
AND WHAT'S- WE DIDN'T INSPECTION
AND DOESN'T. SPECIFIC TESTING
REQUIREMENTS OR WHO-
QUALIFICATIONS WHO DOES THE
TESTING- SIXTY TWO POINT ONE IS
A NATIONAL INDUSTRY STANDARD
THAT SETS FORTH IT SYSTEM.
PRINCE QUIT RECOMMENDS NOT JUST
ANYONE INSPECTIONS BUT EVERY
FIVE YEARS A COMPREHENSIVE
INSPECTION VERIFICATION AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS HI THERE THIS
BILL REQUIRES THAT'S FOURTH
MENTAL HEALTH. DO IT. PLEASE
ENTER INSPECTION UP TO THIS
USING THE CURRENT STAFF FOR OVER
THESE CURRENTLY DO IT BUT ONCE
EVERY FIVE YEARS WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE IT'S DONE. WE ARE. WAS MADE
. YOUR ME. IN BOTH THE A
FACTIONS AND THAT FIVE YEAR
INSPECTION SECURE THE COAL MINE
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
KNOW THAT WHEN- A. A. B. IT'S
NOT PUT UP WITH PERFORMANCE THE
STUDIES SHOWING ADEQUATE CLAY
AND BEFORE BY THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
SO THAT THIS HAS. SIX THE BOARD
INCIDENT. COOL ACTUALLY PROVIDE
THE VENTILATION AT THE STATE AND
TEACHERS NEED THANK YOU TAKE YOU
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND HEARING. NONE T. MODERATOR
IF THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
TWO. THE FOR. IF YOU ARE A
SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. ONE MOMENT THERE WE GO ONE
QUEUING UP ANYBODY ELSE GOING AT
ONE FELL BY ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. FOR EIGHT HE- TWO
THIRTY TWO.
THE SERVER BODY ELSE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT. BEAR WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE. GOT
A QUESTION. I WOULD LIKE TO
EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE JEREMY YOU'RE A
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
SUPPORT. KNOW WHETHER
PARTICIPANTS ACUTE MISTER CHAIR
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN
THE HEARING ROOM. AN EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR IF THERE ARE ANY WITH
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTY TWO ON THE
FRONT LINES. OF IF YOU ARE NOT
POSITION SB TWENTY TO THIRTY TO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ONE FELL
BY ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
QUEUEING UP.
SHOULD BE WITH US MOMENTARILY
ARE WITH AN OPERATOR. ACTUALS
YEAH AND WE WILL GO- I TWO
EIGHTY EIGHT YOU ARE OPEN TO
EIGHTY EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS RON REYNOLDS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATE OF- WILL
ORGANIZATIONS. OUR ASSOCIATION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES AB TWENTY
TWO THIRTY TWO UNLESS IT'S
AMENDED SO AS TO REMOVE THE
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY SCHOOLS
. ASIAN THANK YOU. THE FINAL
REMINDER PRESS ONE ZERO IF YOU
ARE NOT POSITIONED AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY TWO AND WE WILL GO TO
NINETY POINT YOU ARE OPEN. TONY
ON BEHALF. THE TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWO TWO THREE TWO THANK YOU.
NOBODY ELSE IS QUEUED UP MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU ANY TWEETERS ON
A B. TWENTY TWO THIRTY TWO AND
THE HEARING OR- OKAY INSTEAD.
THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ARE BOARD STILL NEEDS TO TAKE A
FORMAL VOTE BUT WE ARE
CONCEPTUALLY IN SUPPORT. YOU
EIGHTEEN PETER IF THERE ANY
TWEETERS ON THE PHONE LINE. YOUR
CLEANER TO AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
NOT AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
CHOI. YEAH THANK YOU CHAIR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF MCCARTHY I
THINK I UNDERSTAND DO YOUR
INTENT THIS UP TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT AIR QUALITY IN SCHOOL LAST
I'M SO. BUT THAT THERE IS A AS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
. COOL SO OFTEN AS A SHERMAN IS-
RAISING THE QUESTION WHICH I AM
ALSO CONCERNED- THAT IS- WHAT
YOU'RE A RECENT THINGS- ARE FOR
MAKING PRIVATE THE ELEMENTARY
AND SECONDARY. SCHOOL BOARDS TO
SUBJECT TO A COMPLIANCE SO WITH
THIS IS A PROVISIONS- NO MATTER
HOW GREAT YES C. A. CALL. BUT IF
PLEASE EXACTING PROFIT THE IS.
SO OFTEN HEIAU EDUCATION. RIGHT
THE DECISION YEAH EXISTENCE. YES
THANK YOU WE- WELL YOUR OVERALL
QUESTION I THINK IS RELATED TO
ALL PRIVATE SCHOOLS AND THE
EXCEPT READ OUR UNIVERSITY
COLLEGES- IN THAT LAST TWO. THIS
ARGUMENT WELL WELL THERE QUALITY
IN THAT WORST DAY IN THE WORLD
TWO YEARS AGO JUST AS BAD FOR
YOU KNOW THEY MICHAEL WAS IT WAS
TO NOT GO CROSS. OTHER SCHOOL IN
THE SAME BLOCK. CAN WE DO IT ALL
. RELATED TO THE PUBLIC WELL
WELFARE RELAY TO OUR SCHOOL SO I
THOUGHT THAT IT WASN'T
APPROPRIATE TO TWO DIFFERENT
SHAPE HOWEVER I THINK FOR THE OF
THIS YEAR CITY THAT THE DRUG
ISSUE FOR MANY. WHERE A DRESSING
THAT RELATE TO. BECAUSE OF THE
CIVIC CENTER HERE. IF I JUST
MIGHT ADD. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
CURRENTLY TITLE EIGHT THAT HAS
CURRENTLY REQUIREMENTS REGARDING
VENTILATION SYSTEMS AN H. BACK
AND HOW OFTEN THEY NEED TO BE
INSPECTED. APPLIES TO ALL.
SCHOOLS BOTH PRIVATE AND PUBLIC
SILVERY WERE INCREASING THE
STANDARD IT JUST IT JUST MADE
SENSE TO CONTINUE AND APPLY THAT
STANDARD AS IT DOES TO. TO ALL
SCHOOLS. AND MY SECOND QUESTION
IS- YOU WILL BE A LOT HOW ARE
YOUR STANDARD DAHLE. A
DIFFERENCE WILL BE UP BETWEEN TO
MY TO MY UNDERSTANDING. LOCAL.
AUTHORITY SELECTED CITIES AND
COUNTIES THEY DO HAVE- BUILDING-
SPECS AND- REQUIREMENTS. AND
JUST LIKE THE MAINTAINING
ELEVATORS. AND SO- YOUR BILL IS-
TRYING TO MAKE UP A SOMETHING
THAT IS NOT THE COVER THE BY NOT
LOCAL LAW. AUTHORITIES STANDARDS
. YES IT'S A MEMBERS SO THE-
TITLE LATE IS A STATE WIDE
STANDARD IT'S THE LOCALS DON'T
HAVE SEPARATE STANDARDS
REGARDING THE- TITLE EIGHT. THE
PROBLEM WITH LATE IN REFERENCE
TO VENTILATION STANDARDS IS IT A
RIG IT REQUIRES THEM TO BE
INSPECTED.
DO YOU FEAR WITH THOSE ONCE THE
YEAR INSPECTIONS BUT FOLLOW WHAT
IS THE NATIONAL STANDARD THE
ASHTRAY DANDER. IT THAT AT LEAST
ONCE EVERY FIVE YEARS YOU NEED A
MORE IN DEPTH INSPECTION. THAT
IS MORE DETAILED- AND DID THAT
IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT NOW THAT
WE LIVE IN THE AIR OF COVE IT
AND OBVIOUSLY WHEN TITLE. IT IS
CURRENT FORM WAS ADOPTED IT WAS
EASY YOU KNOW YEARS BEFORE WE
HAD A COVERT PANDEMIC. SO THIS
BILL APPOINTED BY ITSELF WHAT
THOUGHT MORE. OF ONE THE
INSPECTION ORDER FOR IN NUMBERS
. IT DOESN'T IN WE HAVE A
TECHNICAL EXPERT WHO CAN
DESCRIBE BUT THE ASH THE
NATIONAL ASH'ARI STANDARDS FOR A
FIVE YEAR INSPECTION WHICH IS A
MORE COMPREHENSIVE INSPECTION
DELINEATES PRESCRIPTIVE. EXACTLY
WHAT YOU LOOKED AT HOW IT USED
TO BE TESTED AND WHAT THE
ACCEPTABLE LEVELS ARE. IN PLACE
TO STE. IF AFFECTED IS. GO OFF
OF THAT. YOU KNOW THE- CODES
THAT APPLIES TO YOU KNOW NEW
CONSTRUCTION AND- H. FAQ
INSTALLATION AND ACTIVATION
RATES IS TOTAL TWENTY FOUR THE
TOTAL TWENTY FOUR ONLY APPLIES
WHEN YOU TO NEW CONSTRUCTION
THEY DO MAJOR MODIFICATION
ALTERATIONS DOESN'T APPLY TO
EXISTING CLASS. INTO REHAB. THE
WORD PROP. REALLY IT'S TAKEN LOT
OF THE TITLE TWENTY FOUR
REQUIREMENTS BUT SAY FOR EXAMPLE
THE REQUIREMENT HAS FOR V. FIVE
YEARS REQUIRES YOU TO DO SOME
OTHER PREVENT ACCEPTANCE TESTING
ARE THAT YOU HAVE TO DO WHEN YOU
DO NEW CONSTRUCTION TO MAKE
TODAY TECHSYSTEMS WORK. WHEN IS
. BOB SO FORTH IN THE FORWARD
THIS IS NOW ARE YOU FIVE YEARS
YOU'RE GONNA REDO THAT BECAUSE
WE KNOW SOME YOU KNOW WITHIN
THREE YEARS MOST OF THE SYSTEMS
ARE WORKING CORRECTLY AND OUR
ARMED PROFICIENTLY AND PROVIDING
EVERYTHING ONCE EVERY FIVE YEARS
WANT TO MAKE SURE THEY DO IT
RIGHT THEY COULD DO THIS EVERY
YEAR IF THEY WANT. SPECS BUT
WHERE. TO THE SCHOOLS OF THE
CURRENTLY IS- YOU KNOW THE
BETTER THING WOULD BE FOR THEM
TO DO IT EVERY YEAR BUT WE JUST
REQUIREMENTS EVERY FIVE YEARS.
OKAY YOU'RE A GENERAL ANSWER-
DESCRIBE SOME MORE GENERAL OR A-
QUALITY- IS INSPECTION READY-
THE H. BACK. BUT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF A MCCARTY- DECLINE
EXAMPLE OF LIKE DURING THE
WILDFIRE- PERIOD DOES THAT THE
REGION LACK OF SACRAMENTO HAD
THE- WHAT DID YOU DESCRIBE IS
THE WORST- EQUALITY IN THE WORLD
TO DURING THAT PERIOD. WHEN I
WANT MY AGE FACT THAT ACTUALLY
CAN ELIMINATE THAT THAT CAN THAT
KIND OF BOOK A SMALL-
INFILTRATION- AND THE QUALITY OF
THAT THE WE ARE LOOKING FOR WHEN
EVERYTHING IS SO IMPACTED THAT
DOES SO REALLY AIRCONDITIONING
SCREEN NOT THAT OF A SMALL. YES
SIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF PRINCES
WHEN THE CARBON MONOXIDE
INDICATOR IN THE CLASSROOM OR IN
ANY BUILDING. INDICATES AN
UNSAFE LEVEL OF WITH WITH OVER
TWO THOUSAND PARTS PER MILLION
OF CO TWO. AT THAT POINT A
TRAINED TECHNICIAN CAN COME IN
AND IT JUST THE VENTILATION
SYSTEM REPLACE FILTERS TAKE
SEVERAL DIFFERENT- ACTIONS TO
ADJUST THE SYSTEM THE AIRFLOW SO
THAT THEY CAN THEN MITIGATE-
THAT HIGH LEVEL OF CARBON
MONOXIDE THAT'S THAT'S- WHAT
THIS. IF YOU HAVE. AND MANAGED
SYSTEM JUST LIKE IN THIS
BUILDING. AND REQUIREMENTS
PROVIDE FOR THAT YOU'RE GONNA
PUT IN THE HIGHEST FILTRATION
THAT'S POSSIBLE THAT SYSTEM CAN
HANDLE MARC THIRTEEN AND THAT
PROSTRATION IS WHAT PROTECTS YOU
FROM NOW THE SMOKE OUTSIDE HERE
OR FINING AND THEY GO BACK IN
SOME OF THE SCHOOLS. THE FILTERS
AND EVEN THEIR- ANNOUNCER THIS
AND MAKING SURE YOUR TEST AT.
CAN MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING'S IN PLACE THAT SO
WHEN THESE THINGS HAPPEN YOU
READY FOR. SO THIS KIND OF
UPGRADED- IS SYSTEM FOR THE
WELFARE OF OUR STUDENTS- BECAUSE
TO THIS OUR ADDRESS TO FOUR
SCHOOLS SO. IF WITH THIS PAST IS
SO ORDERED THAT THE NEXT STEP
WOULD BE ALL THE EVEN- A
RESIDENTIAL HOMES AS WELL
ALREADY REQUIRED ALREADY
EXISTING LAW ALREADY REQUIRES
FOR APARTMENT COMPLEXES OR
EIGHT. THE AS A LOT. TO STALL A
CO TWO MONITORS BUT YET WE DON'T
REQUIRE THAT OF OUR CLASSROOMS
TO PROTECT OUR TEACHERS AND OUR
STUDENTS. THAT'S A SOUL MORE OF
A- THE PUBLIC- LOOKED APARTMENTS
SAID THAT THAT THEY HAVE TO BE I
THAT I HAVE A SINGLE FAMILY HOME
RENTAL THAT WE'RE GETTING READY
TO RENTS RIGHT NOW AND TONIGHT
I'M GONNA BE THERE IT'S-
INSTALLING CO TWO MONITORS
BECAUSE IT REQUIRED UNDER
CALIFORNIA I IDEOLOGY IT ALONE-
SEO TOOL MONEY THERESA REQUIRED.
FOR EVERY OUT WHEN THE SO EVEN
EVEN ARGUMENT. SET. BUT NOW-
NORTH IS SO GOOD AND ADD THE- IN
ORDER. TO ROUTE TO MUCH ENEL.
INVASION INTO. IN ALL PRIVATE
LIFE IT'S AN ALL I'LL IF WHAT
YOU ADVOCATE. THEN I WOULD TAKE
CARE OF MYSELF ABOUT DAYS OF
PIED LAW REQUIRING AND- IF NOT
THEN THE WHAT KIND OF PENALTY
ARE YOU ASSESSING. MISS MCCARTY
YEAH- ITHINK THIS IS. THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT OUR PUBLIC GOOD
THIS IS ART IS THERE ARE THERE'S
OUR ASSETS ARE PUBLIC BUILDINGS
BUT ALSO THEIR ACT OUR ASSETS
ARE YOU OUR KIDS IN OUR
CLASSROOMS ARE COLLEGE STUDENTS
WE WANT THEM TO BE HEALTHY. AND
SUCCEED. BUT WE WANT TO KNOW IN
OUR CLASSROOMS IF THERE'S FAULTY
EQUIPMENT AND THEREFORE WE
SHOULD FIX ITBECAUSE THAT THE
LONGER YOU WAIT AS YOU KNOW- DID
HE TALK ABOUT ALL THE TIME IN
OUR COMMITTEE WITH DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE. LONG YOU WAIT THE
MORE COST TO FIX IT SO THIS
DOESN'T MANDATE YOU GO UP BY ALL
INTO EQUIPMENT H. UP. LAST ROOMS
ON CAMPUS WE HAVE DEFIED THE
NEED X. Y. D. C. YOUR KNOWLEDGE
ABOUT WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE AND
BY DOING SO HOPEFULLY YOU WOULD
DO THAT. AND YOU WOULD IMPROVE.
THE HEALTH DECISIONS FOR YOUR
STUDENTS AND THEN LASTLY. WE'RE
PUTTING MONEY LEFT AND RIGHT.
FOR INSTINCTIVE TO RETROFIT- ARE
HSE QUIT MANY CLASSROOMS ONE
BECAUSE- WE HAVE ONE TIME MONEY
WE HAD A BUNCH OF MONEY IN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOING THIS IT
WAS A POOR FOR KOBE. AND TO.
STOP AND LOWER ENERGY BILLS SO
THE NEED MORE YOU DO THIS THE
LOWER YOUR ENERGY COSTS WHICH
ARE TRYING TO ADDRESS THE ON THE
STATEWIDE LEVEL RELATE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE AS WELL SO.
THERE'S MULTIPLE BENEFITS HERE.
YEAH MY AMONG MANY. MY LAST
QUESTION I'M GONNA ASK IS THAT
PUBLIC. SCHOOL REDUCE OUR PUBLIC
THE- OUR FUNDS SO WE SUPPORT
THEM SO ANYTHING INFECTIOUS OF
REPLACEMENT UP WHILE HIS FAXES
STEM CELL HOW. WILL YOU- BE
WILLING TO WHAT DOES YOUR BILL
HAVE ANY PLANS TO- PROVIDE AID
THE NECESSARY FUNDING FOR THE
PRIVATE SCHOOLS AS WELL. WHAT
WHAT JUST JUST YOU THAT WE ARE
CLARIFYING TECHNICAL FIX FOR
COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES PRIVATE
SCHOOL WILL NOT BE IN THIS BILL.
BUT FOR THE PRIVATE K. TWELVE
SCHOOLS THIS IS NOT THIS
COMMITTEES OF EDUCATION MAY TWO
WEEKS AGO. THAT WAS A PROTEST WE
WANT THEM AND WE SAID NO BECAUSE
WE THOUGHT THAT THE HEALTH OF
THOSE KIDS ARE PARAMOUNT
REGARDLESS OF. SCHOOL THERE CAN
BE LITTLE SAME BLOCK ACROSS THE
STREET AND WHAT IT IS YOU KNOW
YOU SHOULD FOCUS ON THE TOTALITY
OF THE ENVIRONMENT FOR ASKING.
REPAIR THAT'S THAT'S NOT IN THIS
BILL TODAY- FACTORS MAKE ONE
CLARIFICATION IS THAT THIS BILL
DOESN'T MANDATE UPGRADES OF
SYSTEMS IT IS AN INSPECTION
REQUIREMENT AND A CO TWO
MONITORING REQUIREMENT- IT'S
THIRTY REQUIRED ACTIVE HERE TO
DO THE GOOD JOB THEY WILL. IN
FACT WHICH MAY. FIVE YOU REALLY
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THE SYSTEM
LETS MISSING BUT THERE'S NOTHING
IN HERETHAT MANDATES ANY
UPGRADES ARE IT SAYS TO. BETTER
PEOPLE KNOW WHICH THEY SHOULD
HAVE THE RIGHT TO KNOW THAT YOU
KNOW YOUR CLASSROOM DOESN'T HAVE
EFFECTIVELY TO WHETHER TEACHER.
ARE YOU A STUDENT. JUST SPECTRUM
. OKAY THANK THANK YOU. MCCARTY
LIKE TO CLOSE I THINK THIS BACK
AND FORTH WAS SUFFICIENT- AND- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE THANK
YOU THANK YOU- THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILLBOARD. AS IN
OURS HAS POINTED OUT I DID HAVE
CONCERNS- ON THE PRESCRIPTIVE
NATURE OF THE BILL. IN ITS
ABILITY TO TAKE AWAY LOCAL
CONTROL FROM THE SEGMENTS AND
FOR THAT REASON I HAD. DONE
RECOMMENDATION BUT WILL BE
VOTING IN FAVOR OF THE BILL THIS
AFTERNOON. SO COMMOTION BY MR
LOW. OF A SECOND. SECOND ON THE
BILL. AND MAYBE FOR A SECOND DR
. SECOND BY MISTER BLUE MADAM
SECRETARY BUTTE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
. MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI.
CHILENO ARAMBULA BLOOM BLOOM I
GABRIEL- WHEN IRWIN I KILEY
KILEY NO LEVINE. LEVINE I LO LO
I SANTIAGO BALLADARES. I AM
SEVENTEEN AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
TWO. WELL IT DOES NOT VOTING
WEBER WEBER I. SIX TO THE BILL
IS ON CALL WE WOULD LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND WE
WILL GO ON TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
ONE MISTER GIBSON A. B. TWENTY
THREE FIFTY NINE. WHENEVER YOU
ARE READY MISTER GIVES. THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL- TWENTY
THREE FIFTY NINE WHICH SEEKS TO
REINSTATE COMP COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISPERSANT- COMMISSION BEFORE I
BEGIN I WOULD LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY ACCEPT ALL ALL OF
CAN MAN MAN THE COMPANY CHIU
STAFF WORKING DILIGENTLY TO HELP
MAKE THIS. STAKEHOLDER
NEGOTIATIONS. I AM VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF TO THAT THESE
AMENDMENTS STATE THE FOLLOWING
ONE YEAR AFTER THE LAST PAYMENT
OF THE STATE'S LONE THE
PERSONNEL COMMISSION RESUMES ITS
INDEPENDENCE HELLO SECOND ALLOW
THE ALLOW FOR THE PERSONNEL
COMMISSION TO SERVE IN ADVISORY
CAPACITY TEMPORARILY AND REPORT
BACK TO THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
AND ADD AN ADDITIONAL
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURE THAT
REQUIRE THE DISH.
THE LOAN PAYMENTS WHEN COUNTY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LOSS OF ITS
ACCREDITATION IT BECAME THE
FIRST- PUBLIC COLLEGE IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY TO DO SO-
THE FIFTH THE OF FACULTY THE
CLEAR OF THE- CLASSIFIED STAFF
ADMINISTRATORS AND THE
LEGISLATURE WORK TOGETHER TO
BUILD A PATH BACK TO A CREDIT
XIN. SOLVENTS AND PATIENT LET'S
. I SUPPORT I SUPPORT THE HARD
WORK OF THE FACULTY AND
CLASSIFIED- STAFF OF COMPTON
COMMUNITY COLLEGE THAT LIES
WITHIN MY DISTRICT AND THEY
DESERVE THE RETURN OF THE
PERSONNEL- COMMISSIONS TO
CONTROL THE FIGHT- SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES PROVIDE THE BACKBONE.
OF EVERY OPERATE OF THE COLLEGE
DISTRICT- RANGING FROM
TRANSPORTATION TO SECURITY FOOD
SERVICES AND CLERICAL- THESE
EMPLOYEES- KEEP DISTRICT-
FUNCTIONING DAY AFTER DAY YEAR
AFTER YEAR I SUPPORT COME TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE I'M ITS
PRESIDENT DR KEITH CURRY WHO'S
IN THE AUDIENCE- AND HIT THE
MINISTER STAFF ACCORDING TO THE
MOST RECENT PIC MATT. COMPTON
COMMUNITY IT MAKES DIFFICULT
UNDERSCORE THE ARE. I ALONG WITH
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE LEGISLATURE
SPENT COUNTLESS HOURS AT BOTH OF
YEARS WORK TO ENSURE CALM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CONTINUES TO
THRIVE IN THIS REGARD JOINING ME
. RACHEL I CUSTOMER- IS THE
COMPTON CA COLLEGE FEDERATION OF
EMPLOYEES- MISTER MACKENZIE-
ALSOTO HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AS MR TRISTEN BROWN
FROM CALIFORNIA FACULTY. IT'S
JUST IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY I'M
TELLING I'M KIND. WE ARE CRAZY
OKAY. IT'S ONE OF THOSE DAYS
WE'LL GET THROUGH IT ALL RIGHT
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT THEN HUH I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
TRISTEN BROWN FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS A UNION
OF- EDUCATED OUTSIDE FASHION
ALSO. VERY THANKFUL FOR THE WORK
THAT THE COMMITTEE HAS DONE TO
HELP US BRING THIS BILL BEFORE
YOU TODAY. THEY HAVE EXCEPT
MINCED MISSED GIBSON IS AS LOW.
BOB THIS IS BEEN A LONG ROAD AND
IT WE STILL HAVE- SOME MORE
PATHWAY TO CLEAR BEFORE COPPING
COMES OUT. AS A PHOENIX TO
REALLYSHOWS HOW COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CAN BE RUN- AND I KNOW
THAT THERE ARE BIG GOALS AND
DREAMS FOR THE CAMPUS. AND WE
LOOK TO HELP EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY. I WILL TIME FOR OUR LOCAL
RESIDENTS ARE BEGINS IS ON THE
LINE. LET'S TALK ABOUT HOW
IMPORTANT HAVING A PHONE. OKAY
THEM WE JUST LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING RESTORED EVEN AS AN IT IS
. I TELL THEM. THEY'RE I
CONSTRUCTION ACT IN THE NEAR
FUTURE I DO REQUEST A AND VOTE
FOR YOU ON IT'S TO BE BACK IN IN
UNIVERSE SECOND YOU SO MUCH.
OTHER WITNESSES REPORT. ON THE
PHONE- MISTER MACKENZIE FOR THE
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR. THIS CALL
AT. THIS INCLUDES THAT HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME. WHEN IS IN SUPPORT
OF. TWENTY THREE FIFTY NINE.
YEAH HELLO MY NAME IS AMERICA
MACKENZIE ON THE PRESIDENT OF
THE COMPLICATED SORT OF REGIMEN
POLICE CLASSIFIED. BY LOCAL
THIRTY FORTY SIX DAY- FIRST I'D
LIKE TO THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF
FOR WORKING TOGETHER DILIGENTLY
ARE FACTORED BILL IN AN EFFORT
TO HELP US RECEIVE THE RESPECT
TO THE PROPER BUT. YOU KNOW THE
TO TROUBLE BAKER HAS A VERY READ
PARA WE ARE GRATEFUL THE
ASSISTANCE THAT THE STATE HAS
PROVIDED TO THE DISTRICT. SO
THAT WOULD MAKE CONTINUE ON OUR
MISSION. HOWEVER THE CLAPPER BY
WORKERS VOTED UNDER THE MERIT
SYSTEM THAT. EACH OF THE PERSON
THAT PERSONNEL COMMISSION HAVE
BEEN UNABLE TO EXERCISE THE
RIGHTS OF THE MERITS OF THE
MAGIC CAN CODE SEEMS TO. FOUR WE
HAVE. TO VOICE OUR CONCERNS.
HOLDING US AS WE READ OUR
INDEPENDENT. WE HAVE BEEN UNABLE
TO LEGALLY WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE FARM
CLASSIFICATION STUDIES TO MAKE
SURE THE RIGHT PEOPLE ARE DOING
THE RIGHT BURKE. AND GETTING A
COMPETITIVE PACKAGE. WELL TO
WORK COLLABORATIVELY
COLLABORATIVELY ON THE SALARY
STUDIES AND SURVEYS WHICH CAN
BRING NEW EMPLOYEES AT ALL AGES.
HOLDING BACK FOR YEARS A VERY
POPULAR WAY UP THE LADDER. AND
WE'RE ABLE TO HAVE THE DEFENDING
HIM HILLS A DISCIPLINARY ACTION
. THE BOTTOM LINE IS WHAT IS
THAT WHILE CLASS OF OUR WORKERS
WERE NOT THE CAUSE OF THE